the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
here we are in Central West Sand and
welcome to the U.S Juniors and Senior
chess championships here in St Louis
it's beautiful out here and we expect
wonderful games over the chessboard as
well let's go to the studio
the St Louis chess club is proud to
present the 2023 edition of three
tournaments in one junior girls juniors
and seniors featuring The Best of young
talent and talented veterans our
coverage from Saint Louis begins now
[Music]
hi I'm woman Grand Master Katarina name
Tova and I'm here with Grandmaster
Yasser sarawan Kate I can't believe it
this is the first time we're doing this
together so nice to have you in studio
I'm very happy here
a great Trio of tournaments we have
here absolutely absolutely hello
everyone and Welcome to our live
broadcast of the national championships
Thrills and Spills Galore are
guaranteed chills as well as we get
ready for the national championship
start with the girls tell us about the
roster of players Kate absolutely and
let's remember that the U.S Girls Junior
tournament is for girls under 20 years
old and first one here we have
international Master Kary Sayeed she's
three times girls General Champion she's
also the 2021 Women's Champion so he
asked her what do you think about this
welcome Carissa I know she's taking a
break from Stanford for the holidays but
look at number two yes Alice Lee she is
the youngest International Master elect
we have a girl to watch out for in this
tournament and plenty of really amazing
players we have Roo Yang Yan here
Rochelle Wu Zoe tank Iris small who is
the winner of 2020 all girls National
Championship welcome Iris then we have
Kelsey Gracie prasanna Rose Atwell and
Shreya mangalam a lot of different names
welcome to each and every one of you and
for the junior roster the juniors are
led by Brandon J Jacobson Grandmaster
who has a very good uh memories of Saint
Louis because just this year he won the
Saint Louis Swiss open tournament here
right so welcome here Brandon then we
have Grandmaster abimano Mishra Jason
Liang a lot of Grandmasters strong
players Andrew Hong Balaji dagupati
Justin Wang Kirk gazarian Arthur guo who
actually just got his last GM Norm so he
is going to be a grand master soon then
we have Josiah stirman and Arthur Zoo a
lot of new names and again welcome to
all of those new roosters yes and he
asked her Duty honors for the singers
roster with the pleasure it's a real
reunion for me Vladimir copian is our
number one Auntie Gregory kaidana Igor
novika Patrick Wolff Maxim delugie are
returning Champion Alex shibalov Joel
Benjamin Douglas root Malik said Kerry
Chan and Dima we call them Dimitri
gurvich welcome to each and every one of
you and tell us about the format for
these three tournaments yes so we have
three 10 player around Robbins the time
control is 90 minutes for first 40 moves
followed by 30 minutes for the rest of
the game and there is 30 second
increment from move one important to
know is that there are no draw offers
allowed players have to battle it out on
the board and the point system is very
traditional players get one point for
win half a point for a draw and zero
points for a loss and tell us about the
schedule of the events schedule is also
very simple we start every day at 1pm
Center time and today we have round one
July 15 and we go one round a day until
July 19 and then we have a rest day all
players have a rest day on July 20 and
we continue with round six July 21st
until around 9 on July 24th and if
necessary we will have playoffs on
Tuesday July 25th on that rest day we'll
be celebrating the anniversary of the
chess club actually it's Monday July
17th is the actual
15th anniversary but we'll have a party
here on the rest day as the club
celebrates its 15th party oh wow it
happened so quickly and we're very very
fortunate to have in studio our good
friend Christian who I'm telling you we
lost you to Europe there it felt like
months Christian welcome back to St
Louis thank you guys it's uh finally
great to be back in the studio in St
Louis I missed all of you but I have to
say those two and a half months in
Europe passed so quickly because we had
so many exciting events uh we did
commentary on the games all the best
chess players on the planet but right
now we have the best Juniors and the
best seniors in the United States
battling for these coveted titles and
let's take a look at the highlighted
players as we begin round one in the
junior section I have to say this is the
player I'm looking at it's abimanu
Mishra the youngest Grand Master in the
world ever at only 12 years of age and
four months he broke a lot of records
that year I think it was 2021 when he
became the youngest Grand Master ever
he's also right now the highest rated 14
year old on the planet and take a look
at that that's a look of a focused man
right there and he wants to win this one
because last year he didn't have a good
tournament let's take a look at what's
happening in the junior girls section
you guys highlighted Carissa I will
highlight feeder Master Alice Lee she's
just an incredible player and it feels
like we've been commenting her games for
so many years but she's only 13 years of
age just an incredibly experienced young
lady Invitational rating 24 38
three-time World youth champion and
she's also she just became the highest
ranked under 21 girl in the nation just
an incredible young lady and yes sir you
are always impressed by her podcast as
well her show on a chesskid.com so just
an incredible young lady and what's
happening in the seniors section well
yes sir you know all of these players
but one in particular I have to say that
I've been making a lot of ways is a
grand master Alexander shabalo 55 years
of age Invitational rating 25 44 2022
U.S Senior chess champion he is the
defending champion and we know how
resilient he is we've seen that in a
five-way tie breaking last year he's
also four-time National Champion
yesterday you must have played against
Shabbat so many times what would you say
is his biggest strength well I well
first of all yes and thank you for
highlighting those players as we get
ready for this round it was Alice's Palm
Palace by the way she's got her own uh
show a streaming show it's 13 years old
streaming I mean what the heck uh Here
We Are the World Chess Hall of Fame uh
just across the street from our chess
club as the players are getting ready
they've had to come in and got wanded
and do all of those things but as we get
ready for the round uh Kate please do
the honors and tell us about the
pairings let's start with the girls yes
let's take a look we have some amazing
battles ahead in round one we have Yan
playing against Atwell Lee against
prasanna tank against mangalam Wu
against Mo and Liu against Yip and in
the junior section the parents
let's take a look honk is going to be
playing with wank Liang against Jacobson
gazarian against tyrman Mishra against
Goa and Zhu against dagupati and finally
the Legends let's take a look how the
seniors are going to be fighting the
first round we have Benjamin against
loogievic against navikov katyan against
akopian rude facing shabalov and
kaidanov against wolf and let's go back
to the playing Hall and get a taste the
flavor of the hall there I know the
Arbiters of women working very hard
as we hit listen to Chris bird giving
the instructions
certainly make that happen if
anything
I'm still listening to instructions
I have to say guys those are playing
holes in the World Chess Hall of Fame
they look pretty funny incredible place
to play chess exactly and in fact
they're uh with the 15 tables
the two those two tournaments the
Juniors and girls who were in one room
this is the other room this is where the
seniors uh are playing also on the third
floor of the World Chess Hall of Fame as
the games get started and underway
just so nice these national
championships you get the butterflies
out of the tummy at the start of the
tournament and again the Arbiters uh
really you know they go making sure that
you know the fair play and everything is
just completely completely assured well
I'm wondering yes where are you going to
put your boots on and get going you know
you you want me you you you'd asked me
to leave this wonderful air-conditioned
Studio or where I work with hard
with my colleagues yes I can tell you I
suffer I play there the American Gap and
it's such a great feeling to be playing
on these amazing boards you see the dgt
set and then you see all the plaques of
inductees World Chess Hall of Fame or
U.S hall of fame it's just an incredible
feeling to play in this this amazing
atmosphere I I I totally agree I I love
the sets I think these are really really
professional sets the Furnishings uh
even just you know the the green felt
for the elbows you know the little
cushion uh that you have there let's
jump into the games let's start with the
ladies I've got uh Carissa yep's game in
front of me Chris is playing the black
pieces uh today
and as she's playing an open Sicilian uh
for nights and then we have Queen D3
okay I'm much more familiar with the
traditional f2f4 Queen D3 uh one of
those moves that Intimates that the
queen could also slide across to G3
after either a trade you'd like to see
the Knight kick you because then the
queen would end up on G3 and you get
your F4 with Tempo but the moon Queen D3
from BK is quite unusual I have to admit
I I'm seeing it for uh for the first
time I believe and it looks like Carissa
is also maybe a little bit surprised by
this move
I don't know if that was the the move or
if it was my uh
already yeah she played Bishop East Side
I don't think she would play 99 95 is
kind of one of those moves the when you
play it it feels good you win a Tempo
but then when you see the resulting
position Queen G3
this night we'll get into trouble don't
you attack the queen but why did I do it
why did I do it Bishop E7 I would expect
the follow-up
to be castles long and it's not that
you're eager to capture capture to take
this Pond or something like that it's
just you want to tuck your king Away
Your Castle play King B1 and figure out
where black is going
um Christian the move Queen D3 maybe
it's not the most popular but oh it's
definitely a trendy move a trending a
very very trendy move and the idea is
very simple if you put the queen on D2
for example which is by far the most
played move in the position very often
you will get this type of ideas with
Bishop E7 castle and then at some point
maybe after a castle but maybe even
immediately black is going to play the
move H6 and the problem is if you do go
Bishop to H4 I have very often ideas of
Knight takes E4 attacking the queen on
D2 with the queen on D3 that's not
possible so this is one of the slight
wrinkles in this position uh that um
makes Queen to D3 a viable option Queen
to D3 makes a lot of sense queen of
Bishop E7 is what we have right now
Castle is already on the board and you
are mentioning is not very popular it is
extremely trendy a lot of top level
players are are playing this position
sutowski has played it husenbet has
played it uh and a lot more others so
definitely an interesting idea
um by um Kelsey Liu we'll see whether
she will be able and she will know how
to follow through with this opening
surprise if you might call it all right
well thank you for that I'm just going
through some of the games and one game
also that kind of caught my eye was this
game of Rochelle Rochelle woo now look
at these phones I know exactly beautiful
it's like how did how did we get like
Five Palms up the board like that okay
it started Queen's uh Queen Pawn opening
and then it was a bishop B4 check
okay not Knight C3 transposes into a
nimzo Indian Knight D2 all very uh
standard castles A3 Bishop E4 D6 so far
so good
Bishop E2 Knight
it's a that's a strange looking move
Knight on F6 so a piece that's already
developed you Retreat to D7 and then B4
so you get all of these Pawns of rest of
one another here
E5 D5
so now we're it looks like a king's
Indian but it's not because the bishop
isn't on the G7 square and and then in
another game it is a Kings Indian with
the bishop on the G7 screen so that was
like I was you know getting thrown off
by the the different defenses there by
the players as like who's playing a
king's Indian and how did how come the
Bishops on E7 Bishop on B2 what's your
first uh take on this uh okay you know
black maybe wanted to move the Knight to
D7 so in the future we can have some
like F5 or exactly we don't have to
worry about the pawn of white Pawn going
to E5 and I like that the other night is
gonna probably like to go to A6 okay to
really Target the opponent before and
then maybe jump on C5 if you can ever
invoke B5 yeah Knight C5 is ideal yeah
but it's going to be tough because also
we have to be careful about the pin on
the a file the Rooks kind of we cannot
really trade and then go there with the
Knight right so for example if you
started with the move Knight A6 and I
castled because of the pin as you were
mentioning on the a-file the pawn isn't
hanging that's the whole problem you
can't or do that but on that note you
might want to in this position take care
of that right you might want to capture
capture capture I suppose I should
capture the queen or the bishop I'm not
sure but now Knight A6 well now you are
threatening to to gobble the pawn
um still the bishop on C8 how did we
feel about that I'm not feeling I'm not
feeling happy about it it just struck me
as a very strange decision to play
Knight G8 to F6 to D7 and to go around
uh the horn like that when you you when
you've got this night still stuck on B8
but uh I'm gonna just give ourselves a
pause and throw it over to Christian and
say uh Christian will caught your eye of
the three tournaments of far I'm looking
at the Juniors section we see some
catalans being deployed and this game
between Kirk Kazarian and Josiah sermon
is quite interesting because we have a
sideline of the Catalan castle castle D
takes E4 this is all very known and by
far the most played move in this
position is the move A6 A6 usually white
continues with A4 Bishop to D7 and I'm
sure we've seen this type of positions
so many times Bishop to G5 or Bishop to
F4 Bishop D5 Knight D7 this is the main
line at the topic of the position if you
might but Josiah chose a different idea
with this move C6 quite intriguing and
you have to be very precise after that
because after Queen takes C4 which was
played B5 Queen to C2 this is what we
have if black doesn't get the
Breakthrough with the move C5 and white
manages somehow to solidify the position
for example Bishop to D7 Rook to D1 this
is what we have on the board right now
Knight bd7 and Knight to E5 this is the
current position you need to be able to
get your C5 in if you don't do that then
you might end up in trouble now the
thing is Knight to E5 is a very very
direct idea because you no longer have
ideas of let's say queen to B6 first of
all because you're just losing the pawn
maybe after Bishop takes C6 maybe after
Knight takes C6 is just not the right
position
um after Knight to E5 of course if you
play the move Knight to C3 for example
then I can go Queen to B6 and this is
why the Rook is on D1 you cannot play C5
first not only that you're losing the
pawn on B5 but also after C5 and I take
with the Rook on D1 and the Queen on d8
this is not ideal for black that's why
you have to get the queen out of the way
with Queen to B6 or queen to a five but
Knight to E5 by the way Corker gazerian
is playing very fast despite the fact
that the C6 move is more of a sideline
he was ready for it it seems like
because area so he's coming into this
tournament very well prepared and you
can see you can feel the confidence in
his eyes because he knows exactly what
he's doing right now let's see whether
Josiah can answer with the same type of
vigor in his moves uh the move 95
Christian if you just pursue the
position for just a moment Knight takes
E5 that's the right move yes he takes E5
and you kind of have to play Knight
takes C5 D takes C5 and now Knight to D5
don't go Knight D7 that's too passive
right to D7 I'm just simply going to go
Knight to C3 I'm going to follow that
with first of all I have a big threat
Knight takes B5 and it's a bit awkward
to defend against it right you would
love to defend against it with Queen to
B6 for example the problem is you're
losing a piece and that's why the Rook
is on D1 right Queen to C7 and doesn't
stop it right it takes B5 and it's even
worse so you have a bit of an awkward
position you have to lose some tempies
maybe A6 maybe Rook to B8 is just not
the type of position that you want to
see and right now I have ideas of Knight
to E4 Knight D6 it's ugly this is not
looking good for black so you need to
centralize the Knight and it's kind of
forced
Knight to D5 E4 works but I have Knight
to B4 and I'm more or less saving my
piece otherwise I would be losing a
piece but after Knight to B4 Queen to E2
Queen to C7 and by the way still a lot
of games have been played a bit more
games a bit older games and I have a
feeling I'm not recognizing any of the
names I have a feeling these are
correspondence games so
um a very engine Reliant opening chosen
by Josiah this idea with C6 and very
very nicely answered I have to say in a
very direct manner by gazaria
all right thank you for that uh by the
way I'd like to test you uh Christian on
this game of Alice Lee because
um where this is the King's Indian game
that I had referenced a moment ago and
trying to compare it with the Rochelle
game for a moment so Alice
on the black site right no pardon me
Alice is his wife yes uh it's this
um
I think it's called the gligarich system
of the king's Indian with Bishop E3 as
fetusar gligerich the grand old man of
yugosoft Chess Bishop E3 Knight G4 uh
Bishop G5 F6 2 major major uh mines here
Bishop H4 or Bishop C1 Bishop C1 was
chosen by Alice and now the move a7a5 uh
I would say that's off the beaten path
that's a very strange movie yes very
strange tell me about that one not
approved by not approved or a silicon
friend either
um no A5 doesn't make a lot of sense
you're not playing on that side that's
where white is going to try to play with
B4 exactly what you have to do is play
F5 exactly you're trying to attack on
the king side right that's right so this
is the main line F5 yeah A5 I think it
was played only a few times
uh but I do see Alice quickly play D5
Knight E7 best move yes and now here's
the thing the Knight on F3 wants to move
and it is a Tempo but uh
should you be playing Knight G5 or you
can certainly play Knight G5 not only
that but after Knight G5 white seems to
have a very significant Edge
close to decisive Advantage guys I
wanted to ask that because I'm I really
do want to play Knight E6 but beyond
that I I really want to play Bishop take
so if you go Knight H6 and I go 96 the
problem is this
uh
I don't even know what to call it uh
criminal this Criminal on East not so
easy to get arrested well if you go
Queen C8 I go 95. precisely Knight D5
and you know you're not taking attacking
exactly and it's such a disruptive uh
Pawn on E6 you can't just allow me to
play you know all of these nice moves
Bishop so I'm looking at this position
for Alice and I was thinking Knight G5
no it's really really bad for it for uh
Gracie just right out of the open yes
yes no and surprisingly I don't think
she studied this game but there was a
big game between cortional and Polgar
and this particular line or Judith yes
yeah okay Judith pogar in 1993 and of
course you know in that game played the
move Knight to E1 so he didn't play
Knight to G5 but Knight to E1 is decent
as well but it just doesn't have the
same impact as Knight G5 Knight G5 is
really strong right now right I think
it's a good mention that the the move A5
I mean it has a point right black is
trying to stop kind of all the white
pawns landing on the queen side because
if white gets B4 it it looks a little
bit annoying for black that there's like
this Avalanche of Pawns so black is
trying to stop it with A5 to delay it
the problem is it's too slow like should
start first attacking on the king side
yeah and the move Knight on F6 to G4 was
designed like if you're in this position
is excuse me if you're in this position
as black you would like as black in this
position to play F7 F5 the problem is
it's illegal you got to get your knight
out of the way now that the night is out
of the way you really want to follow it
up with F5 and that was why A5 just
caught me my and then the other point is
that with this Knight nicely hanging in
the air Knight G five finally I want to
make this a very important strategic
point if you take on F2
and I take on F2 and you take on G5
at the end of the day the problem is is
there's no attack on the king side for
black you have no F5 F4 so whether I
play Rook takes f8 first or I just start
with Bishop takes G5
and we get a position like this the
problem is this no attack there's just
no attack Queen D2 Rook F1
and uh White takes over the king side
the center but I think she played 91.
she did play coach noise
[Laughter]
uh Knight E1 and well here
uh again I'm I'm kind of pounding the
table for F6 F5
I mean yes you can play Knight H6 and uh
F5 but
get it going get it going it's an
interesting Bond structure if let's say
you play F5 yeah Bishop captures the
Knight okay we capture with the pawn yep
like in the future we can play Maybe
hcg5 Knight G6 I'm looking for Black's
perspective okay like what are we gonna
do with the pawn there
right we can get the Knight to G6 yeah
if you can ever sync the Knight to F4
you're a happy camper
um but again in this particular position
uh you can see where black is heading
black is heading King side and uh White
is heading uh Queen side in this case
the move A5 has actually worked out
decently in Black's favor in a sense
you're slowing me down I'm going to end
up having to play one two three not even
three because then I can take and take a
rook yes well I will I'm anticipating
I'll put my Bishop on E3 as well oops
excuse me that was a mouse slip but
Knight E1 on the board makes Knight H6
on the board by the way has already been
played so I'm expect I would expect
Knight to D3 and F2 F4 coming up let's
pause for just a second and obviously
the players are going to be fighting
they're going to be fighting hard for
the next nine rounds what are they
fighting for yeah let's talk about money
what is the price fund for U.S girls
junior so the first place stays home six
thousand dollars the second place four
thousand third place three thousand all
the way to the tenth place which will
take on 500 and tell us about the junior
prices yeah so juniors are fighting also
for a very generous price fund with the
first place taking twelve thousand
dollars second place eight thousand
third place five thousand all the way to
the tenth place of one thousand dollars
and they're of course bonus prizes for
both the girls yes as well as the
Juniors absolutely the winners of the
Juniors and junior girls will be awarded
a ten thousand dollar scholarship
generously jointly founded by the Dwayne
Barber foundation and U.S chess plus the
top finishers automatically qualify for
the US and U.S Women's Championship in
October now that's a big deal right
there that bonus of qualifying for the
Championships but Dwayne Barber many
many decades has been supporting uh
chess scholarships uh and uh we really
thank him big shout out to Dwayne and to
the United States Chess Federation for
their support and
we just lost the seniors what are the
senior
I mean My People my people and they have
a really big money to be fighting yeah
the first place the first place twenty
thousand dollars second place thirteen
thousand third place ten thousand all
the way to the ten place of three
thousand dollars nice and let's uh
introduce our audience to the plane Hall
it's a very expansive uh World Chess
Hall of Fame so you've got two
tournaments in this single room so we're
gonna have 15 boards in all five boards
for each tournament so uh you get this
walk through if you will and you see the
top talents the Juniors of the United
States fighting it and here now we are
walking to the seniors exactly veterans
to the room where the senior U.S
championships is happening and we just
caught cross through the area there it's
kind of a kitchenette area where the
where the players can get drinks and
snacks uh during the play and I have to
say it feels like we relegated the poor
seniors in the app
they're in the Attic this is actually
not the attic even though it's an attic
room it's actually a lecturer Hall and
they have some beautiful lectures there
oh they have a lot of privacy you know
they don't have to be bothered whenever
the games go into the intense those kids
man they're so loud they got the short
stick on this one the seniors have their
own very very comfortable space there
they they should be happy one thing that
I really like about the playing horror
Paul when I'm a player is you can walk
out of your chair and you can just walk
around and then you see your game on the
TVs around so you can still be like
looking at your game on those monitors
seeing what's happening uh and then you
can come back to your to your chair
actually knowing what you are going to
play because you already figure it out
there exactly and uh Christian
your attention well last year if I
remember correctly and we were
discussing this quite a lot at length
the juniors are very well prepared when
it comes to their theoretical knowledge
the seniors generally play a quieter
chess uh much more senior chess
but I have to say this game between ABI
Manu and Artur go is impressing me
because once again we have a Catalan our
tour came with a very very obscure idea
this bishop to D7 at move five I haven't
seen this move before but the way it was
played quite a few times but it's not
really played by a lot of very strong
players
Bishop obviously you usually have Bishop
to E7 that's one A6 Knight C6 C5 a lot
of options in the position but not
Bishop to D7 it doesn't feel right and
obviously the main idea is that after
Knight to E5 which seems to be the way
to go for white because you're trying to
get the light Square Bishop you're
trying to get that strategical advantage
of two Bishops Bishop to C6 and this
becomes very concrete because if white
manages to defend upon on D4 which he
does with the move E3 and then somehow
Corral this Pawn on C4 and take it uh
you're going to be in trouble you don't
have the light Square Bishop I have this
monster on G2 that doesn't have a
counterpart on this long diagonal so
strategically you're more or less busted
as black you have to do something very
quickly and this is exactly what R2 is
doing Rook to d8 and now this move E5
forcing the trade Knight takes C5 I
defended the pawn on C4 you cannot
capture that most likely after taking on
B7 that's probably bad after the move C6
and the computer agrees as well
you have to go once again continue going
for that pawn on C4 knight uh to uh D2
B5 defending that A4 and by the way
Arthur is not spending any time because
obviously he knows what he's doing he
probably analyzed but I'm wondering if
this is a semi Bluff this idea that he's
playing right now and ABI Manu is
responding with perfect play yeah both
playing very very quickly yes sir is
thinking a little bit so perhaps he's
just trying to remember his analysis but
once again we're already in novel
territory right now after Bishop to B4
take on B5 Queen takes B5 was the move
F4 everything is very concrete if you
lose one Tempe and you allow me to
Castle as black then I'm going to be
perfectly fine right so you have to go
for the aggressive approach with F4 take
the Knight away Queen takes C4 and now
very important to go Queen to C5 you
want to trade the Queens but you want to
trade them on your own terms if you take
on C4 then you allow my knight to get
into play now you have to get back to
defend the pawn on A7 and this just
gives me too much time so you cannot do
that Queen to C5 very good move and by
the way still blitzed out Bishop to C6
King to E7 and this is what we have
right now
the engine is saying 0.6 so quite a
significant Edge and that's why I asked
whether this is a bluff by Artur go
because look he blitzed everything up to
this point but right now the pawns are
equal I understand you have a beautiful
night on day three very very nicely uh
place there in the heart of White's
position but at the same time I do have
the two Bishops and if you do take on C1
at the wrong moment then I'm going to be
able to develop an attack on the C file
I'm going to get the Rook on C1 you're
going to have some problems with the
pawn on C7 so I still see some
strategical dangers for black I'm
concerned a little bit for Arthur he
probably thought that he's going to
surprise abimanu and maybe abhimanyu
will not find his way out but abhimani
knows what he's doing right now in this
obscure line
yeah obscure indeed but boy they are
playing it quickly just as you pointed
out well let's turn to our Legends and
get some old man chess shuffling I'll
teach you some old ninja look at this
game we've got this game between Dima
and Patrick Wolfe
and what do these seniors play of course
the night or something very aggressive
that's what they grew up with right and
uh Knight C3 and really when you think
about the night orphan how many
gosh generations of players over the
years and what they've done to try to
meet the Knight or Bobby Fischer played
Bishop C4 Bishop G5 became the rage for
so long Michael Tall
played F4 so many players have been
playing Rook G1 and G4 others didn't
know what to do including Magnus Carlson
playing Knight B3 and A4 and then you've
got the positional approaches with G3
and Bishop E2 and then at one time you
know the burn system or what became
known as the English attack was all the
rage F2 F3 and look at how play the soon
the position will resemble a
okay the move H7 H5 is designed to stop
G4 G5 in the near future so you just
take that option away
what is just developing wanting to
Castle a king exactly and uh the jump
Knight D5 that force is actually black
to give up the light squared Bishop but
he does it voluntarily because in his
Mind's Eye in the future he's got a
majority on the king side Central
majority towards the king side and he's
going to try to use that majority to
launch an attack on the king side uh
we're up to date with the players it
looks like Patrick is thinking and the
reason why he's thinking is because
there's a really intriguing strategic
idea here you've played the move H7 H5
and the idea behind that was to stop G4
now black could uh play the move excuse
me uh castles uh the move A5 and what's
the idea behind that well we see the
center and the queen side majority for
white so
in White's mind an ideal might be to
play Knight A5
followed by C4 followed by B4 followed
by C push forward
exactly remember you want to play in
your theater you want to play on the
side of the board where you have an
advantage in this case white hat whites
majority is on the queen side one two
three four
one two three so let's play on The Queen
side black wants to play on the king
side so one of the things black might
want to do is play A5 this stops Knight
A5 but crucial crucially it also slows
down this whole C4 so in the future
after you've castled you put your Pawn
on B6 you'll you try to hold white up
you play B6 and Knight C5 before
launching your own king-size attack
sometimes an ounce of prevention is
worth a pound of cure so Patrick
thinking over the move A5 if you want to
play castles I'm I'm down with that too
but you do allow white this possibility
of Knight E5 C4 and B4 yes sir how do
you feel about move B5 instead of castle
by the way instead of Castle always told
that you know if black moves the pawn
and you can actually get to the C6
square right with your knight and you
are super happy about your opponent D5
you just play Knight A5 you can kind of
have the Knight resting on C6 and that
should secure some kind of Advantage
well no question about it if you were
magically transport this Knight to C6
it's game over like it's just it's
strategically Overkill the one reason
why moves like B5 are on your agenda is
because you are thinking about Knight B6
and uh rounding up the pawn you know
with the move uh Knight takes D5 the
problem is oftentimes when you capture
this Pawn you're actually doing white
this great great favor white will put a
bishop on G5 a rook on D1 play C4 and
don't forget we have the two Bishops we
do have the two Bishops so when the game
does oops excuse me when the game does
open up you play a move like Knight B6
and Knight takes D5 uh
I win my Pawn back always assuming
very important to get your Pawn back but
assuming I do get my palm back and we
trade off the the D5 and D6 bombs I'll
have an advantage now again
uh let's just take a close-up look at
these players beginning with the legend
Gregory kaidana now uh Gregory
a long time member of the U.S Olympic
team but really has an outstanding
reputation reputation as a great trainer
it's very hard to find anybody under the
age of 30 in the United States that
hasn't gone to a Gregory I don't know
chess camp or been influenced by this
man
and he was the 2021 U.S Senior chess
champion and there he is and for Patrick
Wolff Patrick was former U.S Champion as
well 55 years young 1992 and 1995 was
for his title years wow yeah welcome
Patrick I believe communist Champion
yeah just I believe this is his first
senior so he's kind of returning to the
game you know he took time off to manage
a hedge fund in San Francisco area and
there you see him I feel we've seen him
before at the clock yeah and and I think
he's wearing a t-shirt from one of the
spring classic Invitational
I think he uh was playing in some of
those came back for some gme residents
uh spells and right now for the first
time I think he's in the seniors
competition exactly in this theoretical
position I know it's theoretical that
Patrick is studying uh castles B7 E6 A6
A5
I think those are the three what we
would call candidate moves uh moves that
we would be theoretically
approved which one is the most common
and that's why the engines are so
important and so used nowadays because
only one of them allows black to
maintain the balance really yes and that
is B6 B6 yes just if
you have to stop Knight wave five for
example if you uh go Castle yep then
you're just going to make things much
easier for me because I'm going to go
Knight A5 and now whenever you move the
B Pawn I'm going to jump to C6 that is
true that's a problem right you don't
want to have that Knight lurking around
your camp like that so what you want to
do is stop me from going Knight to five
and by the way if you uh after Knight A5
go Queen to C7 defend upon on B7 then
without with the Knight on A5 out of the
way I can just play C4 then B4 later on
it's much easier to push my pawns on
that side agree and we discussed this is
White's idea why it's plastic in the
position so what about A5 if I don't
want the Knight to jump to A5 I'm going
to push the pawn there yeah yes the
problem with A5 is that you're creating
some serious weaknesses and you're
creating some targets as well
specifically the spawn on A5 so I'm
going to stop you from going A4 I'm
going to go A4 myself
okay
what do you do now castle castle
and now I'm going to go Bishop Bishop B5
Bishop B5 yes yes
and now uh I'm not exactly sure should I
be putting my queen on C7 or should I be
playing let's say King H7 I don't know
whatever you do I'm going to go for
ideas of C3 and get the Knight out and
B4 or maybe even C4 but the big problem
with Black's position is that I don't
see a good way to get your attack going
yeah I need to if you go Knight takes
seven for example I think you're just
losing a pawn right Knight takes A5 or
Bishop takes D7 right and that's the
problem the knights are kind of stuck
they they you cannot move them that's
that's a big problem with allowing this
bishop to get to B5 I will have to play
B7 B6 we talked a moment about my having
a night sitting on C6 yeah I think I
could tolerate a bishop better than the
Knight you can you can definitely
tolerate the bishop the problem is right
now maybe I can start playing for uh a
king side or Santa
okay I mean that's the advantage of two
Bishops right we can do anywhere
anything and black is the one who's
gonna struggle very good point well by
the way I mean it just so happens that
we zoned in on this game Patrick Wolf is
really uh taking a good long think in
this position is he struggling to
understand the nuances between A5
castles and B6 and that's the thing it's
just about flexibility in the position
right right if you go B6 you're not
giving away this B5 Square for the
bishop exactly if you go A5 you
accomplish certain things but you are
giving away this B5 Square so it's all
about flexibility that that's that's a
very good theme and a very good point
that you made the answer and I think we
will go back to this game but what if we
jumping out to the game Dmitry gurevich
against Igor novikov because there is
this king who did not decide to Castle
all right let's see uh is the second one
second one
okay so it's a Murano uh variation
Bishop B7 castles all very standard
stuff C6 C5 takes takes takes check King
E7 Knight D4
so I understand if you don't move your
Kink and you block with the Knight there
is like Knight E5 coming yeah 97 90
which night blocks sorry I don't know
okay let's be the scene let's take the
C9 then we have this Knight C Knight to
uh this is an annoying pin how are we
going to ever uh get out of Dodge here
we could play A7 A6 but that's that's
Bishop we just maintained the PIN
I'm I'm not comfy here I'm not happy on
the other hand the move King E7
uh okay I I agree you know we lose the
right to Castle but if we trade queens
and get the Rook out it's not that big a
deal and maybe our King is actually a
little bit safe and if you move the
queen well I'll quickly try to move the
Rook out and
pretend like nothing happens all good
it's all good yeah yeah I'll put my king
right back on to the f8 square so the
question is
can white exploit this moment to to take
advantage of the King on E7 it doesn't
seem obvious to me how white is supposed
to do that because she can certainly how
he played the right move he did to be
60i he played A4 okay so hold on we we
do have uh some moves Knight D4 yes
queen queen B6 and now A4 A4 very good
move oh we want to push the pawn to A5
that's right
kick the queen away from B6 you don't
actually have a lot of good squares for
that Queen and then the pawn on B4 is
always going to be undefended correct so
now how how do you do things I I don't
think taking on A3 makes a lot of sense
no just because I open up
maybe even B4 I mean I'm not happy about
anything that allows the bishop to come
to A3 yeah yeah that doesn't happen no
I'm not happy about that so I'll leave
it there but I do agree A5 is going to
be very very disruptive right probably
the only move yeah so let's ask play A5
okay so now all right now it's time for
the first quiz for you guys what do you
do after
I mean it's not our Pawn we can give it
no I definitely want to get this bishop
into a play but should I do it uh the
the calm way fee and shadowing and play
b2b3 Bishop V2 forgettable or should I
be like zealous you should zealous let's
go let's be brave or and in fact this
gives white a decisive Advantage no
decisively decisive the engine is saying
plus one point actually no after E4 plus
three wow so what if I take the pawn
with f night well F9 is
Queen G4
it's it's slow right it's a slow cook
right now
maybe Queen G4 later in the game you
just don't have a way to improve your
position as black and at some point
something's going to give when I'm going
to put so much pressure on that Knight
on C5 it's all about the Knight on C5
it's all about the dark squares because
you don't have a counterpart you don't
have dark Square Bishop so you cannot
defend on dark dark squares you're in
trouble right now as black huge huge
trouble
and I think Dimitri understands that
he played A4 and by the way we've been
seeing this bishop land on B5 nicely
supported by that pawn on A4 in the
previous game of Patrick Wolfe as well
it's a very nice Square for that Bishop
on B5 wow
you know it's funny because it's one of
those positions where I I really would
not have thought it's so wickedly
uh dangerous I think you have to buy the
bullet and just play A6
allow A5 as
okay
and then hope that that pawn on B4 I'm
not going to get to it very quickly I
think you have to keep the queen on D6
well that's specific reason yeah
whenever you go Bishop D2 maybe I can
move the Knight away and defend the pawn
on B4
but you were hanging on by a threat
right I mean this is I mean black may
want to try to gamble just play A5 and I
mean what are the chances that white is
going to play E4 you think it's 100
Christian they're big they're big this
guy some people they're a little you
know stingy they're like maybe they
don't want to give the pawn I mean
that's not the best way to think but
they're good they're good and they have
absolutely nothing to lose they've seen
everything these are the seniors they've
done this type of sacrifices all
throughout their lives one of the things
about this move a7a5 I if I'm on the
white side and I am one of those stingy
players by the way
is I do like white because of the two
Bishops funnily enough I actually like
white for a slow reason that has very
little to do with immediate exploitation
of the dark squares with E4 the move
f2f3 I find personally very appealing
because I'm closing the diagonal but
really what I'm trying to do is I'm
trying to be very sneaky I'm trying to
go Queenie one Queen G3 right control
the E5 Square tickle the G7 pawn and
then on a good day play E4 version E3 so
slowly get in that whole E4 idea but F3
as well I wanted to pick up the game of
Alex shabalov our defending Champion for
a moment he is up against Douglas root a
newcomer to Saint Louis but very very
well known International Master Doug
root from Texas and Doug root is playing
one of these there's a name for it and
then it's completely
messing me up this attack where you fan
Shadow the bishop the bishop on B2
eyeballs the long diagonal the bishop on
D3 I evolves this day and you follow it
up with F2 F4 and it's the American
Pillsbury Pillsbury I really like they
said that's in Pillsbury Pillsbury
related also a few times yes I feel it's
so comfortable it just get the Bishops
out and you push the pawns you the
Bishops are so nicely eyeing on the king
side exactly exactly and you go and then
you get a rook lift uh later let's see
what happened a to A3 so the the this
pause sometimes you look across the
board and you say to yourself if I was
in my opponent's shoes what would I want
to do I would want to play night before
and snatch the bishop exactly so let me
pause my attack it's only temporary I
take away the B4 Square for just a
moment I play the move a2a3 Rook C8 F4
Knight E7 Queen E2 Knight F5 whoa Rook
D1 I was about to say I mean aren't we
at that moment where we go all in what
do you think you have to be careful
because I know this is one of the best
transfers for night I also lost so many
games you read black until I figure out
that you actually are supposed to
transfer the Knight to F5 which didn't
make sense to me at first because I feel
like you are getting the G4 there so the
nine on C6 wants to go here yeah you
have to do it yeah that's a very strong
transfer okay and why why did Doug play
Rook D1 and not just go for it yeah
aren't we
pushing forward are we attacking or or
are we failing
I was going to ask that question but in
fact it's the answer he's already giving
it to us because he played Rook ac1
uh I think Rook 81 is on the board
already so that means he wants to play
on the CNN he wants to play for C4 yes
yes and that's why he played Rook D1
right he played Rook D1 this is his plan
it's pretty obvious right now so it's
sort of like even though I've played the
move F4 and it would appear it's a bit
strange right that you're gonna go on
the king side the move Rook a C1 is
reveal you're combining a bit too many
plans in my estimation this F4 then you
get the Rook off the f file you're not
going to open up the king side anymore
it feels like you're not doing the right
things that's why okay so uh but yeah
we've got the question
it was a good move yes yes I mean I
thought we were in for a penny and
perhaps the best move in the position
yes let's go but again what why would
you play G4 with a rook on D1 and not
with the Rook on F1 well that's what I'm
saying I'm keeping the Rook on F1 we
should have done that yes
so you mean before Rook ac1 right yeah
you wanted to play G4 uh the move to my
mind the move Shabbos move
um after Knight F5 Rook to D1 Bishop E7
the move Bishop E7 in my mind says I
want to play
Knight E4 right and to kill the bishop
this way so I so if I play G4 now I'd
feel like you're helping me get where I
want to be I'm doing black a favor yeah
the the Knight wants to go to D6 so why
would I play G4 so now
thinking C4
and let's take oh we do have a move by
the way Rook C7 let's take a highlight
of Doug uh root as he comes to this
tournament by being the winner of the
National Tournament
National Tournament of senior state
champions welcome
and shavalov again a man who needs no
introduction four-time Champion national
champion and the returning U.S senator
champion
just by the way a really fun guy I
played on so many Olympic teams with him
too
he really is a great conversationalist
and we got a very nice headshot there of
Joel Benjamin
seniors are still working out the camera
angles and The Kinks just a quick
question before we leave this game how
does the computer assess the current
position uh Christians because it's
slightly better for white all the pieces
are on the board only if you play this
move and it has been slightly better for
why it equals slightly better for black
for pretty much the whole game there's
not that much separation in this
position at some point one of the sides
will have to do something significant
and most likely it's going to be white
at some point with this idea of G4 you
have to do something I don't like
playing C4 I and perhaps this is why he
played the move Rook to uh C7 you're
envisioning this idea of C4 you've been
getting ready as white why don't I get
my queen on the long diagonal with Queen
to A8 since this diagonal is going to
open up after the move C4 and C takes D4
maybe uh followed by Queen to A8 Rook to
d8 or Rook 2 C8 so I I do like this
flexible once again we're going back to
the flexibility side of things
but what is the assessment after this
move G4 right Knight to D6 right I would
assume this is going to come absolutely
automatically that's why you played
Bishop E7 right to make space for the
Knight to go to D6 or Knight to D6
I have to open up the bishop right now
okay and then I have to continue okay
making uh my Bishop the best piece in
the position for a white stronger right
yeah by kicking the Knight away from the
long diagonal
and then maybe C4 this is a nice
sequence for white and it seems like
it's starting to ask some serious
questions from black how are you going
to continue could I jump into the C4 E4
Square I'm sorry uh with the queen on
the D file yeah that was the question uh
no no no no not uh sorry Knight on F6 oh
from the beginning yes here yes I
thought I wanted to you cannot
unfortunately it seems like okay oh
YouTube oh you have to take with the
pawn yes you cannot take with the Knight
you you lose that's that that's the
queen you have to take with the pawn and
now I just simply go Knight C4 your
Bishop now with the pawn on e4 is
completely stuck right I have the
majority on the queen side yep yeah and
the bishop on B2 doesn't have any
opposition no you're right you would
love to have this bishop maybe on G7 but
you don't right so you're going to have
some serious problems once you play G6
like I played I don't have ideas
the bishop of V2 they say no more you're
done I'm done you're going to get
checkmated Knight G4 Knight H6 I mean
there's so great I agree I agree but
Christian I have a question what if I'm
a bit aggressive and after G4 I go to H4
with my knight because your queen is no
longer on E1 kind of guarding that
square the best move by the way great
nice and then I want to go to E4 with my
knight whenever possible so I can
recapture with my phone and then land
with my knight on F3 yeah that's like a
dream yeah it might can continue G5
how do you do it 97 I would take
oh oh oh
that's a pawn he took upon but can I go
to E4 you can
you can yes after G5 Knight to E4 but
after d takes C5 once again you have
this problem on the D file right what do
you do you cannot take with a pawn you
lose a piece
or a pawn and then after that more than
that right if you take with a knight
again the same idea that is dangerous
yeah
that's the problem right yeah so I want
to capture on C5 and capture with Pawn
on e4 but that's yeah yes you you again
you can take but then take take and once
again if you would have the Queen off
the D file maybe you're in time but you
don't so now you're kind of in trouble
yeah okay well thank you for that
Christian and I'd like to share with our
viewers we had the opening ceremony
yesterday of the three events as they're
the drawing of lots Tony Rich
of the executive director of St Louis
chess club and introduced all the
players Chris bird our chief Arbiters
and these were the bags yeah there was a
drawing of laws they were picking a bag
and there was a number at the bottom of
each bag and that's how they picked the
number they're gonna start with in the
exactly remember these round Robins you
have nine rounds of play because
everybody plays everyone Joe Benjamin
very celebrating the fact that he got
number one he picked the number one
number
and uh yeah it wasn't just happiness
over the bag right I mean it was the
number one thing and the idea is nine
games you're gonna get five whites or
five blacks and getting that extra white
so choosing numbers one through five is
something to be used
celebrated here and uh
I wanted to just jump to a game of Zoe
Zoe Tang against Shreya mangalam what is
happening here I've got a I've got to
ferret out all of these games number
three number three let's go to Zoe this
King did not have time to Castle yet
that can be a big problem especially
when this e-file is open and both Rooks
are ready to jump there I felt the chill
and it wasn't the air conditioning oh
boy yeah no what happened that looks
like a disaster occurred here okay so
this is all very conventional Queens
Gambit decline kind of business Bishop
Bishop takes G7 G6 now this is always a
question of timing right because at the
moment
there's no threat to the pawn on H5 the
pawn is covered so you would think
Knight F6 and castles but I think maybe
she had it in her mind that she would
like to take this Pawn didn't like the
looks like F5 yes so she played G6
thinking I'm going to take this Pawn
what are you going to do about it well
I'm not worried I'm gonna open up the
e-file as soon as possible and please do
me a favor take the pawn on on H4 so I
could land on D6 with a check now she
understood that there are issues and it
was important to get her King out of the
center I don't like the move Knight F6 I
mean I'm not happy about Black's
position but at least with King f8 and
King G7 maybe I can tuck my king out of
the center but this is how she got
caught she missed the move Queen acre
283 is a very strong move just catching
the diagonal exactly no castles anymore
Rook is coming to E1 with a check and
there's really nothing to to do I mean
this is this is a Reuben Fein was a very
famous for saying in such positions the
combination is as natural as a baby
smile after the move King f8
Rook takes let's go for it so sweet so
natural
and uh thanks oops excuse me that that
diagonal and thing I I just go Bob I
secure the queen so this is uh terrible
but let's meet uh these two pair players
we'll start with Zoe Zoe Tang welcome 15
years old very young again the U.S girls
junior is for 20 years and younger so
she still can play it many many times
Invitational rating 2262 and she's the
girls under 14 North American Youth
chess champion wow Zoe and then her
opponent we have here women candidate
Master Shreya mangalam she is 20 so this
is her last time to be playing this
tournament Invitational rating 21-17 and
she's ranked number 28 among all the
girls in the United States under the age
of 21. Last Chance gotta make the most
your last chance
she did Play Bishop E7 oh this is game
over right yeah and now that combination
is just it so before we see the
combination can we just go before Queen
A3 just to take a look because if white
does give a check like Rook fe1 Check
Yes things are not that bad right King
f8 and no no and we go to G7 we survive
we are putting pressure on D4 as well as
H4 no no no you're you're more than
kicking here you I mean but it's this
move Queen A3 that completely turns the
tables that just destroys the position
as Black's King isn't it you know
not that I have any any really great
recommendations but even something uh I
mean I might be tempted to just you know
close my eyes and you know pray to the
god oh no there's Queen no I can handle
no I can't handle Queen H3 check boy
these this is this is really kind of B3
not giving a break to your opponent no
no no but it's the move Queen A3 that
she is miss queen A3 Bishop E7 rookie
now we've already talked about this one
looking back then we put more pressure
we yeah oh boy perhaps she's going to
try to go King to f8 but after all takes
C7 I think this is just this issue yeah
no this is the super I think she's gonna
go King D7 right to still kind of try to
survive but Queen B3 I mean where's the
survival
[Laughter]
and by the way I might even give you a
check first I was afraid of the check
the queen actually this uh uh the
longest move in chess right you know the
side to side okay I saw a nice
combination okay can we check it out so
Quinto H3 I think that's good you you
like this best yeah Queen H3 check okay
I have to play F5 you're creating the
weakness on E6
so let's try to get to it maybe from E3
or from B3 Bishop D6 it works
yeah okay Bishop D6 Christian wants to
play and now I can take I can go Queen
E6 yes
and I can go Queen E7 right
Cross Pin
that's a nasty okay and if I go Queen
then I just take
um
and you've just been teaching summer
chess camps so you probably you've
probably got a wicked tactical yeah
after working for five days in a row
five days in a row eight through four 97
kids we have here during summer chest
cats in Saint Louis and they're all
excited about tactics so we keep giving
them puzzles and then sometimes they
having them inaccurately so we have to
explain that so they really build their
tactical Vision so it's a lot of fun a
lot of craziness yeah the tactics is
something I've been practicing last week
I can imagine you have uh Christian back
over to you and uh did Dimitri gurvich
play E3 E4 yes he did yes without
hesitation wow they play it fast and by
the way A5 was the response and to be
honest it's the most natural response
when you see this movie A4 is the first
thing you start playing about but the
problem is if you do Miss E4 and I have
a feeling he did miss that Igor novikov
that is you're completely busted and he
played it fast right now it's a plus
three Advantage there's been a game
between Salem and La Morel and white
completely demolished Black's position
in just a few moves so this one is not
looking good and if you look at the
times as well you can understand the
Comfort level of both of these players 1
hour and 17 minutes 19 minutes for
gurevich so he barely spent any time
maybe he's even still within his
preparation right on the other hand a
week of 58 minutes feeling definitely
not comfortable right due to the lack of
the dark swear Bishops darkscore Bishop
for himself in the position and it's
almost very similar to what was
happening to the last game the Zoe 10
game that we just seen this king is more
or less stuck in the center you just
simply don't have time to get it to G8
get it to safety right because you're
going to lose that Knight on C5 yeah and
the more you look at the moment you
realize that the move Bishop E3 you
would think that if it was white to move
you would play E5 with the idea of
Bishop's G5 check but as you stop and
Ponder you go to yourself you know this
night on C5 is actually the one that's
kind of high and dry or it there's the
only protection is the queen that's not
a very good protector Bishop E3 Rook C1
and yeah Knight B3 that's the real
threat it's not that E5 and Bishop G5 so
it looks like black is gonna play like
Rook H to d8 right right like we can
kind of Castle hide the king there uh
but also we can be worried that suddenly
we
gonna have some troubles but you can
move the Knight to B3
yeah okay so I can still attack my king
to f8 right
probably just play Rook here now I have
a different kind of a combination this
is a little scary yeah
yeah and just 26 Maybe
Queen D6 I've got E5 uh D4 is hanging
but it's not enough right we didn't get
enough I think I've Got The Rook uh
coming to C7 let's try to get more yes
sir let's try to get more
sorry maybe maybe even before before
this moment Rook C1
can we go E5 ah
as white you would like to get more why
not E5 Knight D5 Maybe
let's go for the attack we need five
yes I understand it's it's so you're
inviting Knight E3 but thank you for the
you're doing me are you doing me a very
nice service here aren't I eight seven
is hanging as well that's too much so I
have to go king and the question is
after Bishop G5 ah
I can imagine I can easily imagine that
I've got no no guards there's no guards
for my king but this is like one of
those it's not that easy right because
straightforward yeah it's
you know
well I don't know this is this is tough
it's uh uh 94 it looks like a move we
would love to make exactly I'm not sure
if I should be sacrificing exchanges or
not maybe it's just premature well then
we could have also Knight F4 coming and
I think it's G2
so now we're talking uh Thrills and
Spills right so the idea of Knight F4
for the moment is not on tap but okay I
can go Rook takes what you are saying uh
with the idea Knight F4
and you know something somehow did the
tables could turn
uh
and let's uh surprisingly I've been
looking at the position a little bit
with with the engine and surprisingly
it's not that easy those lines that we
were looking at oh sorry
um they're not that straightforward
uh yeah so uh from the current position
makes the most sense right and you
remember that idea with Bishop E3 Queen
to H5 later on but you can do that in a
much better version you can actually
start with E5 okay Knight D5 and now
Queen to H5
H6 and now Bishop to E3 do you see any
difference right yeah four stage six age
six instead of King on G8 yes so now I
have an extra move and I can force the
trade on E3 with the king in a much
worse situation on f8 right because on
G8 I'm ready to run away right but after
Knight to B3 Knight takes take I'm
threatening Checkmate and there is no
way in fact you can defend Rook D7
doesn't work Queen C7 allows me to take
on C5 and then take on F7 so you're
pretty much busted there has to be a
very accurate move forward exactly
exactly so forget about the engine right
now the engine is saying completely look
if the engine plays is going to finish
you in five moves from now but these are
humans that are playing so you have to
be and you've seen how easy it is for us
to make mistakes even that idea with
Rook to C5 I was looking through the
engine it wasn't giving a significant
advantage to White not nowhere close to
three plus one so you have to be very
precise but at the same time novikov
also has to be very precise in defense
right now okay this is a very exciting
game I think we're gonna come back to it
but let's take a look at Juniors what is
happening there well this was that uh
Catalan game uh that we looked at
earlier I was very curious to see what
uh transpired after we left it A4 B4
Knight E4 everything that white is doing
by the way it feels to me like a dream
Catalan right I mean the bishop on G2 is
lording over the diagonal right now you
you really haven't gotten in the move C6
C5 until you did then I dropped in and
The Rook on the one I'm just really
happy on that file again perfect perfect
the night on D6 is so disruptive
threatening to captures captures and by
the way don't forget that that Rook on
D1 with E2 E4 there are issues so he
captured captured C4 and we're up to
date with the players and
I have to give black credit the most C4
is the most
uh
honorious uh kind of you know I refuse
to go down without a fight because the
desired E4 I believe Black's idea is to
play before and if we move our Queen to
E2 now at first blush it really does
look like it's game over right we've got
this incredibly powerful Pawn but then
after the move Knight to before we
understand that black is kicking
trying to get his Knight to be through
to D3 pardon me
so we could play Queen takes D6 yeah the
pawn and if we play E5 well at least in
this case I I I'm trading light Square
Bishops and I've got I've got a bit of a
trump myself I mean the D3 square is in
my favorite by the way not saying that
I'm winning a rook or anything like that
but you know Knight C2 is there I think
it's a really cool idea not to recapture
the pawn on D6 yeah because if we were
captured upon inside of uh playing C4
then there are a lot of issues on the D
file so we're kind of waiting and
thinking maybe recapturing later or it
may not be that easy for white to push
it to December now the one thing I
really really want to avoid as black is
I want to avoid going into a passivity
uh so for for for me a strategic howler
like just a terrible move would be the
move Knight B6
after the move A5 don't leave don't go
to a80 right no that would be too
terrible but this is an incredibly
passive way of uh play and I really
really don't like it I despise it in
fact you can see that after Bishop A3
Bishop E3 and or queen A4 it's like
everything's a liability suddenly the
pawn on B4 is weak if I go Bishop eighth
through E3 the pawn on A7 is weak and
you've got a passive position and your
position is really Under Fire and now
pushing B3 makes no sense because I just
go Queen C3 exactly right like you're
just and I'm just happy the pawns are I
can recapture the pawns anytime I want
so they lost all its power whereas so
from the very beginning in this current
position I think it's incumbent upon
black to play the move B3 and if you're
afraid of the move night night to B4 and
you play the move Queen to D2 in order
to stop and you you keep going you know
you go you you try to
turn these pawns into some kind of a
trump uh with the move of B3 and C3
we'll keep an eye on that one and we're
going to toss it over to Christians see
what other Junior games I think we had
Mishra uh also game a lot of them are
exploding that's right exploding yes
just to kind of stay on this game for
one second sure it's not looking good
for black at least from a an objective
point of view and you were mentioning
yes this is the way you're kicking and
screaming at least going down kicking
and screaming with B3 but the problem is
I'm going to go Queen to D2
and you don't have this move Knight to
B4 that's something after C3 you have to
go C3 but after C3 I take and then I
will just simply move my Rook away and
then the bishop comes to B2 I'm getting
my Bishop active as well look
from a visual perspective it looks good
for black right you got your knight to
C3 you're getting a lot of activity in
the position but you're going to get
kicked out very very quickly after
Bishop to D2 and this Pawn on D6 is such
a monster in the position I really don't
like what Josiah has been doing in this
one and after E4 it seems like Kirk is
uh in the driver's seat in this one he
does the bullet because at this point
way back instead of Rook to C8 if you
just go for the pawn on E5 with the move
Queen to B8 it's not that easy for white
maybe it's already black who is starting
to get the better side of things
um Queen to B8 very powerful important
move Queen to B6 was an idea as well
Rook to C8 was just too slow simply
because of what Kirk played and he took
advantage and he did what he had to do
very very swiftly you have to play fast
in this position as wide you have to
create weaknesses in the position as
soon as possible
and this is exactly what he did and
right now I have say Josiah is in a
world of trouble
and he's supporting the jacket of our
University as I should have done better
beautiful jacket come on maybe you're
going to represent you know you got to
represent the colors uh successfully uh
my goodness here what's going on
um all right one of the Junior game and
uh there's a mask so which game am I
looking at here I've got a tape that
goes right here who's on the white side
of this game uh Andrew honk Andrew is on
the white side uh for me this is a
really really important
strategic Motif that I have used
throughout my career very often times I
have been in those situations where
Queens got traded early
and I lost the right to castle with my
king but I cured my problem with this
very important move C7 C6 and it's like
the simplest thing in the world but boy
it makes a world of difference first of
all of course I take away these two very
nice squares for the night on C3 but far
more importantly I give my king this
beautiful Escape script where actually
you know I lost the right to Castle but
you can't hurt me yeah hidden away if we
lose the right to Castle and especially
if there are no Queens on the board then
everything is kind of okay and the King
can be tactical C7 especially there's
also another no dark Square Bishop so no
one to kick him away from that diagonal
so you look at the the position with
some confusion you go oh well white is
definitely for Choice a better
development black has lost the right to
Castle blah blah blah then you get to
this position and you go oh my goodness
where's my advantage because
when you lose the right to Castle but
your king ends up on a very good Square
where it's safe it's not there's nothing
wrong there's nothing wrong at all
um I wanted to also ask just
was another game that was very
intriguing
so can we go to the doors yeah
because we have a really cool game here
but already we have a winning here I was
about to say I think resignation uh when
we left it we oh hold on make sure that
uh I've got it just a second let me make
sure that we've got the right position
you know we have the wrong position so
it was the analysis so when we left it
it was this move rookie one and we said
it's lights out
um
trying to survive fighting for Rook H7
Bishop D6 where you'd anticipate Rook H7
the problem is
we're just going to double double
Rook to East Rook to E6 and Rook to E1
and it's sort of like if I'm the trainer
I'm throwing in the towel I've got I've
got my towel ready I don't want to I
don't want my player taking wait a
minute wait wait wait wait wait wait
you can always recapture with rook and
look on dicks and then make this
discount the only way to give her give
her some chances King E7 for example
King D7 excuse me rookie six queen king
D7 but then Bishop takes E7 and then I
take back how with the Rook and then
Queen D6 or I have Rook D6 I Rook D6
yeah I Rook D6 came over oh he was
saying sorry just to uh help our viewers
for see that's the thing when you get
the chess players together for dinner
they just play blindfold chess yeah they
don't give me a chance to catch up on
the king D7 Bishop takes E7 is with the
tempo it attacks the queen you don't
have time to take the hanging Rook Rook
takes and what Christian missed and what
you delightfully pointed out to
Christian
but I mean Christians
you were hoping I was gonna do what it's
beautiful right you get so close to
Checkmate but then I tuck my king on it
well otherwise I lose a rook right right
of course and then like taking on F6 I
have a feeling this is completely
hopeless yeah but but what he was saying
was that he was a queen no no I will
take on D6 if you do that yeah yeah by
the way rookie six on the board as Zoe
uh is putting the finishing touches on
what looks like a opening disaster
opening disaster rookie six
how
get the towel coach yes yes to to many
hits and where would you take this one
Rochelle will games because you're
talking about you know people pushing F5
quickly and she did a cool thing here
yeah so there is this Pawn Avalanche A5
attacking Queenie is ready to kind of
get the queen to the king side and now
she played F5 immediately
timing is an issue and that doesn't look
like a very good move and now she's not
recapturing with the Rook she's like hey
I'm gonna wait I'm gonna get this Pawn
later like in kind of some kind of
King's Gambit decision but nobody
believes you I mean that is a very nice
pawn cake I mean just a second Queen C2
not only defends the pawn but it really
does a moment in one of the other games
I think it was Alice Lee's game we were
looking at Knight G5 with the idea of
getting the E6 well with pawns on D5 and
F5 Knight to E6 would be boss so
I'm attacking twice on F5 with the
bishop and the brook clear I'm
transferring potentially the Knight to
F4 and I still have extra Queen who can
attack the pawn on F5
but then after Bishop to D3 Queen to F7
G2 G3
and well
how are you going to recapture the poem
I wanted to but now I'm a little scared
but like all the captures and G4 of four
exactly well that's a that's a crafty
move by Rochelle uh At first she says oh
you're right you know you you can win
the pawn back you know I'll just stop
you from playing the move Knight F4 but
yeah you're right you go ahead and win
the font but then Kate your spidey sense
was tingling there and you got the scent
you understood what Rochelle has in mind
very nasty move now it's like the
Stutter Step you play G3 but now you
play G4 you Fork the rook and the and
you force and the uh the loss of an
exchange okay still still you have to
show technique to win the game but you
should yeah
and let's take a look at these uh two uh
protagonists yes so we have woman in
Grand Master Rochelle Wu she's 17 years
old her Invitational rating 2353 and
she's the 2018 North American junior
girls Champion she's also the world
champion for girls under 10 from 2016 I
believe fantastic and for me it seems
like Rochelle has been playing in this
tournament for many years I mean she has
really been one of our top competitors
and her opponent we have women
International Master Iris moo age 13
very very young wow wow Invitational
rating 22 31 and she won the 2022 Casper
of Chess Foundation all girls National
Chess Championship I mean I'm just
looking at that Masters rating of 2231
at 30. and that's like ridiculous for me
I really want to emphasize I had the
ceiling I became you know in several
years I became an expert
and it was like really really tough to
get to that expert class but to get the
master class I I it was just so hard and
and when I burst through 2200 I didn't
get a 2200 or rating I got a 2300 I was
overrated I went literally from 2190 to
2300 and I was trying so hard to get my
Master's rating and here she is at 13
years old she's much much stronger than
I ever was at 13. I mean it's ridiculous
I like talking about the seniors because
we can talk about the past but boy these
future and it looks promising with such
Polaris Christian back over to you and
you've got the seniors well I actually
just want to let you guys know that Igor
is Frozen Frozen no he's been thinking
for the last 30 minutes after this move
E4 and he has no idea what he should be
doing at this point will he take on e4
will he go Rook to d8 he does have
options the problem is all of them are
extremely dangerous and objectively
already this is a very very bad position
there's no good moves in a bad position
and right now if you let yourself go to
your last few minutes as he is doing
well he's going to be in deep deep
trouble because you know this attack is
going to go on forever for white I'm
going to go Bishop B3 route to C1 it's a
long-standing attack and if you don't
have enough time to try to defend with
precise moves then you're going to be in
huge huge danger and this is exactly
what's happening to Navi carve right now
and as you can see this is a very
experienced move by grevich he's just
stepping aside from the board letting
him think hey don't worry about the time
take as much time as you need yeah
finally we see and we do have Knight
takes E4 I was about to say if you're
gonna be attacked whether you capture or
not
we might as well have the Solace yeah of
having something in your pocket to
suffer the attack and he did play after
a long think after a 30 minute thing
night on F6 takes E6 question from for
you Christian or Yasser like if you are
in a bad position you see all those
choices but you don't like any of them
do you have any rule about your time
management like how much time are you
gonna spend to to decide which one which
move out of those bad moves are you
gonna make yeah I don't I mean if I'm
gonna have a bad position okay shame on
me but I don't want to have a bad
position and be significantly behind on
time because I know the time trouble is
going to force me to play quickly and
likely I'm going to error even worse
with the time so you know I'm just gonna
you know bite the bullet
choose one of the ugly options but the
option I'm more likely to choose is take
the material I have something that I can
hold on to and say I've got I've got
this in my pocket
as we get prepared for a break I'm just
going to prepare I'm going to take one
look at Alice Lee's game and I'm going
to tell you about our good Folks at Q
Boutique but first of all let's just
take a look at the Alice Lee game for
when we left it we left that was the 91
moment remember Victor corcinoy Judith
Polgar so the the players are following
a game Victor course Noy versus Judith
Polgar and we really liked the move
Knight G5
yeah going for it Victor corchinoy
played the move Knight E1 and that was
the move that Alice Lee also played uh
provoked the night to come back we were
looking at F5 and then you were
suggesting Bishop takes G4 she didn't
want to deal with that she would drop
back with a knight Bishop E3 is C5 and I
think that this was an interesting
decision by Alice
she captured
and giving her opponent
what I want to say is the big Center but
at the same time What Alice is trying to
say we'll see if she's right I want to
attack the backward Pawn on D6
a2a3 okay so this is a kind of an an
intonation way down the line now play
for B4 B5 create a pass pawn and just
try to pray and take the D5 Square uh
from you F6 F5 F 3 F4 and we caught up
to the players I'm a little bit
surprised by the move A3 and I wanted to
ask you about this why didn't she play
Queen D2 because that to my eye is the
most natural move I'm I'm provoking
either Knight F7 or Knight G4 what do
you think made her choose A3 over Queen
D2 it's an it's an interesting moment
right yeah the question is whether you
where is the queen better right do you
need the queen right now on D2 or is
there a prior ready to because maybe she
wants to recapture with the queen on A1
right after A3 and B4 if the pawns trade
you want to be guarding your Rook okay
and just recapture there gotcha if you
don't do that you move the queen I mean
you attack the Knight
yeah and then you need to move your
knight from E1 which which is nothing
wrong I mean the Knight is not doing
such an impressive job no it's not we
can improve it exactly but it slows down
the thing so I think maybe Alice just
wanting to be really fast with attacking
the queen side Okay cool so the idea
there is that she wants to play the move
uh A3 and B4 as soon as possible to get
in B4 B5 and and then deal with Knight
on E1 and all the pieces that are a
little bit like okay right there right I
mean and for me for for me and I think
um
uh all players love developing with
Tempe I mean that I mean I love to check
my opponent's king or Checkmate of
course but uh developing with a Tempe uh
a Tempo in this case forcing the Knight
to move uh would have been so attractive
we'll keep an eye on this so we're going
to take our first break uh before we do
that we always check in to with our
folks our good Folks at Q Boutique at
the chess shop across the street to ask
them what is the special today and this
one
is a chest travel bag tote your roll-up
board and chest pieces in style with the
official St Louis chess club local
travel bag the zipper pouch holds an
entire set of pieces comfortably while
your board fits
underneath
gold screen printed ink on durable vinyl
don't forget the chess pieces and vinyl
roll up forward all your chest needs can
be matched met pardon me at Q Boutique
St louis.com and by the way they are
very attractive I I have one
and as we go on break uh begum checks in
with our players we hope you enjoy
[Music]
whatever welcome back to Saint Louis
it's lovely to see you here thank you I
checked fide and your rating is 26 12.
currently and you were of course over
2700 at some point how do you keep such
a high level
I used to keep a higher level more
higher than that
I don't know
I used to play on higher level of course
yeah and this was but also that time I
mean I I did a lot of work edges I was
working on everything on chess openings
now also sometimes but somehow whenever
you're over 50 it's already more
difficult yeah you have some other goals
in in your life and episode that it's
not like I would not say that I don't
even know that this is I-12 to tell the
truth I don't know that's such a low oh
I'm sorry
for me it's still a very high rating and
what are you what are your goals you
mentioned that after 50 you have
different goals can you no you just note
that like you already enjoy your life
you don't spend that much time on chess
uh
and you already normally if you are like
something like this you all lose all
those uh you lose motivation actually
when I was young I remember that just
you should play and you should win and
you make everything for that
uh both preparing and during the game
and now I see you lose yeah this like
side this this part of but still yeah
still of course I mean nobody likes
losing so if we come here we try to do
our best it's clear but
um of course something something is lost
it's completely different whenever
you're young let's say 20 or something
like this
so this tournament is kind of new for
you did you make any particular
preparation for it or you try to work as
you would work before mostly physical
preparation
because
um uh yeah it's already difficult again
because of of your age
just mostly this some chess some chess
but not more yeah again whenever you are
young you can actually skip that because
you are your fit normally
but now it's already some some some some
problems they already uh and so yeah
physically yeah I did I mean going to
gym and making some exercises everything
like this just like already like some
seconds you already have it right yeah
Alexander chavalov also mentioned and
then actually send us a video saying
that he's focusing on on physical
progression more than chess and probably
this is the one thing we can see who's
gonna handle better I guess and how how
are you feeling about the tournament in
general about your opponents
he was very interesting a great
tournament again this was a very
pleasant experience last year I mean I
knew that there is such a tournament but
uh I mean you should be 50 yeah to take
part here so that was great last year
and of course this year I expect also
um I mean very very good opposition of
course it's it's it's not easy I mean
it's not easy it's it's very tough and
last year it was also very tough and
this playoff with fifth actually five
players we played the playoff was very
tense actually this year they changed
this because last year I remember after
the immediately after the last round I
was just totally exhausted and playing
this playoff after that was very
difficult but now I see that this year
they changed everything and this is of
course great you can have rest after
that and on the next day you play
playoff so they're always improving and
of course
this is this is great of course this is
Eric glad to hear that and good luck
with the tournament thank you very much
[Music]
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the Arts culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
hello I'm women's Grandmaster William
tokerchonova I will be doing social
media for the U.S Juniors and seniors
chess championships follow us in our
social media and get more exciting
behind the scenes action
[Music]
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States and
is among the best in the world thanks to
co-founders Dr Jeannie Karen singfield
and Rex sinkfield the St Louis chess
club is a non-profit organization
committed to promoting the game of chess
locally and internationally we bring the
educational benefits of Chess to
thousands of students across the St
Louis area promoting cognitive
development critical thinking
concentration and analytical skills the
St Louis chess club welcomed chess
lovers of any age and skill level to
come and enjoy the game of chess we also
promote Chess at the highest levels
posting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over 2
000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chess piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
monthly concerts and much more whether
you are a beginner or a professional
there is something for everyone to learn
here at the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy free admission to our rotating
exhibitions and our Galleries and sign
up for chess events family friendly
programming and art classes and don't
forget to stop by our award-winning gift
shop Q Boutique and Shop a wide
selection of Chess related merchandise
for more information on current exhibits
please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q
boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
hello I'm women's Grandmaster begin
Tucker jonoa I'm doing social media for
the US Juniors and seniors championships
here in San Luis follow us for more
exciting behind the scenes content
foreign
hello and welcome back to our show these
national championships boy they're
heating up as I'm I'm loving what
Rochelle is doing she's got a terrific
position and we were kind of fearful
that on our break that Zoe uh would have
won her game I like The Bravery of
giving up the pawn but kind of the issue
of not being able to recapture that is
uncomfortable yeah with that you mean of
the Rochelle's game you know just
bringing that up on the board what what
happened
was that Rochelle has captured this Pawn
on F5 and invited her opponent with the
move G2 G3 to recapture the pawn on F5
but the problem is the stutter step of
the G Pond when we left it uh Bishop
takes F5 Bishop takes F5 Queen takes F5
Queen takes F5 Rook takes F5 G4 and the
pawn Forks the rook and the Knight
forcing the loss of the exchange black
didn't want to lose the exchange but the
problem is if you don't recapture this
Pawn on F5
it's not a pretty sight because at a
certain moment
how are you ever going to develop your
queen side pieces and this move uh by
the way uh
c4c5 is a big big threat in the position
and that was why uh black just played
the move B7 B6 but you can imagine for
example if I play A4 say it's just your
turn uh what you're going to do the
other thing I can easily imagine is a
peace sacrifice oh just yeah just you
know like like if you just kind of
stopped and looked at this position for
just a moment first of all
the fact that I'm already a pawn up I
want to re-emphasize the fact that
that's three problems yeah like that's
three bonds already but that starts
those types of sacrifices start to occur
in your mind so wonderful things happen
but maybe one thing you don't want to do
let's say after B6 what about move G4
ah because that's like you are holding
on to the pawn very safely with your own
Pawn right but the trade-off of allowing
the Knight to F4 is not a good trade-off
no that's the one thing uh you know it's
funny I once did this I made this huge
strategical error against Dr John Nunn
black snide is off-site
black snide on H5 is offsides and it's
almost like you're Desiring to win the
night when what you should be saying is
your night's offsides it's in the woods
it's in the bushes uh it's not doing you
any good uh I haven't won it yet that's
what you need to think not the idea that
I should be trying to win it because in
fact what I've just done is I've brought
the Knight back into civilization and by
the way night on F4 as we know from our
career experiences those nights on F4
are very dangerous and all the dark
scores around not not to be done not to
invite you know I see another game where
there is a shop landing on a very
beautiful
twirl the first game yep
look at that Bishop on D6 or Applause
looks very nice but on the other hand
like night would be much better there
yes right let's establish that right and
I'll see what are we gonna do about this
position
hmm well there's so much I don't like
about Black's position for the moment
the first thing is this night on each
Somebody's gotta go I don't care who's
going but somebody's got to leave I've
gotta
yeah right I'd love to take the bishop
or you know like if I if I force a trade
Knight takes Bishop takes I feel like I
can breathe a little bit more uh for the
moment if I'm black I kind of like to
see my Bishop on e4 which is the delay
that was the delay I had I want to play
Knight F5 I really do but if I start
with Bishop E4 and just for argument's
sake that is not a good move or not a
bad move and I ended up doing something
as crazy as recapturing
with the pawn okay not something that
comes uh naturally to me by the way
doubling my pawns uh at least I got this
strong Vision
holder position exactly so see what
happened in the gameplay
Pawn takes on E5 nope if we go back
whatever oh yes F4 and now they took
Pawn takes on a five
yep and politics
it would be very reluctant I yes I so
again I whenever you trade I I like to
have this conversation with myself I
imagine myself in a market okay yeah a
farmer's market you go to the royal mark
and all the people bring their Wares and
their trade and we barter we talk about
it we barter how much for the loaf of
bread how much so I'm sitting here
saying okay I would like to trade this
Pawn but in these trades I ask myself
who's benefiting
so we trade the Pawns
the F6 and F4 Pawn disappear from the
board that's our trade who benefits I
see this Rook on F1 and they go whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa I
know the bad deal as well I got the bad
deal because wait a minute The Rook on
F1 is already on the open file I don't
want to trade so I would be very
reluctant to this black to have made
that trade and I would have probably
played the move Knight F5 myself when
there is some kind of tension positions
we usually don't don't want to be the
first one who's Nerf kind of cracks and
they just destroyed attention we need to
keep it because there the pawns on file
we're blocking The Rook of on F1 right
and the worst part about this is the
desirable Knight F5 now does give my
opponent the option of making a very
dangerous looking exchange sacrifice
Knight takes Knight takes Bishop takes
F5 now because I opened up the file I
have to imagine that this is a
possibility yeah because it takes
another Pawn exactly check and whether
you play Queen of seven or move your
king this is a possibility I've gifted
to my opponent the option of this
exchange sacrifice
um yeah that was a trade I would have
been very reluctant to do Christian I
want to turn it over to you as you've
been following that attacking game of
Dima I'm following uh the seniors indeed
and I have to say you were talking about
the Saturday markets and things of that
nature but taking this Pawn I mean there
was no barter I mean you took this point
and now you're completely losing you got
a losing position after this queen to D6
and it's easy that is the problem for a
black in this position because after
Rook to C1 I played by the way he played
Bishop E3 very very quickly Queen to D6
followed but you're not bringing any new
Defenders into your position you're just
sidestepping from the very dangerous
diagonals so you're losing time and I'm
gaining speed with my attack because I'm
bringing new attackers into the game the
easy way out for white is to just
continue play the move Rook to C1 and
now the best move for black is Queen to
D5 which to my eyes doesn't make any
practical uh sense because after Queen
to D5 first of all F3 and this is more
or less a four slide you go Knight to D6
I take on C5 I have better moves by the
way Queen to E2 and queen to E1 are both
better from an objective point of view
but Rook 2 C5 is the easy way out and
you get to this position and you
understand that I mean if this is the
best thing you can get as black then
you're probably in big trouble because
this is completely losing as well
Queen for a rook and a knight and a pawn
but unfortunately your king is still not
safe and is not getting any safer I'm
going to establish this connection with
Bishop to C5 Queen to D4 Rook to D1 and
at some point you're going to lose this
Knight on D6 as well bad news for your
position so if Queen to D5 the most
natural sorry not the natural move in
the position is the best move in the
position for black well then you're in
big trouble you have to go something
like Rook ac8 at least to my eyes this
is the most natural but after F3 Knight
to F6 and once again Knight to C6 this
is an easy tactic that I think
definitely grevich will be able to spot
and you're just simply losing a lot of
material you have to take with the Rook
if you take with the bishop you lose the
queen after Bishop takes C5 so you have
to take Rook take C6 the problem is I
continue
you take on C1 on D1 once again if you
take on C6 I take on C5 you lose the
queen you have to take on D1 first but
this is completely losing right not only
that you're an exchange down but you're
also uh first of all the king only eight
the Roku Knight rate is not getting out
anytime soon and I have ideas of Bishop
to B6 nice idea if I really want to
simplify things with Rook to C8 and Rook
to d8 pick up the Rook on h8 not
necessary I can just simply take the
pawn on uh A5 this one is looking really
bad for black and the problem is once
again it's easy very very easy moves for
white to get to that final moment where
you're going to get your Tactical blow
in the position and pulverize blacks
position
polarized damn yeah
it's tough man that's tough uh what I
would like to turn our attentions to the
game of Zoe for just a moment because
Zoe is winning and it's all going really
really beautifully for her she just
played this move rookie six and in fact
we didn't want to go on break we
resisted because we thought her opponent
might resign the game after the move
rookie six but no she found one idea of
continuing the game with Rook C8 to C7
sacrifice and exchange sacrifice which
was captured and I'm forcibly reminded
of the quote by Michael Tall
when you see a good move stop
you might have a better one might have a
better one and this move Bishop takes C7
is of course a good move there's no
question about it but then the challenge
to the audience I would ask
is what is the better move we know
taking the exchange Bishop takes C7
really works really well but the moment
I saw the move Bishop takes C7
tall came to my mind and for me here it
comes in case you haven't figured it out
a warning I'm about to show you I love
this move Queen G3 I just you like the
long moves here from one side yeah they
went to the H3 G3 is how you know but
this one was a really attractive move to
my eyes the double hit because you have
to go Rook to D7 and then I go check
oops well there goes the Rook otherwise
right that's just terrible I thought
Rook F7 right and then I thought okay
but now let's go into the king and pawn
end game right do this
this uh it doesn't matter how I do it
but we just trade everything and I've
got the I've got the
outside passer right after we trade
everything so it was that move Queen G3
she did end up she's in a winning
position Zoe is but I just liked uh the
the queen G3 more than her choice her
choice is definitely definitely uh
winning and Christian what caught your
eye well a lot of uh explosive stuff is
happening in the junior section and one
player that's
um pretty much uh losing completely
busted at this point is one of the
rating favorites more or less going into
this one one of the GMS in the
competition if I'm not mistaken this
position that we have on the board after
F4 I believe he missed this move Queen
to C5 first of all because it's an easy
move to miss but also the follow-up is
easy to miss he played King to B8 and
you might be wondering if you go Knight
to C4 then I get Rook to c18 then you're
actually in trouble yourself right
you're the one losing as white with so
many pieces on the C file the problem is
that I have this move Bishop to B3 a
nice intermezzo
and right now you can resign because if
you take on B3 I'm not taking your
knight on E7 I can probably do that as
well but Queen to E5 is so much more
convincing yes Queen E5 check you cannot
go well you can go on the seventh rank
but that doesn't help you I can continue
Queen to D4 I force you on the eighth
Rank and then I pick up the Rook we
check after that I'm going to get the
queen back to E5 or to D4 with Tempo
move the Knight away you don't have
enough compensation for the exchange and
in fact most likely I have the exchange
I have the material and the compensation
in the position so after Bishop to B3
where do you put the queen you go to F6
to keep contact with the Knight on E7
and the square E5 well thank you very
much that's another Tempo Knight to G5
at some point you're going to have to
place this queen on H4 allow my queen to
get to E5 and resign the game and this
is exactly what's happening right now
Bishop to B3 is on the board he's
playing fast Arthur uh Google and I
think this is is just going to force
resignation in this game after Bishop to
B3 wow this E5 square is
where it says and you cannot
cannot get close to an exchange of
Queens as black you would love to be
able to pick the Queens off the board
unfortunately there is no score that you
can do that from
wow you know it's good to mention that
video Master Arthur Zhu he's actually
the winner of 2022 us Juniors open that
earned him the qualification to be in
this junior championships so he's
definitely hungry to you know to prove
how much he belongs here and he's also
the lowest rated player in the event by
far right that's true like about 300
rating points between him and Balaji
this is a huge upset guys
true wow great start for Arthur zoo I
mean he may be doing really well here
but it's still I mean finishing winning
position that still requires some craft
so so let's see how that's gonna go
exactly uh by the way my my highest turn
to this game of uh shabalaf and it's a
very uh
funny looking game the game between
Douglas root and Alexander shabalaf our
defending Champion it's not one of those
situations you see that often is upon on
E3 and upon on E3 is forking uh both
Knights so yeah you want to remove this
this bond this bond is really bothering
you it's going to capture at night but
you capture the Knight and Maiden one
suddenly and it's like where did that
come from you you you you're threatening
a night what what what what's the deal
with this mate in one threat well the
mate in one threat uh provoked Doug to
block the diagonal with the Knight he's
just played Knight E4 I'm imagining that
we're taking this and because the Knight
is now hanging we have to capture this
I'm imagining we take
take A3 is hanging A3 is hanging so we
take this and one of the funny parts is
like you you your eye is almost drawn to
the move Queen here in order to threaten
mate but Queen takes G2 ruins your
entire day you don't want to be the
second one who's trying to Checkmate on
the board exactly so that's a confusing
uh position it's not a pattern you see
very often move E3 94 okay so takes
takes so what do you make of this uh
Kate I'm just coming to grips with it
myself yes I need to
Queen G4 that's an interesting move to
consider exactly
so because you're you're still defending
the mate but you're threatening the mate
I but we need to be careful about Muslim
even if
this is coming with a Tempo sorry yeah
I'm sorry yeah it's yeah you've got to
move the Rook first so let's move the
Rook to B1 A1 well A1 kind of has my
how do you say I because of uh I'm
trying to win the pawn I I was thinking
that we were doing a whole sequence of
trades right like captures captures this
type of thing
um at some moment I've got to defend
this Pawn so I need to play Knight F3
defend upon so something like Rook A3
hard to come to any firm conclusion on
this one but it looks like well I like
the bishop I like the bishop on the on
the long diagonal would you play here
something like A5 or blocks to just stop
kind of Pawn on B3 and we are defending
the pawn with Rook on C5 exactly yes I I
would uh very very much
um like to to do that
and we think this game is yes
um Balaji dagupati and that was the game
that Christian was talking about the E5
key square right
and oops
so there goes the Rook with the game
with check
that's okay
oops Pawn goes away too but gets back to
F7
by the way the material count is
terrible right it's not great
yeah I mean I was thinking if I block
with the Knight or if I should move my
king if I move my king queen before
Queen D4 Shack so he did block with the
Knight
and now first move that came to my mind
was Rook C1 and that was why I asked
what's the material count just a little
I want to have as much in my pocket as I
can yeah and perhaps you can also do
that but
why would you of course
yeah no of course you would uh you would
move your knight which is attack
um and he has more than 50 more minutes
to think wow these Juniors they play
really fast I do I have I'm in time
travel by move 30 and they still have 50
moves uh 58 minutes
they're very good practical players I
have to say they make their decisions
extremely quickly
um and I found that to be quite common
ground for the new generation especially
they play very very fast they they don't
wander too much oh what if I played that
or that you know they see a one move
they debate it for five minutes and then
they played it immediately then they
follow it up they usually have a good
plan behind it
that's one of the key techniques that I
feel the new generation is employing
quite well as a chess coach you're
seeing that Trend and is is that because
of the engines the influence of the
engines that it you know that the
players use the engine so well I think
chess is just getting faster chess in
general is getting faster you you see
more tournaments with rapid and Blitz
play you uh see very often this 90 plus
30 time control without the second time
control as well so 90 for the whole game
90 minutes for the whole game yes in
this particular case we do have an
additional 30 minutes after 40 moves but
that's not the typical time control that
we see nowadays exactly chess in general
is just getting faster and faster and
the players are adapting to it it means
that the players also have like
confidence to actually make the moves
make the decisions
because it requires a chess skill of
course but also the confidence to
believe in yourself that you are making
the right choice precisely yes
but training with the chess engine
consistently day in Day Out
uh does have this habit of convincing
you you may the right choice because the
chess engine some Narrow Path might say
plus three and you go oh great this is
plus three except every other move zero
zero zero so suddenly you are playing
this very narrow path and then you
convince yourself there is one way in
one way only I just have this uh game of
uh Jason Leon and uh Brandon Jacobson on
my screen and I've got this position and
I really like it for white uh it's kind
of unusual that there's a king on G7 and
there's not a dark squared Bishop right
yeah so somehow white has managed to
achieve almost
this idyllic setup with the Knight on F5
and captured this bishop and breaking
breaking open the king side with the
move H4 I feel like whites achieved
almost the the the dream you know if if
you've probably the Joker piano and uh
you know you get a position like this
you're a really really happy camper
something went wrong for black uh in
this game Christian what was it yes and
perhaps even the last couple of moves or
not the most precise for white from an
objective point of view but they do feel
like the most practical ones pick up the
bishop which seems to be the main
Defender around the black king and by
the way look at the time as well I
believe Brandon has 26 minutes on the
clock against close to an hour for white
so significant time difference and that
just goes to show how uncomfortable uh
Brandon Jacobson is with this position
he is coming into the this event as a
rating favorite
the best move after this move H4 is to
understand that after Knight to G6 in
fact you will get a lot of compensation
for the pawn if white decides to take
that pawn after moves such as Rook to h8
is not an immediate compensation it's a
long-term compensation you have some
ideas on the age file it's not that easy
for uh White to defend I have ideas of
Rook to H6 Queen to h8 maybe Rook 2 H5
Target the Knight on G5 as well you need
to understand this and this is a big
decision right visually it's not that
easy to understand because you might be
wondering hey I'm just getting right on
H3 right blocking the H file and where's
your attack I'm a pawn up I have the two
Bishops here King is unsafe on G7
completely opened up this doesn't
visually make a lot of sense right no
why um black would have a lot of
compensation but in fact after after
Knight H3 Bishop C8 black is winning
right you can't play night age
you cannot plug the H file it seems like
and he has played Knight G6
on that the inviting the pawn grabs
that's impressive that is an impressive
decision by uh Brandon and we'll see
whether you know
um he takes the poison Pawn with hd5 and
Knight hd5 most likely better is to just
go deeper
just try to play in the center play for
tension in the center and as black
what's your next move okay you got the
Knight on G6 nicely coming to F4 perhaps
you have the Knight on F6 the King on G7
maybe there's not that many attackers
against the King on G7 but what do you
play next after D4 I'm creating and I'm
setting up a lot of tension in the
center
but again not easy to understand that
that pawn sacrifice actually works so if
I would be in liang's shoes I would be
very tempted to take that moment indeed
it almost seems irresistible it does to
me you've played H3 H4 if you wanted to
play D4 as you've just suggested you
would do it with the pawn still on H3
you would say okay I won the two Bishops
I'll play D4 and open up the position
I've just played the move H4 because I
wanted capture the pawn on G5 if you
Kate you had a student
who came to you and said I played like
this sacrificing the pawn would you
berate them and say you know like well
you've lost a pawn and I don't see your
compensation or would you would say
genius
you've got there I've got I'm the wrong
teacher well I think here the black has
an idea for counter attack right which
is really powerful how the faces
can go there and there's a mate on this
yeah right also we need to look at the
alternative right if we don't give up
the pawn and we play G4 right how is
that gonna look and probably it's not a
good look nice too if we force H5 maybe
F3 or even F4 F3 or F4 breaking things
open and it's it's play on one goal I
mean white is the one uh having the fun
here it looks like black is going to be
kind of struggling for the rest of the
game whereas when sacrificing the pawn
I'm taking risk but I'm willing to kind
of counter-attack exactly in fact if you
start to look at the position after Rook
h8 you you might almost stop yourself
you might almost say okay I'll play
Queen D2 I'm just wait you know like I
I'm trying to provoke G4 it's not as
good as it was when the queen was on but
you know uh I'm almost beginning to be
fearful of Rook h a rook H5 Queen h8 and
so Queen D2 but when when white went for
h3h4 he was really thinking boy do do me
a solid capture my Pawn so I can either
take with a knight or capture with the
bishop I would probably be capturing the
bishop or played the move G4 and the
move Knight G6 is just
plain honorary you refuse to go along
with my with my program it's almost like
a cold shower right right you're feeling
like your opponent has to ease the
tension somehow either by taking either
by playing G4 maybe even taking the
passive approach and playing Knight H7
to defend that pawn on G5 but not just
leave the pawn on G5 exactly with Knight
G6 and then he just plays Knight G6 and
he's like okay what are you going and
you can see it look at his body language
right yeah he's not happy about it he's
missing beginning to think like wait a
minute I didn't want this Pawn why
didn't I I wanted you to do that you
need to defend it I wanted you to trade
it off I didn't want you to just give it
to me but he has some serious time
Advantage right we see Jason Liang 50
minutes and seat number one Brandon
Jacobson 26 minutes
uh probably I'm going to get myself
destroyed so please understand uh I am a
prompt Pond Grabber and I have to ask
the question I take the pawn just as
you've advised me to uh Christian but
this is also why Jason in it's such a
tough position because he knows that
you're here in the commentaries sure
revoking his uh membership grabbing
Association if he doesn't take on G5
right that's a lot of pressure for young
men like himself exactly so I'm playing
Knight takes G5 you're playing rook h8
and I understand that if I wait too long
you're going to go Rook H5 You're Gonna
Go Queen h8 and it's not going to end
well for me
so I'm gonna play Bishop to B3
intending to meet your Rook H5 with
Knight takes F7 so I know it looks a
little bit absurd
I'm I'm protecting the square f8 is that
yeah like okay it's two pawns but I
understand
the questions
yeah Queen David seven E7 E7 yes
in fact I think you have
your own the idea for active play for
white is to go D4 at some point exactly
the queen on D7 D4 comes with with Tempo
okay
and here I my pieces are a little bit
too far yeah so so if I play I don't
know uh
Queen F3 D4 you're gonna play Rook f8
and you're gonna take
no return
and uh let's take a look at these uh too
just uh profiling if you will yes we
have international master Jason Liang
816 very young wow ridiculous 2600 it's
16. that's amazing they're really good
these kids are just so smart so
skilled and what is that graphic the
2022 eastern Ontario Chess Championship
wow what is going on with that okay well
I'm just looking at the 2630 and I'm
going easy and here we have seat number
one Grand Master Brandon Jacobson h19 so
he has still at least one more year to
play right I think he's no stranger to
the junior championships either he had
some great uh games sorry to interrupt
you yeah an Invitational writing also
about 2600 26 43 super incredible and he
is the 2023 Saint Louis super Swiss
Champion so I think he's enjoying his
time in Saint Louis and happy to be back
to now fight it in this junior
Championship okay and yeah he's going
for it uh you know like you can't Bluff
me I'm gonna take that but I am a pawn
Grabber after all you can't Bluff me
well the thing is once you take it and
open the H file you kind of have to go
for Knight xg5 right yeah
I mean if you said hey you have to say B
right yeah if you're just gonna wait
then like your opponent knows that you
are just scared of capturing it and they
will just he's taking it how some other
moves and yeah that's not good for you
no it takes you five by the way
Christian you have a game that I was
also looking up at on your board this
was the game that we were looking at B3
and C3 tell us what happened yeah this
is the game between uh gazerian and
Josiah steerman and um we have this
position I think this is summer yeah and
we were saying that Knight F6 probably
the passive way out is not going to be
good the right way but he did go for it
A5 blocking the Queens
um Square on A5 or B6 as well so it
makes a lot of sense right because if I
managed to get the queen on A5 support
the push of the pawns on the queen side
maybe I can get some sort of counter
play so this is uh the idea behind this
move A5
Queen to D7 Bishop to G5 Queen to B5 so
we see Josiah still trying to find a way
to activate his Queen H4 is the move
Knight to D7 getting away uh from all
these Bishop takes F6 Shenanigans and I
have to say queen to A4 seems like the
Practical move for white because once
you trade the queens and go into the end
game the two Bishops also the pawn on D6
also the weakness uh that the pawn on B4
and the pawn on C4 uh is going to become
it feels like white just has pretty much
all trumps in the position so for
example Queen takes A4 Rook takes A4 how
do you defend this Pawn do you go B3
that doesn't really seem to uh improve
your case I can even go A6 if I want A6
Bishop C6 I take the pawn on C4 this one
is not looking good Bishop two A8 Bishop
to E3
where are your targets right you cannot
remove this blockading piece from D7 try
to defend because once my Pawn starts
rolling down the board it's game over so
you're in trouble right now I think this
is pretty much game over so after Queen
to A4
you have to do something else question
is what can I go Bishop A6 you probably
have to maybe not Space six maybe
bishop C6 to force the trade a bit more
forcing yes yeah but still it's this
position we get to it I go A6 I have
ideas of Rook to A5 and more importantly
I solidify and cement that weakness on
A7 it just doesn't feel like black has
enough compensation for what's happening
in the position the strategical trumps
that the white has in the position
there's no compensation for them and it
just feels like you are always putting
it play on one goal at this point it's
white who's having all the fun in the
position Kirk gazarian understood that
offered the queen trade and right now I
have to say the pressure is on Josiah
interesting thank you for that Christian
now I was going to say in our girls uh
tournament the girls Championship our
favorites are having a bit of trouble uh
let's start with Karissa Carissa uh
black in this open Sicilian I want to
say classical uh with the two knights
um Bishop on E3 wrote went to E8 look
what happened white just traded things
down traded traded traded got to this
position and it's Carissa to play and in
my opinion
White's very happy uh it's very hard for
for for black uh
to shall we say play for a win or play
my friend Jeremy solemen might say are
you playing for a loss because after for
example you trade everything here who's
got the better structure White's
structure is intact Black's pawns are
split and that's the Carissa Yip game
let's go to uh
by the way intimidating jacket what do
you think about that stand for chess no
less right yes exactly well actually yes
yes back for a second I think please it
looks very dangerous but even like F5
seems right
yeah like I'm not very happy about it
but the idea is that if you take a table
pawn and then I can have two pawns
running but yeah the pawn on E6 that's a
dangerous one and I don't think it would
be that easy to recapture it yeah it's
one of those times
if it lives you're dead if you take it
well maybe you'd be better but I think
it lives that's the problem yeah
it's like Frankenstein's monster be very
careful who you would like to dinner you
know the tiger might be uh thinking that
you're on the menu uh yeah F5 okay but
yes that's one of those things you
really got to be sure about like okay
like imagine I go uh Bishop to D4 yeah
and I'm just going to play rookie one
not necessarily giving you the pawn on
e4 you don't really want to take because
then you say to yourself well why did I
play F5 yeah so I feel like Bishop F6
here maybe okay maybe I'm gonna get the
pawn on E6 well let's have a look
are you are you going to actually win
this Pawn all right D5 D5 no I think we
had much easier ways much easier way yes
sorry Christian please tell me no just
take only four in Queen F5
uh back at the back of the month before
yeah let's just do it right at five and
I'm picking up the pawn on e4
oh that's so brutal immediately brutal
and the thing is you you can go Bishop
F6 Queen takes C4 Queen C8 but I think I
have rookie one and you're still not
getting the pawn on E6 wow that's very
nasty now if I take you with the Rook I
have this space Bishop A7
discover check so you're just one move
away from
reestablishing uh the material balance
now I do feel that your summer training
camp where you've got that tactics on
the brain you see these things rather
quickly
Discovery yeah Queen F5 so that so again
I I'm saying that Carissa she's still
got to equalize let's jump to the game
of Alice Lee because I think Alice Lee's
opponent
um in this game just as it comes up
Gracie she did it really really well
when we left it Alice was playing for A3
B4 B5 but Gracie got in a very nice
break I want to say timely before Alice
could play the move B5 and get D5
Gracie said well let me I'm gonna be the
first one I'm showing some teeth exactly
and by the way the these are very
dangerous pawns Alice is forced to
capture then capture and we've caught up
with the players but I'm thinking Queen
takes D5 and it's
wonderful I I mean I do agree that you
have to pass Pawn but at the moment I've
got that kind of controlled and I black
has traded off her weak weaknesses uh
she's looking at ideas of using her own
Center ponds with the move E5 E4 and I
think Alice is going to have a very hard
time
proving the imbalance in her favor I
think that she doesn't need to get the
knight from E1 out by the way the Knight
on Eve one is really you know not not
performing its keep it's it's you know
you gotta bring it to a much healthier
Square than E1 speaking of bringing
Knights to a healthier Square please
take a look at the Rochelle Wu position
she has an amazing move right now author
Queen to C8 first of all you highlighted
that night on ba that's ugly that's an
ugly night that is ugly but I can go
Knight deformer yes wow I would love to
get the Knight to E6 right oh and then
the night from being it is never coming
back oh no oh no that that is a
beautiful way of turning a positional uh
and material advantage into just a
simply dominating position this move of
Rochelle yeah we've got if she plays
Knight D4 I mean this is uh the uh in
the back yeah we've got on the screen
we're actually looking at Alice Lee's
game we need to go to the Rochelle uh
game there to match the class the
analysis board
this is where yeah this is where
Rochelle's played this really well I I
really uh pleased with all of her moves
beginning with the move G3 rookie three
Rook e one but I'm telling you this is
sacrifice coming on E5 I think uh her
opponent felt it she went Queen C8 all
the white pieces are really ready in
their best spots maybe the Knight to D4
yes exactly is that the only thing that
you can be worried about is Bishop G5
right
not to worry maybe the only thing that's
stopping you exactly at least you you
have to consider that move is probably
uh but 96 now yes is amazing you're
going to be an exchange congratulations
I I would also be very uh tempted by uh
well and why am I tempted by F4 because
it's just that all the queen side it's
it's just on the queen side right and
the bishop is so well open now from B2
just eyeing in that King G7 the Knight
is ready to jump to LEAP to E4 the night
is ready to go to E6 Christian news
concept I like it I like what you liked
immediately nice yeah we'd have four
yeah no I mean because yeah okay I lose
an exchange but so what look what I have
I think you were saying the night on B8
it's like dude you need to get out
because I want to get out and exactly
the the night's blocking this is like
the green position I mean yeah if you
ever get this type of position with
white pieces if you're enjoying your
life exactly the sun is shining Knight
to D4 finally land on the board that's
nice this is a game over it's like uh
these seniors they had a way about them
so
um I'm trying to really it's Anatoly
karpov so Anatoly karpov would like and
Boris Golf and others they like their
teas and their coffees at the board but
when they had a particularly good
position it was like they were
particularly meticulous
like they were enjoying themselves so
much they enjoyed their tea they enjoyed
the coffee they enjoyed everything that
was going on the cookie here
and I think we have Knight D4 by
Rochelle
wow and that is what a brilliant move
yeah nice very oh boy it all looks
really good guys yeah I have a question
for you what's happening in the Justin
Wang with The Blacklist against Andrew
Hong game well let's go I'm just saying
a bishop on E6 and I'm wondering the
first one what in the world is that
right
uh this was the game where the king went
to C7 and
you're saying did he really play Bishop
EC he played Bishop B6
I'm trying so let's imagine we take he
wants to take he wants to take and then
give a check and that's exactly so he
wants to separate the the king from The
Rook the immediate rookie eight I just
moved my Bishop so if we can get this
position excellent beautiful right you
got the tactic on the board but what if
I just take on E6 with the Rook
and get the two two pieces
then you I mean that's two pieces they
will say good job you found it and then
you just lost everybody all my coaches
have taught me that I bet two pieces for
the most part they are going to be
better than a rook right and you've been
taught very well I mean because this is
one of those positions where the two
pieces will overcome The Rook I mean the
only thing I can imagine is he's
thinking that this Rook on the
uh no but I don't want to put my
Wishbone H3 or maybe I do for a very
specific reason like where if your Rook
goes I'm just gonna go here I just
didn't want to see The Rook Rook land
but I want to be meaner okay we want to
go Bishop C4 check
and if you do try to get your Rook to G1
I'm going to trap it with the bishopone
F1
that's really mean and then you're sure
I'm not sure whoa whoa whoa are you sure
okay
um let's say I go King E1
wow
and then Knight E2
and then you get your Rook on H1 I will
trap that Rook yesterday I think you
will I I do I I Think You're Gonna Go F3
King F2 and even if you don't I'm going
to protect you and then I'm going to
laugh at it right right yeah your Rook
will never you never be in the game but
I agree Rook takes E6 let's take a look
was it a forest move or oh
as well you can transpose into uh it uh
so I just wonder if we had something
different to play so more or less we
caught up to the players in this moment
maybe this move Bishop D7 was a little
inaccurate uh was it a force move so if
it was no no not even close I mean you
can go rookie eight right
absolutely no rookie eight is incredibly
sensible just stop rookie seven
I thought he had some I think I think he
had an issue with Knight G6 he didn't
like to see Knight H5 although 66 on the
board and we do have the two pieces
versus The Rook he's saying my friend
what are he doing
he's a lapse of judgment from uh I mean
it's the first round right and sometimes
it happens that you just miss something
you are not yet in your full speed in
your first round
I had that issue I would lose first
rounds at like championships and then I
will have eight rounds to catch up with
my first loss right for me it was the
jet lag right where you know somehow I'm
just thinking to myself you know play
the first three rounds get through the
first three rounds you'll win the
tournament
if you're in good shape uh Rook E8 three
pieces uh two pieces I first of all that
whole concept of Bishop Retreats that
wasn't in my Consciousness at all I was
thinking you know I wanted to to use my
my two pieces so that was why I went
Bishop H3
um with the idea of just playing uh my
knight to H5
um
but this move
was that attractive to you this idea of
bringing the bishop to F1 yes yes you'd
like that I like that and let's see how
these let's let's profile the players
yeah so we have a great Master Andrew
honk age 18 Invitational rating above
2600 again 26 17 wow and he tied for a
third in the 2021 World open that was
the world open was always a rite of
passage I want to say for so many
America generations of American players
that would go to the World open in
Philadelphia and Justin here we have
international Master adjusting Wang age
17 Innovation rating 2577 and he's two
times Saint Louis I am Norm Invitational
winner wow he must enjoy his time in
Saint Louis definitely now when you say
the norm Invitational so we have those
classic round Robins that we host four
times a year and there's two sections so
there's the I am and the GM Norm
sections and he's one too wow so he's
got the IMs from from Louis he's like
that's how he got his style yeah right I
mean you know and he finally produced
and created here in St Louis
and here this is the Zoe Zoe with white
was completely winning this game and and
she still is still is although if I've
got that right there's a bishop on A2
what is there Bishop that's a queen oh
that's a queen a queen on A2 a little
bit lost wanting to come back but maybe
not many squares to go to
and we can see the body language she's
just
the white is still kind of thinking what
you do how to close but probably the
game is going to finish soon I have a
request can we go to the seniors
Championship let's do it because we have
one game we didn't really look at and
that's again Malik said katian against
Vladimir akopian the seat number one and
with white we have Malik kachen who is
actually the U.S coach since like
2010 forever I feel for the women's team
for the women's team the U.S uh women's
Olympic team captain captain I think
Captain correct yes Captain yes and okay
this is one of those
um
crazy wonderful Hedgehog games that my
generation of playoffs just love to play
the Hedgehog with black takes takes B5
Knight B6 captures so I'm just trying to
keep a running count
of the material balance right so Star
Trek Spock the character you know what's
the time and Spock would keep the time
in real time but here it's the material
okay we're in exchange
it's an exchange up oh wow for uh White
E5 why did we like E5 not 100 sure that
did invite Knight F5 we gave up a big
Square
Bishop to G5
okay
interesting because here again we have
this opportunity of check and pushing
the pawn to D4 is that on the board no
we we have captures on the board this
happened I think that position is on the
board right so Queen no capture capture
on F6 yes yes yes no I'm just saying I'm
I'm getting the position I haven't
gotten there yet so as black we have
this opportunity of getting two
connected past bonds
that's huge compensation but he went for
the material that he wanted to open up
the bishop maybe on A8 to have that
beautiful diagonal okay and so he did
there was a capture check
Queen E3 captures and we have now caught
up with I'm assuming we have to take so
we have
an exchange a bishop and a pawn
right foreign exchange that A5 may be
coming with eight kind of wanting to
take that pawn so I can
make a skewer oh that's a nice move yeah
A5 uh you know I like the I like the
exchange sacrifice okay I like Black's
position okay the the the trouble I'm
having is understanding that move here
because I'm thinking if I go check
and if you move The King and I go D4
I've got two connected past pawns this
bishop what what you're he's saying you
know like you want to blast open the
don't worry
Maybe
[Music]
Queen F2 maybe maybe Queen F2 yes Queen
F2 so that after
D4 and maybe Queen G3
I'm gonna move this Knight if you don't
take the Knight I'm gonna move it
um the the point that I hope to me the
problem is I have a bit on Knight H6 and
you resigned ah Knight age that's nice
wow oh wow
okay so I I can't move it that way I
have to move it in
WoW Knight eight oh sorry I didn't show
that to the audience so it's not age six
check
and Bishop F6 is mate it does seem like
this was just basically a taste Choice
well both options Queen B6 actually
three options Queen B6 D4 and the move
that he played uh D takes E4 or more or
less zero zero all of them
zero zero by the engine yes so very
balanced positions the position we have
currently on the board is very balanced
as well I'm stunned because it to to my
mind if I'm getting to pawns on D4 and
C4 and they're connected and passed you
are saying you have enough Advantage
a huge advantage and I'm saying triple
zeros who who would believe it by the
way uh we have some tweets from a social
media join the conversation there's a
way for you to absolutely to test us if
you will and here it comes it's in
Russian
do the seniors drop down
from their top rating due to not being
able to keep up with the current opening
theory yes or they just lose their
tactical sharpness yes
which is a bigger Factor yes
to the question and and I think this is
really really misunderstood
is all the seniors today
know more about Chess right now than
they've ever known so they should be
better players because their knowledge
is increase they work with other they
work with students so they have to keep
abreast of theory
they produce tactics they they they they
produce books they they know the tactics
they know their strategies the problem
is their energy I can show any one of
these players the latest Game of Magnus
Carlson and they'll go wow that's great
and they've may even guess the moves of
Magnus many of magnus's moves the
problem is trying to do it for five
hours nine days in a row and nine days
in a row keeping that energy levels uh
to the height that they used to have
that's that's uh the that's their real
problem because the brutal part about
Chess is you lose concentrate operation
for five ten minutes you make one
inaccuracy cost you the game exactly on
the spot on the spot just as we just did
that move Knight H6 also I feel it's a
lack of practice as well and then the
rust Factor myself okay and I'm you know
I'm only 30 something years of age but I
I don't play as often I play maybe a
couple of golly I thought senior
championships were on here
together the uh the opening ceremony the
junior so we were just hanging around
with Andrew Hong and Brandon Jacobson
and then who comes to me and he's like
why don't you play in uh this tournament
yourself and I'm like you know I'm too
old for the juniors I passed that time
and he was known in the seniors
we'll think of something good
but thank you for the Tweet really it's
the energy and one more tweet let's see
uh let's see if we can be uh what do you
see as the difference of stars between
the seniors and juniors a question on
Twitch from normal at Super
I'll take a quick shot at that I think a
lot of the senior uh
players well I mean we're the product of
Our Generation we we had these questions
about Queen's gambits grunfels Kings
Indians and we like those questions and
answers so a lot of the seniors play the
openings of their day if you will and
then the Juniors today are going to be
in fashion they're going to play the
latest and greatest that the
grantchester Champions all play Magnus
Carlson et cetera et cetera so I do see
the seniors as playing
um maybe more classical I I also have to
say that I think that juniors are just
really hungry in this tournament they
want to achieve things they want to
prove stuff they want to experience
stuff the Sinners they've done that a
lot of them want to actually Junior
Championships I mean they have worlds
Champion titles they work with the
greatest the best they are now coaching
the younger generation so they're more
like maybe more classic whereas the
juniors are willing to take risks and
relay uh prove stuff and those risks pay
off because let's not forget for the
juniors the title also gets them a spot
in the actual U.S championships which is
a big money tournament along with the
title and Prestige by the way did we
just see a result did Patrick Wolf
resign yes we just have a result in the
game Gregory kaidenov and Patrick Wolfe
oh wow what happened there yeah exactly
we we took our Eye For a Moment away and
something happened as yeah Gregory has
won according to our score when we land
left it actually it was this moment that
we left it it was a long thing and we
were debating ourselves between A5 B6
and Castle check the video
[Laughter]
all the all the broadcasts are archived
so people can that's true yeah look it
over Rook C8 was Patrick's choice but
the move we were espousing Knight A5
that was the drawback because now we get
to play C4 B4 C5 Knight A5 came C4 and
Gregory
went on apparently to win very
comfortably well he's got in this whole
Queen there was a funny moment after
this move C5 this is I believe move 20
yeah
um this position has been played once
before no way yes some random game but I
don't know this is a this is no Theory
this cannot be considered Theory right
but it was played it was in the database
before oh my goodness so where was the
novelty then it's a good question let's
see because this looks immediately after
taking on C5 was not the move play but
by the way these are two players 2300 25
60. perhaps its correspondence I'm not
100 sure but
um it's not names that I can easily
recognize uh after I remove C5 G3 was
the move and by the way this is the best
move by the engine
um after taking on C5 D6 already white
has a tremendous Advantage yeah
tremendous Advantage huge and in fact uh
it looks like a very very smooth
conversion all the way through Gregory
just traded down it was an ex
okay he won an exchange he traded it
down and then he said look my Pawn on D7
so strong and then it's Rook versus
bishop and Rook is going to capture all
the pawns because the bishop can never
defend them they're all
light squares and we have a passport on
a A2 that is going to get a queen and by
the way what was the times on the clock
as well you know you're adding up all
the lights advantage and he was ahead
two and a half minutes now I mean you're
right so what a great start to the
tournament for Gregory cardano
absolutely uh shabalov our defending
champion this was the the imbalance of
Bishop versus knight I liked this bishop
on A8 versus the Knight on F3 I wanted
to go to the game of Doug root because
that game
somehow where am I where's Doug's game
versus shabalov oh that was the one with
yes that was it sorry what about the
game between Dmitry grevich and Igor
novikov did they like survive there it's
so cool no the short answer and the easy
answer is it was no shockingly enough
he's not surviving anything to D7 and I
think there's a lot of uh choices here
Knight C6 that seems like absolutely the
most forcing but it wouldn't have
surprised me that Queen G4 also or queen
H5 for that matter just Knight C6 takes
takes
uh the night on e4 was hanging there's
an exchange by the way
which he captured Bishop G5
Queen F3
and Zoe I believe has one
uh her game so our first results coming
in are victories
victories Galore here I I think Igor is
just busted actually The Rook is coming
with gain of tempo and everything's
going on
Rochelle's winning so let me just see
let me just make sure about the Zoe game
by the way
I'm pretty sure she's Zoe oh yeah
Zoe just won her game oh yeah there is
an extra Rook we've seen that uh result
a long time ago yeah being officiated
yes yeah and this could have ended a
long time ago as well yeah she ended up
picking up the bishop uh I I didn't know
if the bishop was it was a queen or a
bishop on A2 by the way but she did end
up picking up the bishop on B4 and
winning that game I mean there was the
scheme of Queen A3 I think once white
found that move 17 yeah and it was
it's it's kind of hidden right here
right here from Black's point of view
black is thinking I got this i got this
I'm gonna Castle the D4 Pawn is hanging
the H4 Pawn is hanging
I'm good I'm in good shape until you see
this move Queen A3 and it's sort of like
oh that's the cold shower move because
now the king is trapped in the center
you no Escape you're welcome to capture
either of these pawns but the Rooks are
coming into the center and then after
Bishop E7 everything just went like a
charm for white I mean when you look at
the white white moves just every move is
an improvement right you get the Rook to
double you improve your Bishop you
double the Rooks everybody is acting
towards that Bishop attacking it there
exactly she pin pieces the the pin piece
on E7
black white just brought everybody to
attack the thin piece she took the rook
and
went on to convert but we have a guest
in uh Studio over to you Christian
Gregory a perfect start to uh this
year's campaign for you just a Flawless
game it felt like how do you feel from
your perspective
um maybe it was Flawless so obviously
during the game I didn't know that but
um
felt great to play the tournament felt
great to play the first round I was very
nervous uh but you still get nervous
always nervous yeah always nervous
um uh Patrick had a long break from
chess uh but I didn't feel like it would
make a huge difference so I was prepared
for a very complex fight
um and
I played the variation against neither
with F3 Bishop E3 I played for the first
time in my life so obviously that also
was very nervous because there is so
much Theory
um was that part of your strategy the
fact that he hasn't played in a long
time perhaps he doesn't know all the
intricacies of this no no no I
recovery opponent very seriously so no
no I expected him to know the theory yes
and and and he did but I played
the variation with kingside Castle which
is uh not the main line
uh many many years ago we analyzed this
position with Judith Polgar okay
this idea in general like we were
talking about like if they play H5 why
can White Castle kingside and H5 would
be just a weakness so it was more like
on the conceptual level we didn't
analyze too deep I didn't have any notes
on it but this idea that this variation
is playable stayed in my mind and I
decided wait for him to play H5 and then
short Castle because that's a very nice
idea correct and it felt like he also
understood that once you place the
Knight on A5 your attack comes just like
much easier right and this was a
critical moment I believe after Castle
he played Rook to C8 perhaps B6 was the
only right that's the move I expected
that's the movie you were expecting
right right and and I actually
even regret a little bit I was thinking
maybe instead of Castle I should play
Knight F5 right away I wasn't sure yes
uh maybe that would be good okay I see
computer says all zeros right so so
typical the typical yes right and after
Castle B6 still all zeros but it remains
are very comfortable right it's a game
it's a game yeah and after that it just
felt like
you are in the driver's seat you had an
easier plan as well and you're putting a
lot of pressure on your opponent
wouldn't you feel like you're taking
over completely
uh
probably after C5 after the move C5
right right after C5 I I felt like uh
yeah I should be okay but still I had to
kind of uh revisit my calculation
because uh originally when I played C5
um uh I didn't take Rook takes C5
seriously so so when we went at one
point uh here yes right so so when he
played when he took on C5 I thought this
is just winning yes and then uh when uh
then I realized okay he can shake with a
rook and I had to
um uh calculate again and I found Knight
B3 and then yeah and this was this was I
mean Bishop C3 and after Bishop C3 I
thought I have a choice uh if if he
would play Bishop C3 I thought I thought
I'd have a choice between Queen C1 and
queen F2 and I felt like both probably
are good I think I I would play probably
queen of two but and that's the best
movie in the position yes yeah and if it
takes you probably think I just check I
just check and uh yeah and and uh look
to C8 and now you defend the pawn right
or oh no no I was thinking Knight C5
Knight C5 D7 uh that's even easier yeah
yeah yeah I mean and I will have uh Pawn
for two piece for two pawns uh sorry
piece for two pawns but you also have an
attack correct but with Queens on the
board I should be able to create an
attack on a king So Gregory
congratulations a great start for you go
get some rest we'll see you tomorrow
thank you Gregory a quick question for
you uh first of all good to see you uh
nice to see you I mean it's a reunion
with uh the seniors uh quick question
this one comes from Twitter and we
thought we'd put you to work I mean
after all and the question from the
Twitter was
Gregory what is the difference between
junior chess and Senior chats
the uh
um I mean it's obviously very different
right so uh in general uh the answer is
obvious uh in junior Chef you will see
much more uh decisions based on
calculation and in senior chess uh you
would see many more decisions based on
field
right uh but uh as a senior I know that
if I want to stay in this game and
compete with Juniors I need to keep my
calculation sharp
I thought the answer had to do with good
looks but
I think you you presented very
very much good luck in your uh in your
tournament yeah congratulations on your
first round thank you very much very
nice uh just looking at some of the
other Senior Games I just pulled up the
game Joel Benjamin Max delugie they're
in a rook and pawn end game looks like
it's just heading for it is equality and
it looks like it's going to be remain
equal equals zeros after the move Rook
C5 this is the game Dimitri gurvich
versus Igor novikov and everything is
going in uh dima's way he's an exchange
of material ahead
and very importantly he's also got an
initiative once he plays moves Rook C6
and or queen C7 pardon me Queen G3 with
the idea of Rook C7 just loving
everything about uh White's position but
let me stop myself
we do indeed Zoe for of all welcome to
the Saint Lucia's Club welcome to the
junior girls competition tell us about
your initial feelings playing here at
the St Lucia's Club so obvious
ly I'm playing here and the first time
didn't go so well so I have absolutely
no expectations for this time but I'm
glad I started off the first round
nicely
and that was a great show of good
opening preparation I have to say but
also great middle game execution after
she allowed you uh to keep her King in
the center is that the moment where you
felt like you're taking over yeah I felt
like I was taking over well the first
one where I the first moment where I
really liked my position was when I
played E4 out of the opening and um E4
wasn't part of my preparation at that
point I was already kind of lost but um
I was like okay I can isolate upon but
why is that black skiing is still stuck
in the center so I really like my
position here and then later once I
played Queen A3 I knew my position was
really good that was the key move yeah
Queen 283 did you feel like she missed
that little detail I feel like she might
have missed that because I missed it as
well I mean up until that point I was
planning Rook E1 and then but after king
f8 or something the king is running to
G7 and all I have is an isolated Pawn
Yeah but I realized Queen A3 to stop in
qf8 would be really strong and then um
this position my I already have a really
good attack yeah yeah and I think uh the
advantage is pretty obvious on your side
she tried to defend but you kept pretty
much so Bishop takes C7 movement yes I
think I could have played Queen G3 like
I figured it out after I moved that was
probably a slightly more precise yeah 23
this would be a really pretty attack
some Queen G6 Rook F6 stuff yeah yeah I
I think this is just ignition thing and
then the rest of the game I was like why
didn't I just play Queen
still a great way to start your campaign
what are your Ambitions for this
tournament um this tournament I want to
not embarrass myself and play some good
chess well that's you definitely started
that well guys join the conversation
anyway our congratulations very nice the
queen G3 moment when you miss queen G3
we've actually caught that one too I'm
thinking yeah it would have been nice
but very good yeah congratulations on
finding the queen A3 move I think that
was a really very crucial move good job
and a very great start to the tournament
how do you feel now after you know
crossing the first first round and
managing to win well I already did
better than last time I think I started
with half a point out of seven so I'm
already doing a lot better than last
time which is really nice right well
then congratulations and good luck in
the rest of the tournament thank you
absolutely Zoe and just as we go on
break once again I just want to say for
the Women's Championship for pardon me
for the girls Championship
um our our favorites aren't doing that
great Carissa she's actually
slightly worse I mean yeah yeah yeah
kind of equalish but not easy and for
Alice also so as we uh
as we get prepared for our break uh I'm
just saying the the favorites in the
girls section aren't doing that great
one other game I just wanted to say
reference before we do go on break is
Benjamin Joel Benjamin I thought that
we're going to agree to a draw it's
again it's two versus two
um I'd be very very surprised if somehow
the players didn't make a threefold
repetition remember
Shake of hands exactly what happened
about to see a shake of hands here
and you see they found immediately the
repetition by the way the more yeah and
the the bring over the chief Arbiter
crispr to say we're going back and forth
with the move Rook to G3
yeah established a position for a third
time remember the rule is you have to
write down your move before you make it
yeah so I feel like Chris is very
killer about making making it accurately
yeah an accurate claim
I think that's a very very good idea to
be accurate you want your Arbiters to be
sticklers for the world I mean just you
know just interpret it exactly the way
it's written because that's their job
right that's their job that's what it's
all about and uh well as we take a break
I don't know we've got more vegan
material prepared for you but whatever
it is you're going to enjoy it and we'll
see you on the other side
[Music]
thank you
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as high
profile tournaments that attract the
world's best players become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischesclub.org to claim your
membership today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the games the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in-store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
hello I'm women's current Master William
Dr jonova I will be doing social media
for the US Juniors and seniors chess
championships follow us in our social
media and get more exciting behind the
scenes action
foreign
chess club is the Premier chess facility
in the United States and is among the
best in the world thanks to co-founders
Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield and Rex
sinkfield the St Louis chess club is a
non-profit organization committed to
promoting the game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American Cup as
well as high profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over 2
000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chess piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
monthly concerts and much more whether
you are a beginner or a professional
there is something for everyone to learn
here at the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy free admission to our rotating
exhibitions in our Galleries and sign up
for chess events family friendly
programming and art classes and don't
forget to stop by our award-winning gift
shop Q Boutique and Shop a wide
selection of Chess related merchandise
for more information on current exhibits
please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
hello I'm women's Grandmaster William
Tucker jonova I'm doing social media for
the U.S Juniors and seniors
championships here in San Luis follow us
for more exciting behind the scenes
content
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program in the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grand Master
varuja nicobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between at-risk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since 2019. the St
Louis chess club has also created a
chess merit badge for the scouts BSA
quickly becoming one of the most popular
badges with more than 2 250 000 Scouts
earning the badge since 2011. students
of chess can also pick up a copy of read
and write Jess thanks to Club co-founder
Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield anyone can
learn how to understand chess notation
in no time we view chess as a valuable
educational tool learn more about our
Scholastic programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
chess and St Louis is back with nine
major tournaments throughout the year
seasonal Classic Events are back the
summer chess classic August 2nd followed
up with the St Louis Norm Invitational
and the winter chess classic wraps up
the year in December September brings
back everyone's favorite chess night
Alex where some of the world's best
don't even know what's coming and
compete for a 150 000 prize fund 30
players across three Fields come
together in St Louis for the U.S juniors
girls and Senior championships starting
July 15th in partnership with U.S chess
the best in the U.S fight to be the
nation's best and a four hundred
thousand dollar prize fund in October as
the U.S and U.S women's championships
takes place in the chess capital of
America a year full of action-packed
Chess is just getting started all
broadcasts are available on our St Louis
chess club YouTube and twitch.tv
channels
thank you
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back let's
take a look at some of the results of
the national championships beginning
with the girls
so we have tank who won her first game
against mangalam
and she was so happy because she said
she started with a half out of seven in
her last outing so uh she's always been
and in the seniors
seniors we have two results so we have
Benjamin against Lugia that was a draw
right and then we have kaidanov against
wolf where kailan of one exactly in fact
we're going to tee up Joe Benjamin in
just a second here uh and ask him about
his game uh with Maxine it looked like
it was a steady game throughout neither
player really had anything and you said
that's the start you have to a
tournament right just make a few draws
well you just want to get into the
groove of the tournament and I think
Gregory kaidanov who earlier was on the
show said it really well like uh we
haven't played that much we don't really
know our form until we've actually
played a few games and gotten gotten the
tactile feel and we do have a guest and
we he's with Christian Joel we often
talk about the seniors Championship as
not as theoretical but I have to say
today you guys were fighting a deeply
theoretical battle
well it's it's an opening that I played
last year against uh Nick deferman and I
put put a lot of time into it
um in in previous outings Max has played
in a completely unsound way uh this
variation for black he did Once in a
game against federovic many years ago
and he did it in the Blitz game against
me in the park but I had no had no
illusions that he was going to play to
to play like that today so he he was uh
he was pretty well prepared but then we
got to a point where I made what I
thought was an obvious move and he said
that it was unusual which one was that
this one H3
I mean that's what my computer says to
do yeah I think that's the point I think
F4 is the only idea for white to and the
thing is the position uh it's all about
timing you know because why it is wants
to open the position for the bishop pair
yes and you know black voices idea of
playing Knight D7 to E5 after after this
break a trade right so it's it's a
question of uh who got gets there in
time I thought he was not quite in time
but then didn't seem that I had much
anyway yes and he actually played uh
quite well were you worried at any point
that you might end up in a strategically
worse position for the similar fact that
you know you had no no because because I
saw concretely that that I was going to
dissolve that pawn yeah I mean if he had
time to put a knight in E5 and put a
Pawn on C5 yes I would be worried about
that position but you got the C5 in I
got it and I thought it would do a
little more and no probably I could put
after Rook FDA it's possible to play
better so somehow it requires some
subtlety and I think it does say that
Queen D4 is the best move in the
position it says it's the best move
really okay yeah Queen to D4 F6 it felt
like both of you played quite a precise
game I have to say so it was it was uh
correct to trade off the minor pieces
very correct I I mean it seemed like it
was very drawish to me but I didn't see
anything better yeah Joel uh you don't
play that much but you whenever you come
to this one it feels like you you come
prepared how much preparation do you do
before this event in general well this
year I I think I I put more time in it
than usual because I I made the decision
that I was didn't want to be working
really hard every day you know putting
in two or three hours and I've done that
in the past and it's just a physically
debilitating so I kind of think that my
you know my work is basically done for
for all the games I'm hoping already wow
yeah so like really I didn't uh today I
was really just just checking some lines
but in hindsight I you know I wish I had
to check this a little bit more you know
like um like Queen E7 was not a move
that I had uh the the my my computer was
saying black shirts by Bishop E6 in that
position and I just sort of followed the
main line which is very silly you always
have to put some Alternatives in there
because you never know what your
opponent was going to do so I was
feeling very stupid when he played Queen
E7 that I didn't have that worked out
when I could have but I probably
couldn't have done any better than I did
no it was a very correct game guys join
the conversation uh congratulations Joe
uh for the preparation I want to say
because that's the way I feel that when
you come to the event you can't spend
three hours preparing and then think
that you're gonna play a beautiful
five-hour game you're already
energy is is down so I like the fact
that you're doing all your preparing in
advance
yeah I mean that's it's the that way for
me the key is is really to have uh to
have enough energy to play the games and
um you know also I I tend not to sleep
that well so I'm tired to begin with so
I you know I need to conserve whatever
energy I can
well good luck in your campaign I have
one more question about the Hall of Fame
is that your first time playing a
tournament there because we used to play
at the settlers chess club or a Sub-Zero
how do you like the space there you know
I've been I've been here many times and
it seems every year it's different you
know I just sort of you know got gotten
adjusted to playing the games uh on the
corner like last year and suddenly it's
in in the Hall of Fame and uh so that's
uh just a new a new layout again but
um whatever room they put us in it's
pretty pretty much the same it's it's
high quality conditions there's plenty
of space air conditioning seems to be
working fine and there's you know snacks
and Beverages and um
so it's it's all good
um today we we played in that sort of
little cubby hole in the corner which I
think is nice but they've told us that
we're going to rotate into the main room
as well so you know hopefully that will
be just as pleasant
perfect thank you well good luck in the
rest of the tournament I appreciate that
it doesn't hurt to have it absolutely
absolutely I just wanted to turn our
game to Alice Lee for a second because
when I left it Gracie made her life
quite difficult for herself uh she there
was a straight on D5 and I expected a
very simple Queen captures D5 there
would be trades but black will be fine
she took with the bishop and she got
herself into a jam right wow these
Bishops dancing around and now suddenly
now suddenly this light squared Bishop
ended up on this silly Square B3 where
it was vulnerable to Rook to D3 and then
to Rook F2 look what happened next a
very nice little tactic Bishop comes to
C4 hitting the Rook on A2 hitting the
Rook on uh E6 and why did this really
turn into Alex his favor the moment you
see the current position
bang and that's it that's just you're
gone it's Suddenly It's lights out and
there's nothing you can do
a terrible pin
after the move Rook F6 uh Knight B6
Bishop back B7 check Bishop B8 and now
right it's it's it's
as the Dutch would like to say hoopless
it's hoopless resignation resignation
time so Alice uh really I think Gracie's
decision to recapture on D5 was in a
strange way her down falling if she
recaptures the queen I think she has an
easy path to to uh to equality uh and
now she just
got jammed up with her with her Bishop
after this move Rook F2 so uh Alice Lee
uh I want to say along with Carissa yep
our pre-tournament favorite doing good
Karissa on the other hand uh we might
see a resignation maybe we can stay with
this with Alice for a second yeah and in
cariso's game is not that much no
nothing is happening on the contrary uh
that that game looks to be a certain
certain draw we'll go back to the Alice
League game because we do expect that
after Bishop takes C4 Bishop C4 takes F7
I beg your pardon King takes F7 Knight
takes check King E6 Knight C6 oops that
Bishop
is uh is lost
and you actually have to work not to
lose more than that you have to go King
D6 King C7 right to not uh to allow the
queen also upon the queen yeah very even
then the knights will just take business
of all the pawns exactly this is an easy
let's see how would I do it I think I
would do it like this okay Bishop to b86
yeah
and uh munching the pawns uh one by one
um so so Alice on her way to Victory
there and let me just go to the Juniors
because they're not getting all the
attention they deserve they are after
all uh the future so let's just uh when
we left this game this was uh Arthur uh
remember it was that Queen D4 uh
right here it was this a very nice uh
Intermezzo move check
so the king takes and then Knight F5
Queen E6
this looks like a very nice
game by Arthur Queen to d8
yeah he just this massive threat of
Queen Seven followed by Queen B8 mate
and we might see a resignation here uh
this is this is really really bad let's
jump to
um one of our uh well I think he's
actually Jacobson isn't he the number
one seed yes he's the number c ahead of
me by Invitational rating by
Invitational rating and uh time trouble
is we saw that clock time yeah
okay so we have a result Alice
Alice on her game
and by the way we expect that along with
Zoe Rochelle also is winning her game
but sorry I am still with the Brandon
game for a moment yeah because he
sacrificed the pawn right yeah to attack
opponents opponent's king so how is that
going
but he has only one minute on the clock
wow guys it's going well but the problem
is the time right now it really is a
problem because with one minute and this
is never going to get any easier
right this is not the Brandon Jacobson
game
um but uh the the The
Branding game okay whites upon up but in
my view white suffering because Rook
takes
Bishop takes
or Bishop takes Rook takes is on Black's
agenda and
the the white king is more vulnerable
than the black king right now I mean I'm
actually looking for a defense yeah
black is also transferring the Knight to
F5 which is a real problem because the
desirable Knight G1 knight uh F5 is the
issue I'm I'm going to have to play
Bishop F2 and I'm thinking first of all
there's Knight F4 H1 Rook H1 I love that
move too by the way Rook H1 with the
idea of Queen H2 and Knight if you want
to check made a bit too nice I see it
the patterns are there but uh it's
looking really bad I Christian I I'm
even looking for a defense for white is
there a good defense it is bad but it's
not losing terrible it's not losing for
white black is slightly better but white
does have to be extremely precise with
his defense and in fact it has to be a
counter offense in this position he has
to play D4 okay
so that after Knight F5 I would assume
just take on E5 perhaps
Bishop takes E5 yes
you can get away with that I think I can
night all right let's say Rook day C5
I'm not sure why but let's say C5 Rook
takes E5 Pont takes Rook takes right
I'm sorry blindness blindness ah
Ah Ah that's important okay so I guess
he just with this move d4 the computer
just wants to get rid of an iPhone G6
yes that's the defender that covers
everything around the black king
precisely and if you can take on E5 and
force this exchange perhaps you get some
ideas with this queen to G5 move
defensive ideas in fact because rukesh 3
is a big problem right and indeed I I
was being myopic there uh Bishop takes F
by the way Joe he may his game may be
over but you know like he's gonna take
advantage of the fact that he can watch
some of the other games uh Bishop takes
F3 that's the best move yes
that is the best move after D4 and then
how how would the lines continue I would
have to go Queen to F2 okay there is a
oh wow there's a queen to F2 these are
not easy moves to make guys there's a
sighting on F7 by the way but there's
also a sighting of Rook F5
this queen F2 I have to say it's not an
easy practical move to make and now you
have to take on F3 allow Queen takes H3
this is not easy stuff guys no and he
did play by the way Knight G1 he didn't
go for that yeah this is losing
and that was the first move I was
looking at too and then it was just it
was it was an avalanche of black pieces
and that's exactly what it is coming
against my king nice F5 I wanted to ask
about the clocks what were the clock
times so the clock time is uh Jason link
white has 12 minutes
that's comfy yeah but Brandon he has one
minutes 13 seconds so he's definitely
hoping that his increments will help
guide him but okay Knight F5 is a is a
Tempo gaining move that's an easy one to
play that's an easy one and he made it
it is happening and he started
retreating with all the pieces as white
and black is coming after you it's not a
nice feeling so Queen F2 unfortunately
it does defend the bishop but only for a
turn and The Bishop's trapped after Rook
G5 which is why you have to drop it back
with the bishop but then whether it was
Knight F4 first or Rook H1 it sure is
great for Brandon By the way let me
pause my thought here as Rochelle when
we saw it it looked awful that was nice
that was a nice game yes oh Rochelle had
uh you know dominant uh position she won
the pawn on F5 and she played tonight so
Rochelle Wu has her first point against
Iris Moe three decisive results so far
and the girls game again I'm going to
just stay with The Branding game for
just a moment because I'm I am expecting
to move Bishop F2 I wanted to tease you
for just a moment would you play Knight
to F4 or would you play Rook H1 here the
reason I'm asking is by the way guys I
think we have another result that is
arturug Zoo versus Balaji oh wow what a
great ending let's take a look at it
Yasser I'm so sorry this looks so pretty
what a great tactic let me bring up
sorry that's the seniors
yeah I had it where are you right here
Arthur you're at the bot oh look at that
so when we left it we just left it at
the move Queen to d8 and we saw that
White's intentions were nasty he wants
to go Queen to C7 to B8 mate so black
captured upon said go ahead play Queen
C7 let me capture your Rook white Drop
The Rook down and after Rook D1 Queen C8
Queen takes uh B5 uh
prepping to defend Quincy Center Queen
C8
Bishop captures and we have a
cooperation between the rook and the
Knight kind of in the corner checkmating
the black king they call this the
Arabian name I'm just not sure how it
got that uh uh label but yeah that's a
very very nice so what a big upset of
Arthur against Balaji dagupati
absolutely rating wise
what were you saying about a 300.
Christian was saying 300 already yikes
and let's just refresh our results page
uh starting with the girls
let's take a look so we have results in
games wow three whites all they want so
Lee against prasanna 1-0 tank one
against mangalam and Wu against Mo also
white one here okay and in the Juniors
so far only one result Arthur wants a
get one against
um dagupati
[Music]
draw here yes Benjamin Drew glugy and
kaidano we was a guest here one against
four exactly and we have another result
to add to that it looks like a draw
there no no no no no no no no no
Viking sorry the white king is on e4 so
white is one Katy on one I mean they're
getting a copian that's that's a big
result I wanted to say is it another
upset doesn't Vladimir come in as the
number one seed perhaps the rating
favorite yes yes by the Invitational
writing he's CD number one oh my
goodness so wow uh so this is the really
updated by the way it looks like a
whitewash I'm seeing a lot of white
Wings
in the studio so let's go to Christian
Alice successful return here at the
Saint Louis chess club but they wasn't
easy you got a very decent position out
of the opening but it felt like she
slowly got back into the game how did
you leave this game
um yeah so the opening I actually didn't
really like the position I got after
um I saw like maybe I shouldn't have
ampazant like DJ C6
um did you know that you're following
yasser's good friend Victor no I didn't
know this game I wasn't really preparing
for like the specific line
um I mean I thought it would be possible
but A5 I think usually instead of 85 the
main move is F5
um and then there's some like lines
after that that's right um but so after
I thought I knew like A5 had to be like
better for me
um I was expecting like 97.91 F5 uh but
she played net H6 which I think is also
okay yeah
um more or less I think Knight G5 at
this did you consider this move oh no I
didn't this was a really good option for
you it was giving you a tremendous
Advantage yeah that looked very good
just so that after Knight H6 then you
get the Knight to E6 and this one feels
good but you play Knight E1 and uh it
felt like slowly slowly she was getting
back into the game especially after this
move D5 yeah actually I felt like after
D5
um my position was more pleasant to play
like I knew objectively I should
probably still like I shouldn't be too
much better but
um I thought if I was ever able to trade
queens and game would be pretty Pleasant
for me
um because I have the past be upon the
bee Pawn yeah um
but uh yeah after
um this
yeah after rookie six I thought Rick D1
my position was quite good
um Bishop B3 and then I calculated this
line uh
oh with like Bishop A2 work she had this
move route to B8 maybe the best option
in the position yeah I thought like I
would
I would have D7 but I guess like after
Bishop C4 then she can take with another
E6 and then I'll lose the exchange fast
yes and of course this is not easy stuff
and finally now she gets your B Pawn
right with bishop f8 and things of that
nature but it still remained very
complicated and it felt like she fell
through the cracks after this move
Bishop to A2 yeah after I Bishop a two I
was very happy they
um
I calculated like roku6 B5
um and yeah my Bishops are just too good
I thought like her work on E6 has very
few squares to go
how do you generally feel in the first
few rounds uh does it take a while for
you to warm up or do you feel like
you're very dangerous in the first few
rounds what type of player are you
um I mean I guess it depends I think
last year I started out uh pretty poorly
like I got one out of the first four
rounds
um and I actually never won a first
round game in the US Junior Heroes
Championship so getting this first round
to win was nice and I guess it also
depends on like the parents who you're
playing what color you get
um so overall I don't think like I have
like a specific very good first round or
very bad first round although
um it's probably leaning more towards
like a very bad first down to feel like
a slower start yeah
guys any questions for Alice oh first of
all Alice uh we just want to say
congratulations you've been having a
kind of breakout year for yourself uh
everything's going so well what are you
doing right
um our viewers want to know
yeah I've been playing in like a lot of
strong tournaments
um I had like two back-to-back
tournaments right before this uh and
like another tournament a few
tournaments in June so I think just like
playing in these really strong
tournaments have given me a lot more
experience playing against strong
players
um and that definitely has like helped
me improve in the past year
your big rival in this event is Carissa
Yip tell us about the Rivalry what are
you looking forward to in this
tournament when you meet
um yeah I
before so this will be the first time uh
that definitely should be a very
interesting game I think it's in round
seven
um so isn't one of the later rounds so
for now I'll just focus on I guess the
next few rounds but um it would
definitely be like really great to play
here since she was one of my biggest
Idols that I looked up to for so many
tournaments and to play against her
would just be a very good experience
wow that's so amazing like you see some
19 year olds being like role models for
13 years old that's amazing I'm
surprised that you never met because I
know both of you already competed in the
U.S women's championships but I guess
Karissa maybe did not buy the year you
did yeah I think Carissa
um played 2020 uh 2021
um she skipped last year yeah she
skipped last year and that was the first
year that I was in because of college
yes yes wow nice well good luck for the
rest of the tournament absolutely uh
Alice uh everybody's cheering for you
accept your opponents
I just wanted to say uh in the game
um Brandon is Jacobson sacrificed Rook
very nicely how did that happen yeah
well that was a we we I was asking you
would you have played Rook H2 here or
would you played Knight F4 the reason I
wanted to ask you that question was
because are you afraid of Queen G5
anyway he played Rook H2 remember
because you were playing Rook H1 even
even wow and queen G5 came and
Bishop C8 he's just basically saying hey
dude I'm just going to kick you out I'm
going to play F7 F6 and then after the
move d4 F6 game Queen back and bang
wow not wasting time with Knight F4 just
bang like night takes
uh uh sorry King takes Knight F4 check
and now you've got to go King to H1 now
Queen H2
Queen eight
I was just thinking if I could just play
Bishop H3 right all I've got to do is
play Bishop H3 I thought about bringing
the queen to H2 and G2 Checkmate okay I
like that one too right
but we have another uh first round of
the victories are coming the hot and
Furious and uh Christian you you're with
guests Rochelle a victory a good result
but more importantly a very
aesthetically pleasing game as well you
must be feeling quite proud right yeah I
am tell us about the opening phase the
middle game where did you feel like
you're taking over the initiative after
she put F5 and I took on F5 I was not
really expecting her to play Knife six
um I thought the idea of Queen E8 was
killed Knight B6 and like go Knight A4
or something okay so
um and I thought this way she takes on
F5 with the bishop and uh I don't know I
just thought this is her plan so Knight
F6 took me by surprise do you know Iris
have you ever played again
so it was a new opponent did you do some
preparation before the tournament Joel
was mentioning that he prepared against
all his opponents before the tournament
did you get any prep
um
I didn't
honestly I needed a break from chess
before this tournament
so um no I didn't I didn't really know
who was playing until yesterday is it
about motivation what is about that you
need that break I was just like playing
extremely bad in my last three
tournaments like I
um I withdrew from all of them because I
just like
I just didn't feel very motivated yet
but this is definitely a good game to
get that motivation back uh and you
found and we were all quite impressed
with this move G3 just a simple move
that completely kills her whole game
because she cannot take on F5 anymore
um and this was the move that you must
have felt quite good about just giving
up the exchange getting the Knight on E6
definitely taking over and finished it
off in style after that Rochelle uh
you've participated in this event quite
a few times you've never wanted what is
your ambition for answering you want to
win it finally this year I mean I'm kind
of just taking it game by game like I'm
definitely giving myself like zero
pressure because
um this isn't my first year playing and
I still have a few years after this so
it's like I don't think it's the biggest
of deals if I don't perform Super well
so I just want to have a good time
excellent guys any questions so Rochelle
congratulations on your first round of
Victory what if spectacular game we
really love the 94 move and I have a
question how do you usually start your
tournaments do you because we talked
about other players who maybe start off
badly losing the first game do you
usually win your first round or do you
have troubles with first rounds
um it honestly depends like if it's an
open tournament
um if I'm playing down
first round then I typically
I think I typically win but like
sometimes you know there's hiccups
um
I usually I think I usually have pretty
decent first rounds
good that's good for you just
congratulations and keep up the good
work thank you absolutely
for the girls uh the the results are
coming in uh hot and heavy we have four
out of five results already uh one draw
wow so only Yen draw against Atwell and
then we have three wins Lee against
Persona Tang against mangalam and
against Mo and our uh Carissa yeah uh
the pre-tournament hot rating favorite
um well it's they're now in a rook and
pawn end game which is well four versus
four and should be a draw but there's a
little bit of an imbalance so
I can't call it a draw there's not going
to be some forcing sequence and we see
that Curry size only one minute to go
but they already reached move 40 so
they're gonna get additional 30 minutes
yeah I'll get there 30 minutes and let's
go to the Juniors and the Jacobson game
what happened there exactly yeah
inquiring minds want to know so we have
Jason laying against Brandon Jacobson
Queen H2 did happen after Knight F4
check and what move what number are they
on
35. okay so time travel is still a
factor Knight G3 check King f
the bishop of course is pinned
so we capturing where's the killing blow
guys exactly where is the killing we
will find it give us a second
so if we
if we play Knight takes
that might be the money move guys wow
made on F1 and if Bishop takes then we
Checkmate on G1 correct
that's it wait so they can run right
King D1 we've gotta run but if you King
E1 we can capture the rook and play
Bishop to G4
that looks really strong well the thing
is like very strong maybe take and then
Queen F1 oh we cannot okay so we first
of all white has to play the move King
D1 to stop mate right
and is is is the clock a factor for we
saw we saw Brandon Jacobson just looking
at the score sheet because he still has
four moves to make before getting
um 30 minutes and he has 53 seconds
foremost to make to get 30 minutes
yeah I think after King D1 I might just
be able to take both of your Rooks or at
least get close to that
like I take only four first and then I
go for Queen F1
so uh sorry uh what's the line question
I take one Rook Knight takes Ponte and
then I try to take the other one Queen
F1 and if I block you I lose the Knight
if you block with the bishop you lose
tonight if you block with a queen I
think I have Bishop G4 and a very nice
Checkmate after no I saw her check my
bathroom
going there okay how are you still alive
yeah
King City too
how am I still alive I still go Queen D3
and then I take on D4 and then try to
include my Rook as well
I mean I have all my pieces playing yeah
it's remarkable that white is not just
yeah after Bishop C2 I'm not convinced
yeah I mean you you you you your Jedi
mind trick hasn't completely convinced
me either just a second so Queen G2
we're expecting King D1 and we're still
trying to uh bring this game to rest put
it to rest I said
but as we do that we toil in trouble we
have a guest in studio with you
Christian Arthur first of all uh welcome
to St Louis welcome to the Juniors uh
this was an incredible start to the
tournament for you probably the biggest
upset up to this point trust a bit about
your emotions right now yeah I mean
coming to this tournament um I don't
expect much being the lowest seed
um in every game I kind of just told
myself I want to put up a fight I want
to make myself
um not lose easily
um and coming in this first round
um without much expectations being able
to kind of get a win
um I mean it feels great yeah is that
something that you put a price on just
not coming into this event with pressure
on your shoulders yeah I mean that's
very important to me because I just want
to take all that pressure off kind of
enjoy the tournament enjoy playing
against all these top players
um and I think that helps for sure well
you definitely put a lot of pressure on
your opponents and especially in this
game take us to of the game and where
did your opening preparation end um
because it felt like you were very well
prepared it was very long
um I think it ended near something like
move 18. oh wow
um so actually this is all preparation
this is a typical line but at the same
time and at this point he had one hour
and 30 he knew as well right but this
move E4 perhaps was a little bit off the
beating tracks
now B4 is this where he felt like you're
finally taking over like getting an
advantage
um I remember in my preparation that
you're supposed to play Rook d8 first 44
yes um and I would play Queen E2
and then he would play E4 Bishop C2 and
I think this is around equal I think
um but by playing E4 first I can play
Queen H5 and I thought that was a better
version for me because my queen is I
mean much better situated on that square
that's right that's exactly what it is
yeah yeah
um
and kind of yeah I wasn't really sure
why he allowed me to take on d8 and
I thought Rook takes he would play
rotate C1 Bishop takes D1 and then
someone F5 and play I think G3
um I thought a pretty normal position
but he allowed me to take on d8 and kind
of expose his King so I thought you know
that was kind of good for me
and right now he was still playing quite
quickly but missing a lot of details and
you spotted this beautiful Bishop to B3
yeah did you understand that at this
point you're probably completely winning
um I honestly I knew Bishop B3 is a
correct move and then I started
calculating and then I realized that oh
wait a minute he doesn't have any moves
now and that's kind of when I realized
Queen to F6 what was your uh I believe
Knight G4 Knight G4 yeah and then
Queen is overloaded yeah yeah yeah you
cannot defend D5 or and E7 at the same
time very nice game and I have to say we
missed the final move but it was so
beautiful right Queen takes 25 Queen
takes C8 a stylish way to finish this
game congratulations Arthur and welcome
to St Louis thank you absolutely our
congratulations to Arthur very very nice
Victory indeed and like you say you're
the lowest rated seed so no pressure on
you you take you take your wins when
they come right they're very nice good
luck in the rest of the tournament
arthro congratulations on your when I
have a question so you qualified here by
winning the 2022 us Juniors open how was
that did you prepare for that tournament
to win the event and qualify here or did
it happen out of nowhere and how did you
feel about it
um um
it honestly kind of happened out of
nowhere
um I played that tournament I mean I
played that tournament basically every
year
um and what happened was I think I was
actually tied for first with the top
scene that tournament um
tugstomer and he was his tiebreak was
hiring so he was supposed to play here
but
um his Federation was Mongolia so he was
not allowed and so I somehow managed to
qualify for this tournament so it was
completely unexpected but I thought I
mean it was a great opportunity I
thought I would have a lot of fun here
um great opportunity again so I decided
to play here okay
awesome congratulations and good luck in
the rest of the tournament thank you
it's like almost a Dean Lauren story of
Miracle it wasn't allowed and he didn't
get into the candidates except one
candidates player was removed
this he did this anyways World
Championship
um just turning uh our attention again
back to the uh Jacobson game uh let's
see what had happened because I was that
was a nice hunt that we were going
through there right
Bishop G4 check
check
and stop and Brandon has one more move
to make and there's 93 coming
yes well the problem is well we can't
really play uh Queen to E1 because as
you were just pointing out Knight D3 is
coming we can't fight Queen to D1 that's
covered uh we pretty much have to move
our King and I am going to take a rook
and then the material has
swung in uh Black's favor are you trying
to trap the queen like before he's
played Bishop E1 excuse me
Bishop to E1 so he's tossing away the
Knight
which is much better than the Rook by
the way shame on me
hmm
stop I'm taking the night by the way
unless you see something no I think we
agree because 93 just King moves up and
defending the bishop there's something
to be said for wanting to involve The
Rook right
maybe this move
is actually even stronger well the thing
is if you go King C2 now I have D3 right
and that's very nice right that's a
negative and he's done he said uh I
would much rather have this position
and I'm involving my Rook
and you see he made a move and he left
the board because he did his 40th move
he's getting extra time so he can take a
break made time control
absolutely
um what else has oh sorry question what
caught his attention it's a guest
who's got your attention Malik uh
starting the tournament can always be
rusty but starting tournament against
the top seed is never an easy task yet
you just won against the top seed Rodney
miracobia and your initial feelings
after this important Victory I actually
was happy to face him in the first round
I know a lot better like for I counted
for 45 years yeah we we grew up in the
same city so we knew each other like
since being a kid
we're playing many games against each
other
yeah so yeah but it was very important
for me to play and I was hoping to get
white color and I got it yeah how did
you prepare for uh this game well
firstly it was sort of expected from
Vladimir to play Sicilian uh I thought
he wouldn't play against me like E4 E5
because I thought he's like you know
hire the player and he wouldn't play
like a like symmetrical or Lopez or
something like that so it was expecting
but uh I actually mainly prepared
against the other lines so for me a line
which Vladimir played
um I saw the game against he played
against another Beck uh back to 2015. so
I thought it's only one single game at
it it's not really principal Queen C7
because I thought it's supposed to be
Bishop before right but he didn't play
Bishop before and he never published
before by the way he only played Queen
C7 so okay I thought the setup which I
played is quite known
up to rookie eight it felt like he just
wanted to get a longer game and try to
get you maybe in time travel and then
yeah make a push for something but I
mean I'm familiar with the system
because I I same system I teach all my
students and we talk about this actually
in our Olympian experience so I knew up
to like uh rookie yet moment yeah it was
so a first surprise when um he played
rookie eight
yeah because funny like um I thought the
the red was supposed to be like Bishop
da Bishop C7 right so this is like a
very common idea yeah Bishop d8 Bishop
C7 because um I'm actually not making on
time uh typical King H1 move
and why is that well I mean he played
Bishop C7
yes and let's say you go Bishop G1 right
that's why I thought Bishop G1 and
actually that's what something like this
happened with no not a big another big
plate so he goes D5 or what is the
problem well actually I was thinking to
I was considered between this line or to
play as I was thinking like initially
Bishop F1 Bishop uh if you don't play
King H1 second yes uh play uh Bishop F1
and then something like this and then I
thought it's not a big deal I can play
uh let's say G3 or something like that
yeah okay in a war scenario I can play
G3 and then you know its position I mean
I kind of play this in some Blitz Games
uh something like that is fine but uh
either this or King H1 but I thought let
him think and then let's see what he
does he actually spent some time on 95
right yes
he gave me like very valuable time so
now I can play Bishop F1
uh not E5
yeah also I I didn't I didn't actually
expected this I thought he's going to
play something like Bishop f8
but I mean I wasn't sure like what's the
point yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know it's a silly in like cam
positions typical plants yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah but he played that E5 that A4
here yeah by the way I missed something
yeah right here I missed something right
this is the critical moment go back for
a second yes yeah I knew there's
something wrong with this and I knew I
suppose I mean I supposed to take Knight
B6
mm-hmm
but I see pretty chicken out okay
because same sacrifice we have uh in
Sicilian in idors uh whenever you second
B5 and it was kind of similar thing when
you second four three four three pawns
now it's only two
you might be getting the third one yes I
was trying to compare remember the
famous game when the way he was very
young and he played against shirov I
think and won the World Cups testing my
memory I have my own live TV yes sir do
you remember that oh absolutely
yeah I mean it's kind of sacrifice but
honestly I saw this but actually you
know I mean I got
I thought maybe I'm gonna miss something
and this and that uh
yeah I'm going to blame myself for this
and then I played that B3 but that's
still good enough but I misjudged the
position I thought this is supposed to
be good for me yes number five initially
I was speaking Bishop G3 and that's why
I went for this exchange accepted
exchange sacrifice I thought Bishop D3
and I'm clearly better but I realized
after d is thought so better you know
sometimes by uh trying to evaluate Queen
B2 move not Queen G5 yeah but then I
realized on computer he has a bishop C5
check something like that it's pretty
annoying yeah yeah right you play the
bishop to G5 this was a moment where he
had an option but I really like this
move Queen to H3 I saw it instantly yes
yeah
pressure on him on his neck statistical
position uh Christian I had to do
something I can't handle this position
on it because uh one one move later he's
going to be two Bishops he's gonna kill
me yeah yeah so I gotta do something
actually I believe A5 is a big mistake
we agreed to we spoke briefly with
Vladimir
um it was expected which I thought G6
moved and I was thinking to make a check
another six uh capture capture Bishop
before and I said whatever you know what
let's see let's play this position like
whatever this couldn't be back and uh I
mean I think it's roughly equal yeah
Dynamic dynamically yes yeah I mean he
definitely had compensation uh but I
mean uh when he played A5 I was very
happy
uh I said okay I saw Queen Street
because I saw this even before K5 I
thought I was hoping if you play A5
because I saw Queen Street move because
it's funny but Rook is trapped there is
no there is no good Square for The Rook
yeah yeah yeah and everything just keep
contact exactly yeah yeah there's always
I mean we should be seven or D7 I
thought uh but no matter what any animal
was better than Queen E6 yeah I think
soon is just losing yes and you spotted
it directly the exchange of the Queens
definitely helps you after 28. yeah yeah
this is what the the win yeah maybe most
precise was not to capture and phrase
but like Rook D7 initially but I said
whatever it doesn't matter as long as it
gets the result yeah yeah that you want
it congratulations great thank you Chris
thank you to start the game uh to start
the tournament with guys back to you
indeed our congratulations we're always
winning against the
tournament's highest seed is a very very
very good feeling and winning in the
first round
it's all good it's all good downhill
from here uh let's go uh get into the
games because wow I mean just uh so many
uh games of uh kind of blown up one game
that is still kind of it's well I don't
know I don't know it's confounding it's
it's the two minor pieces
yeah uh jumping into that game and uh
this is the one of Andrew
versus adjusting uh why does done
everything right yeah I mean he's got uh
the two pieces two minor pieces against
uh oh that that's a great transfer oh no
you don't like it no I I I was just
thinking that you know like how am I
supposed you know like I could get my
king to be six the King was going to
stay on D6 but now uh the cobwebs have
just gotten cleared uh the move Bishop
F7 so the idea is King to D6 King I've
got Bishop to E8 Oh I thought it's just
Bishop H5 Bishop A3
even just uh yeah so so it was about how
I just didn't know how I was going to
put added pressure on the C6 spot so I
was just having a blockage there because
I'm sitting there going you know
white should be winning this you know
just winning right two minor pieces
versus The Rook that would equal number
of Pawns I've got an active King why
aren't I winning well that's because I
didn't see that you were going to put
the bishop on F3 I was thinking King
here King here you know like what am I
doing and now he's played Bishop F7 with
what you've said just transferring his
Bishop I think the Knight on D3 should
get a medal I mean it's defending the
pawn and it's guarding the F the C1
Square which is super important super
important so the pawn doesn't have to
move and definitely Andrew on his way to
Victory now with this move Bishop F7
players have made time control let's
take a break and we're gonna see you on
the other side of this break
[Music]
in 2019 the Missouri Bicentennial
commission along with Governor Mike
Parson approved the building of a
life-size chess board to celebrate the
200th anniversary of the state of
Missouri Dr Jeannie sinkfield a lifelong
patron of scouting in Great Rivers
Council board member proposed that the
project be built as an Eagle Scout
project Jeannie invited 16 year old
Andrew Dowden of troop 6 Jefferson City
to take on this incredibly important
project
my name is Andrew Dowden and I belong to
troop 6 in Jefferson City Missouri so my
troop we were down camping down at the
sing fields and Jeannie came down and
asked you know is anyone close to
getting their eagle or needing a project
she had this idea of the Eagle Scout
project chessboard and she wanted
somebody to kind of work with her to see
what we could come up with at the time I
kind of had a project in line but when
she brought up this idea obviously I
wanted to choose it because it was a lot
better idea than what I had started
prior to this project I did not really
know anything about Chess once I got
into this project I downloaded an app on
my phone started playing chess and I
took the chest merit badge down at Scout
camp this was a bicentennial chessboard
for the Historical Society of Missouri
there were a lot of people that helped
me with this project because whenever I
I got the pictures from the Historical
Society to engrave onto the granite I
wasn't very familiar with the technology
needed to engrave on there so I needed
some assistance with that and learning
how to do it and after all that I'm
pretty sure I know how to do it now so
to engrave those Edge pieces I went down
to the Lake of the Ozarks Scout
Reservation and we use the epilogue
laser me and Thomas Yang did I wasn't
really expecting it to end out this big
but as we me and Jeannie were working
um it just got kind of got bigger and
bigger and bigger which I didn't have a
problem with I thought you know I can
take on a little bit more and a little
bit more and
um it ended out to be a really really
cool project so we had a ribbon cutting
of the chess board and there were a
whole bunch of people there including
the governor the St Louis chess club the
World Chess Hall of Fame the State
Historical Society which all helped out
during this entire project
Jeannie was there I had to give a little
speech that I didn't really know I had
to do but that kind of has taught me a
little bit about speaking too so I think
that has helped me too this project it's
made me real proud that everyone is
enjoying it like every time I go down
there somebody's playing
um and then they're taking care of it
which really makes me proud because me
thinking all that time and everyone else
that's helped me sinking in all that
time like to see people use it but I
also like to see people appreciate it
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischesclub.org to claim your
membership today hello I'm women's grunt
Master William tokyonova I will be doing
social media for the US Juniors and
seniors chess championships follow us in
our social media and get more exciting
behind the scenes action
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the games the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
foreign
chess club is the Premier chess facility
in the United States and is among the
best in the world thanks to co-founders
Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield and Rex
sinkfield the St Louis chess club is a
non-profit organization committed to
promoting the game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
posting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over 2
000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chess piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
monthly concerts and much more whether
you are a beginner or a professional
there is something for everyone to learn
here at the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy free admission to our rotating
exhibitions in our Galleries and sign up
for chess events family friendly
programming and art classes and don't
forget to stop by our award-winning gift
shop Q Boutique and Shop a wide
selection of Chess related merchandise
for more information on current exhibits
please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
[Music]
thank you
hello everyone and welcome back we have
our results let's start with the girls
so in the girls Championship we have Yen
making a draw against Atwell Lee won
against prasanna tank also one with
white against mangala Wu one against Mo
a lot of white wins here are sir oh yeah
in the other sections as well uh here we
go with the Juniors
we have only one result so far Zhu won
against dagupati but a very big upset
there by Arthur as he takes down one of
the tournament uh top favorites and then
in the seniors again the whitewash
continues one draw here Benjamin Drew
against loogie and then it's white again
winning katriano won against acopian the
number one seed here another upset and
kaidanov won against wolf and uh and the
girls with one game remaining in the
girls Carissa she's trying her best uh
but she's in a rook ending that is so
balanced it's hard to see anything but a
draw here but you can you understand
when you're buying Carissa she's the
number one seed you're feeling nervous
and to slip as long as she can exactly
so and uh last move King B6 kind of an
intimation that hey look you know I've
got ideas to go and you start to get
nervous you see ghosts you start to
thinking to yourself well if I go back
but then if you go back you walk into B4
yes the computer is going to tell you
zero zeros and it's going to suggest
moves like Rook a six but putting
yourself in the hot seat if you will
with your clock ticking it's not that
easy it's not that easy and what has
caught your attention uh Christian well
I think we might be seeing a result in
that Brandon Jacobson game that was
great yeah and perhaps maybe we can pan
over the bird's eye view because after
Rook takes A1 just pick up the root keep
the Knight Under Siege on G1 and it's
just a decisive Advantage there's no
Perpetual tracks coming that pawn on F6
nicely keeps that G5 score extremely
important because if the queen could be
going to G5 then that would be
problematic but by the way that's not
the case Knight B Fortune oh that's nice
what a tasty move that's nice him he's
looking at Queen
C4 check after King leave here yes yes
yes that's a nice way to finish things
off
Force resignation because I guess you
can go King to B3 and immediately
where's the checkmate
yeah where is the Checkmate after King
B3 King B3 Queen C4 check King A3 I just
think
that's the lazy girls
that's effective exactly
yes
Christian this looks pretty good to me
yeah yeah nice uh nice so what if you
try to capture the Knight but then Queen
C4 and then Queen C3 saying I'm gonna
take the Rook hold on what what are we
talking about I'm sorry so let's go
approach that take on B4 BC for Queen C3
yes I mean I'm just saying I'm gonna
resign I will just try to hold on to it
well I can take on C3 and then take on
B2 and then either take on G4 or take on
B4 and take your Rook yeah so if I take
the Rook
truck after clicking B1 yeah no I just
pick up that's terrible or I can go
Queen D3 and queen to D2 and pick up the
Rook yep oh wow if I want to be
materialistic and material yes I do want
to be materialistic I take the Rook over
the bishop uh in that particular
sequence so is that going to be our
first win with black pieces with no
question about it but don't get me wrong
you know I'm All For You Know winning in
style and things like that night before
is visually a nice move but excuse me
Rook takes is just absolutely
convincing I like night before no I I
approve of this movie yes I agree I like
9v4 too what's wrong with you people I
mean I look for efficiency and by the
way we do have King B3 on the board and
we have Queen C4 check no question about
this one we've got to play King A3 I
like your Rook takes and B3 I guess
right
and then I'm guessing we're just playing
Queen takes
I mean sometimes at a certain moment you
say well I just want to see the
handshake oh you could do night's seat
no you couldn't sorry no never mind I
heard Knight C2 and then before but that
doesn't work yeah then King A1 I want to
see like this handshake uh B3 on the
board and we're expecting Queen C3 yes
just exactly simple simple chest simple
chess and after the queen trade it's a
coronation not to mention this guy is
hanging not to mention Knight C2 is
check made in one threat
it is
our first win with the black pieces I
didn't think it was possible that you
could win with black Brandon Jacob send
the top seed in the Juniors uh is
showing us how to do it
and by the way he did it in a very he
did it very stylish this whole Pawn
sacrifice H4
and he said go ahead take the pawn I
refer earlier to this moment earlier in
the game where uh I actually thought
well H4 and white was taking the
initiative right here uh
we have just captured a bishop on G7 uh
quite probably the move D3 D4 was
White's best move at this exact moment
but when you see the move H4 it's very
hard not to continue you've sacrificed
upon and then you suddenly like well
wait a minute
who's attacking here right like hold on
I thought I was the one attacking and
from here Brandon went on to get an
attack down the H file which was
very very powerful and he won it in
style Christian no absolutely but take a
look at this moment
huge moment between abhimanyu and Artur
go because
the very natural move is what Knight C7
exactly Knight of C7 loses on the spot
no I take I take and now I go F6
and you're caged you cannot approach
this Pawn with the king at all all I
have to do is just like get my kingdom
oh my gosh Bishop da takes F6 this is so
beautiful you cannot touch the F6 Pawn
because once you take on F6 I go C7 and
there's no stopping the c-pop agreed so
this is a huge huge uh Trap by abhimanyu
and he didn't fall for it he played F6
only move in the position to stay in the
game and he found it right he played the
move F6 and right now it seems like he's
very very close to a draw perhaps
getting that equality uh establishing
the balance at the same time is it that
easy because Knight C7 is I think all
the threat yeah so I take I have to take
right thing takes yeah but then I how
how easy is this
to make a draw yeah you go right you
have to defend this Pawn Yeah so you
probably get this position
yes
I could also Play Bishop to D4 but yes I
understand what you're saying can you go
Bishop D4 I don't know I guess you can
okay yeah I cannot move with my knight
because I don't want to allow him to see
exactly this is the perfect position
that I can get but unfortunately I don't
think there's okay I'm gonna try to get
this h-pawn but we do have the trade
just as you uh yeah suggested yes and
King C4 he has to go King the eight
yeah just to stop the king from marching
to B7 I'm not so much worried about the
pawn that the king marching to B7 yeah
and he's he plays he's done that King d8
King C8 King B8 as we expect
not that easy for I'll be money actually
it might just be a fortress yeah
absolutely by the way some crazy games
going on I'm
I just pulled up this one what is that
so many pawns everywhere right like uh
the players uh
I don't know the because I can't read
the player's name versus Josiah is that
the the there's a black Pawn on C2 okay
and there's a White Pond they all want
to go
got it okay there we have it on the on
the top board I
trying to read this is not easy what are
we gonna do here with white pieces
well
I'm assuming we want to play before
talking about this
because this Pawn is on C2 we have to
bring our King don't we the lasso this
pawn and stop it from
from promotion yeah can you do and the
thing is my king on D7 is kind of stuck
also I would love to get it to B7 and
capture that A7 Pawn Yeah that's so kind
of the deep on there's a P6 and D6 a
passer on A7 this guy black would
probably like to play like Bishop D5 and
then run with the King to get that pawn
on E7 on A7 right
or get that one B3 that's true uh sorry
so you mean Bishop to C6 and the King
for example or D5 yes and then run with
the King we need to protect this okay so
let's start I I start with King E2 tell
me what you're going to Bishop D5
to D5 and I'll go King to beat
the D2
you're welcome to take this Pawn I want
to play Bishop to D4
so
it's quite the
um
okay let's take a look if I take
oh I have a check also if I need to I'm
sorry
but if I give check no I'm not giving a
check yes let's go back with tonight and
then don't you kind of end up like stuck
yeah no this is dangerous well this
might just be lost right because I'm the
well White's got three pawns and you've
got two but we're not gonna go anywhere
and the night is stuck yeah yeah this
looks uh this looks definitely deadly
and kingy too sure looks like the
Pathway to Victory here you have another
move you you wanted to go King to a
seven so something like this
no but I'm gonna just I need Bishop on
D5 okay but so it's our Bishop D5 no
Christian doesn't approve what if I go
for these look I have to take that A7
Pawn right so Knight C8 I see it
immediately okay if I lose another Tempe
then you will be able to go Bishop D4
next agreed
so let's say yes King D3 that's true and
then I take only seven you take on C2
right right
well hold on I've got one yes I'm two
points down I know I know how to count
no but I just want to make sure we were
on the same page
uh okay as we'll we'll shift to the game
of uh Alex should fall off well he's
just about to finish the job
is he against Douglas root
what is happening there it's resignation
time
yeah it looks like Alex's two pawns up
and just figuring out which discovered
attack to make how about three ponsa
let's take
all Trader Rooks Rook D6 let's take
another Pawn
don't
Yasser is not going to allow you into
what's better than being two pounds up
here
one of the great talents of American
chess
well something went really badly wrong
for Doug because when we left it he
seemed
that he had a slight upper hand because
he has a decent position right out of
the opening and then suddenly we come
back and he's all kinds of Pawns down
and
shabby is ready to don't understand what
is Alex thinking about just grab the
pond whatever
choices choices it's always difficult I
remember I did something like this with
Ben Larson I grabbed the pawn and I had
instantly took the Knight as well
so I was like four pawns and a bishop
against a rook and he had to resign
because I took away the knife you know
he couldn't trick me there was no tricks
after Rook takes G3 and Rook takes C3
there's no more tricks and it's just
three bucks
and there's no stopping them you know it
was kind of fun
party hand class but
that that it would it wasn't the first
two that heard it was the third extra
Pawn so we have another win for black
pieces you see it's coming yeah it's
coming back it was it was bad there uh
jumping to the uh the game of Dimitri
gurvich and Igor uh novikov this is the
game there where where Dima was up in
exchange for a long time but somehow
he's not finished the job yet the last
move was
Rook to uh C6 Rook to Ace back to A7
there are repeating moves
which is kind of strange why isn't white
just winning after Rook C6 Rook C7 Rook
c-sex again I'm missing something
Kate clear clear the cobwebs here why
why aren't I playing Rook C6
um
helper
it has to be Rook D7 right
rotates
it has to be that the Knight has to move
so that the Rook can jump so he has to
play with the tempo no
Knight to E7
this must be what uh is concerning
Dimitri
because otherwise it's very
straightforward that we would play this
I mean
I mean it looks like black is having
some counter attack so maybe it's not
going to go anywhere the pawn so maybe
White's thinking about improving the
position and be going somewhere with the
King just King E4
well yeah that thing can improve as well
true that I'm
a black king is you may be
honestly you cannot go there though
because you would be in pain ah then I
take the Knight so King E4 there is no
King G6 you're right
okay uh let's just take an update of the
seniors with this the fourth game in the
book One game remaining so we have a
Benjamin draw against loogie kachian won
against accopian root lost against
shabalov and kaidana won against wolves
and it was Gregory who was our earliest
winner I want to say and Christian uh
with a guest Brandon with the black
piece is definitely a very difficult
game and it felt like you were quite
uncomfortable with your position you
were spending a lot of time the position
was uh quite uncomfortable tell us a bit
about your experience with this game
yeah no so
I figured going to this game I was just
gonna try to sleep well not prepare too
much and it's kind of funny because I
looked at this line and like I looked at
every move order like rookie one ipd2 H3
and as I was walking into the game I
realized what if white goes rookie just
in my head I was walking the game I was
like what if white goes rookie won
um in H3 without 92. okay how am I
supposed to put this because
so the thing for black normally is like
um actually wants to play a quick D4 and
not a lot of Bishop G4 okay and so if I
play Something Like H takes then D4 is
probably pretty strong here and okay I
can go B5 and transpose some other line
but that's not really what I want
um
and yeah or I can start with B5 Bishop
C2 but now it's not really clear what I
do because again wait is maybe this is
what I should have done in Cisco Bishop
B7 here and it kind of transposes to
some somewhat somewhat like something
that I know
um but I kind of figured like okay
Bishop f8 can't be the wrong move like
Bishop G5 H6 Bishop H4 I mean I figured
worst case like I can play like Bishop
B7 here it's probably not a big deal I
got this position and I realized I'm
actually in pretty big trouble here
because
like if I go Bishop B7 I feel like I'm
kind of down the tempo on normal Italian
lines right
um and no maybe he can reshuffle go
Bishop g3p4 yeah and if I go G5 like
like I played I mean I figured it's
probably a bit unsound but I thought it
would be an interesting try at least
um but then yeah I mean I played this
terribly after Knight D2
um B5 Bishop C2 I think maybe instead of
yeah Bishop B7 was a terrible move and
if even after night F1 I was considering
Bishop back to ca it was such a bad move
um I think like sort of similar to what
I did in the game like with 97 Knight G6
everything yeah
of course and yeah I mean I think I sort
of hallucinated that I had tell us why
why is the bishop much better on C8 than
on B7 yeah so I mean Bishop B7 is only
useful if I'm going to be preparing D5
so I kind of hallucinated some some D5
thing but it's it's all pretty bad I
think um because whenever whenever I go
D5 you just go like 93 Queen two and
kind of just leave it there yeah um and
yeah like with the bishop on C if he
goes like I can play quick 97 Bishop E6
and I think maybe this isn't so bad for
black okay I see the computer I'm still
worse but it's kind of like playable
yeah so
Bishop p7 yeah and the issue with this
with an f-197 is that like after 93
instead of Knight G6 go back like I mean
I just completely underestimated that H4
was going to crush me in the king so I
thought I'd have time for some C5 C4
counter replay but I didn't I just as
soon as I got here I realized like I'm
in pretty serious trouble so at this
point I'm kind of trying to find all the
only move to stay in the game every move
yeah
um and
I think kind of luckily there's no like
direct way for white to put me away
after Knight G6 I mean so yeah five
nights exactly so after 95 97 I figured
like the principled way for white to
play to take the bishop like you did so
you take it and then go something like
B4 is what I expected B4 yeah just to
stop C5 and then go A4 A4 right should
be much better here and but I can kind
of like sense he's a little bit shaky in
its first round so I kind of tried to
play logical trick I was like shaking my
head a lot on purpose and I was trying
to like beat him to to go H4 and kind of
you know like try to put me away here
because my position looks terrible
um it was not really experience it moves
right yeah I figured I mean I spent all
my time and I figured it's my only
chance because if he goes b4a for
something normal like I I'm you don't
have any trouble yeah so I tried to beat
him to go H4 he didn't like I played
Knight G6 pretty quickly I I okay
apparently it works but I was just
trying to to complicate the game I had
no idea this was actually any good or
not yeah um and I think what he did in
the game I think what he was counting on
was after Rook h8 Bishop B3 Rook H5 I
think what he missed was Knight takes F7
um and I went through another quiz
Summer Queen D7 yeah so let's say queen
E7 Queen D2
yeah now I can go D5
not through Cafe no okay uh Knight G5
and this is a total mess but after you
get Rook h8 okay so the computer
actually backs it up can't F1
exactly now it's only like Queen D7
let's say and whites up two pawns now
but it's actually kind of difficult to
find a move yeah because of F3 I can
take on e4
and that's nice yeah and I didn't think
any better than a draw for him yeah so I
think he sort of thought like
right I think he sort of thought that
he's getting that pawn and getting his
Knight back and didn't I know he
underestimated by counter play here did
you chat with him afterwards did he
calculate any of these or after a game
with this I don't think he would be in
the mood to talk I don't think I would
be either no like I I think like a lot
of it was just was just nerves and we
both played pretty terribly from being
honest but um I I know what happens
first round of the tournament and it was
such a complicated position it's it's
really tough to evaluate these things
especially with lowen when you're alone
on time but he also played for like a
full month before this in Europe and you
were mentioning that and you are
mentioning the first round and being
shaky having some rust on your shoulders
do you feel that that month in Europe
helped you start I wouldn't necessarily
rest I just um just I mean it's a pretty
serious event playing the first round of
something like this it's kind of a
different experience especially because
I haven't played a one game a day
tournament a long time in a while I
don't think he has either like we both
came from the world up and a few days
ago so I think it's hard to adjust like
that tournament was with 30 delay at the
time control so it's pretty hard to
adjust from like a fast-paced tournament
where you kind of just have to trust
your instincts to like something super
serious
um I definitely feel like my my
tournament Spirit was a good experience
and it did help me like put things
together better
um but yeah like at the same time like
most of my games in Europe I was playing
on an hour or two of sleep and just sort
of I don't know having fun with it I
didn't I could have done a lot better
and like I think that um
like for me at least tournaments like
this motivate me to take it more
seriously and actually you know like
take my preparation my sleep and my
routine pretty seriously during the
event so I don't know I think different
people have different styles and do
better in different events I know some
people hate one game a day some people
hate the more serious events but I think
for me it's what I need to motivate me
to be more disciplined you're also
coming into this event as the rating
favorite does that put any extra
additional pressure on you well I'm not
sure what rating they're using for me to
be reading educational I think I think
Mr outrates Me by quite a bit but no I
wouldn't say it has any extra pressure I
mean this is my last year it feels weird
being the oldest because it's funny like
when I was like 14 or something playing
my first event here I was like okay I
have four years left before I'm too old
I'm sure I'll win one of them and I
didn't even come close in any of them so
you know it I wouldn't say that's extra
pressure but I would say like it is it
does feel like now is like my shot so
in some sense I guess in some sense it's
a good thing in some sense it's a bad
thing guys any questions yeah Brandon
first of all congratulations very nice I
want you to bring you to the game to the
game position when you played the move
Rook takes G2 for our audience could you
just tell us how far did you calculate
the Rook sacrifice variation well she
played in the game really yeah
okay so yeah instead of what takes G2 I
kind of figured that like I could play
something like rook d8 and probably have
a good position but being so low on time
and like the position's still messy with
no like clear threat I figured it's
probably better to go for something
risky and and just and see how it goes
and that F4 came F1 Queen H2 yet so what
I saw is okay you can't move this work
off the e-file because then he takes D4
so basically there's rookie three and
rookie four
um after rookie four well okay so again
talking about first round nerves and
rest like in my head I had Queen G2
Knight G3 and then I like my hand
playing Knight G3 without realizing and
I tried to not like hesitate to make him
not inspect anything and the thing is
after G3 he did take a minute so I like
Bishop HD3 I should probably be winning
for White Queen takes D2 Bishop takes F4
I mean the game goes on I can take on B2
and have some Bishop F5 maybe but it's
kind of hard to believe this could
actually work for black
um but I was just sitting there trying
not to panic for the whole minute he was
thinking realizing that I meant to go
Queen G2 first just all
um so so from this yeah so for this
rookie for that I did see what I had and
then so the other options were E3
and here honestly like I didn't really
calculate much but I saw there were a
bunch of like slink ideas like there's a
lot of like for example Queen G2
um key one Knight G3
King D1
like that F1 for example
your queen E1
and I don't know like at some point I
thought I could play some quiet move I
don't even know what maybe like maybe
just Bishop at five yeah Bishop F5 and I
saw up to here and I figured you know
we're both low on time like if we get
here then it looks like I don't know a
nightmare to play with white and I
thought it was a good practical decision
and it did work out but
I'm not quite sure what is going on here
like my guess is computer would say all
zeros or something that just always what
happens but
probably Rick d8 was was a better move
um and I figured during the game that
that made more sense but I don't know I
kind of I I already went this far to
attack him may as well try what takes
you too and see how it goes and yeah I
think like a big problem for me lately
has been not trusting myself trusting my
intuition
um in a lot of positions where I feel
like I want that like like I gotta get a
position and then I'm not trusting
myself to find like the the Breakthrough
and I figured you know what we're
already here by the way for it this is
uh three people zeros
yeah
that's interesting I didn't even
consider a rookie too it just felt wrong
to me but
yeah it's just that's the funny aspect
of it so what happens if Queen G2 and
Knight G3 I'm just curious
yeah Knight G3
Queen E3 only
[Music]
some crazies okay this I didn't see at
all no it makes sense it makes sense but
yeah like it it I figured you probably
had some some defense but I think with
long time it's it's very difficult yeah
no I was sorry Brandon I didn't want to
I I didn't want to point out that you're
completely bluffing out
disciple and Brilliant well yeah sir I
think you've come to indefinite games to
know that I'm always blocked
Brandon I'm curious when was the moment
when you figured out like you are
winning because
and like the move it takes D4 was that
the moment when move 40 you made and you
were like okay I'm winning or was it
still unclear because it was a crazy
game very complicated game at the end
well I mean when you play rookie four I
was pretty confident I was winning but
besides the scare with night she's read
giving the extra option but like once he
once he played King D1 I was pretty
confident that I was winning here
um but when you play Knight G3 that's
like a cold shower yeah
yeah smokes actually losing now yeah
yeah no I it's crazy I I like and the
thing is like this has happened to me so
many times before too like when I when I
let go of the piece I was like okay this
is just another Moment Like This is
gonna happen to me like I don't know
what I can do about this like it just
sort of was trying in that minute just
to sit there and not like make any faces
so I was just trying to like Zoom my
brain out because I I'm a very
expressive person so I figured like if I
was thinking about the fact that I've
wondered I would probably subconsciously
make a face or something so I'm just
trying to zone out for the whole minute
and like not think about it too much
and it paid off congratulations it did
uh I I want to say Well done but instead
I'll just say good luck with the rest of
the term thank you nice nice but the
Rook sacrifice it was a very visual game
and let's take a look at the uh results
so far so we have only two results in
the U.S junior Championship so Liang
lost again Jacobson and Zhu won again
dagupati
uh
top tournament seed here he's the one
pressing he has a an enjoyable
positional Advantage but the problem is
it's not so easy to win you know look at
the hall of fame here by the way it's
kind of clearing out where's our
finishing but there are still a few
games left actually there are three
games in the juniors girls are almost
done seniors are almost done but juniors
are still fighting exactly exactly and
we just have this move h2h4 that puts a
question to Archer are you going to play
H5 or not the problem when you play a
move like H5 should put you you make
your Pawn vulnerable right so you kind
of happy that the pawn is way far away
from this night it's not easy but then
you start to think to yourself and you
start to get a little bit worried well
wait a minute that this Pond does manage
to creep up the board and you do manage
to win upon them you're really close to
coronation so what do you do here for
black do you want to defend with the
pawn on the same color as you're Bishop
you're just going to leave the H Pawn
all alone just move your Bishop back and
forth just go back and forth or move
your King well he went back yeah yeah I
didn't touch his H Pawn either to play
H6 or H5 I was thinking that I would if
I were in black shoes I would probably
have moved my king only from the idea
that I don't any night jumps I don't
want to come with Tempo and make sure
it's running with the pawn he just moved
H5 okay so he's serious about do you
think going further to H6 because that
leaves the point vulnerable to the
bishop yeah and then the question is
okay how will you you go H6 great how
are you going to win the spawn on H7
even after the Knight going to f8 but as
you say then white is going to be very
fast in terms of so you put your Pawn to
H5 I play King here I'm assuming we we
we
us with our King we pass with our Bishop
yeah either Bishop to D4 or Bishop B2
the problem is
is a Black's King just stays and and
lacks Bishop is patrolling this diagonal
hold on wait a minute what am I saying
C7 check and then King B5 King
and we have a guess as we work out the
increasing intricacies of this uh end
game over to you Christian thank you
Yasser Alex first of all welcome back
and congratulations this is a great
start for you as the defending Champion
ah thank you very much yeah that was an
interesting game and uh Douglas is the
first time he's a rookie on this
tournament and he didn't change his
opening very much last 50 years so do
you know him uh well have you guys
played against each other a few times no
I think you start playing chess before I
came to the states I mean uh actively I
mean of course he was playing all these
times and uh
and uh but seriously I Was preparing uh
using his games back in 80s today wow so
he's still playing the same opening it's
a collie and I think uh
maybe Queenie 2 was technically the
first novel yeah that I like did not
look pretty Queen F3 not here okay Queen
here is Queen F3
um
yeah so here 22 Yeah that's the move
that I didn't really specifically
analyze but everything before going to
F3 on the board something else yeah yeah
I think in this line if white wants
something he shouldn't Castle too early
because that's uh and what's the plan
behind that's a critical critical loss
of time powder uh same same he did like
Queen F3 and all the kind of space is
the same thing but without cast but
don't Castle because that's it and now I
need to go like
has to be on C6
perhaps you have some C4 ideas or
something like that is is that why right
but it's not a position from my game
oh yes yeah that night was on uh C6
so something like that yeah Knight needs
to go to C6 so he can go to B4 and to E7
and uh so people
yeah sometimes white plays A3 sometimes
he doesn't but at least that's uh that's
an interesting top here yeah and then at
some point perhaps you will go long
Castle or nobody did yes like no not
really yeah but he did short castle and
it does seem like there's quite some
games in even uh Anton giharo versus box
so some some strong players have played
this position before uh I think it was
all interesting and Knight F5 was good I
believe a bispy sound I played too fast
I I should have started with Rook C7
so in case of Rook C1 I have Queen E7
and A3 suddenly it's hanging yeah that's
that was a bishop takes a three ideas
right I think that was a little bit
incorrect on my part and then position
just became like really complicated oh
yes Knight F1 the strong move hit took
on C5 icon took me by something I said
and C4
um probably why it's I saw like why it
should be slightly better because pieces
standing really well so I played yeah 94
takes takes here using B7 yeah here came
the critical moment so I kind of knew
that Knight D4 might not be the
strongest move in the position but
if I play Rook d8 yeah here
then
I probably missing a chance to activate
my Bishops and so sooner or later
eventually I will have to play Rook D3
and suck anyway exactly something so I
thought like I'd rather do it earlier
than when I still have time yeah so
Knight D4 might as well get it over with
this yeah but objectively I felt like it
shouldn't be that great
yeah I think this move uh Knight to G4
instead of E4 just so that it doesn't
hang potentially against the E5 was
better for him yeah that that looks
pretty uh dangerous but then again first
round yeah better take a risk now of
course why why not you have to yeah yeah
94 and actually you mentioned even
before the tournament that it's not the
preparation it's more about the
resilience those later rounds physical
preparation was that something that you
emphasized in your training yeah
specifically for this tournament if uh
so last year I played non-stop prior to
destroying my eye this time I decided to
take like a complete break and just do
physicals instead and we'll see how it
goes you're feeling good entering the
tournament but it's such a blood blast
today yeah
it's going to be quite a race I got a
feeling oh okay that's that's good well
it was last year as well you guys ended
up in a five
yeah that's true so um and I I yeah I
think I made a mistake
yeah F1 for eight point that was
completely unnecessary he should have
195 it seems like 95 yeah or Rook D4 on
a previous move now maybe not now it's
like um right maybe here with the deeper
yeah I thought it's
probably slightly better for me but not
that much yet still with black pieces a
great start for you Alex congratulations
guys any questions for our defending
Champion absolutely first of all welcome
back to St Louis uh Chevy a reunion it
feels like a reunion does it feel like a
reunion for you you see all of these
guys that you've known no absolutely
yeah it's uh it's a Pity just once a
year yeah right yeah we need more
serious
yeah there should be a Christmas
tournament The Summer's tournament
exactly like four times five times a
year that's that looks like appropriate
number yeah and get the answer to play
in them yeah of course yeah
congratulations and uh yeah well eight
more games to go it's gonna be a race
yeah thanks absolutely
and our senior results so let's take a
look at the results let's have a look so
almost all the games are done we have
Benjamin Drew against loogie cacian won
against akopian root lost against
shabalo and kaidanov won against wolves
which leaves uh gervich in novikov and
by the way a draw in the game of Carissa
let's take a look at the girls let's
catch up with the results of the girls
oh so we have a standings because all
the games are done so Alice Lee Rochelle
and Zoe tank all won their first round
so they are leading with one point then
we have karisaya Peru Yang Yan Kelsey
Liu and Rose Atwell with their first
draw and Iris small Gracie prasanna and
Shreya mangalam who lost their first
round
wow all right I mean for a moment there
and we we have one more that seems to be
a win for Andrew Hong we were expecting
this result yes we see Kings on the
lights
lights around tell you it was a
whitewashed there for the longest time
yes and we do have a guest in studio
Carissa you definitely took a very
aggressive stance out of the opening but
today it just wasn't meant to be you
didn't get your chances how are you
feeling right now um I'm a little
disappointed about the result but you
know I was black I didn't feel like I
had any opportunities anywhere and I
definitely made a few mistakes in the
game so I thought Kelsey played really
well and true I was a fair result do you
know Chelsea well you've had some
experience previous experience against
her she's from Massachusetts too so we
grew up going to like the same chess
club and everything excellent and how
would you characterize her as as a
trustler since you've played her quite
I'm gonna be honest there was like
because Kelsey's a lot younger than me
so there's a bit of like lack of overlap
between our time at the club
so I have no idea but I think generally
she's a from what I saw of her games
When I Was preparing she seems to be
um sort of like not super aggressive
player I saw against the Sicilian lot
she plays like Kathleen kingside so I
was super surprised by the sort of like
Bishop G5 yeah
she's like the sharpest line against the
classical
followed by Queen D3 yeah
um I don't think I played this opening
quite right
I was definitely a bit because I meant
to surprise her at the classical and she
ended up surprising me yeah
um yeah I don't think Queen C7 was right
but I was mostly trying to find a way
maybe get her out of book and into a
position that I thought was comfortable
or more comfortable for me to play yeah
and you play Queen C7
um Bishop D7 and Castle really
aggressive played by you
but she came in the position quite
quickly she was looking for
simplifications as well
take us through the game yes kind of
estimate this bishop D3 move
um
I'm not sure why I missed it but I just
thought I would have like two Bishops as
you're ready to sort of sacrifice a Pawn
on F7 as well if need be
um
so what's happening if she takes I think
I was planning
um
what was I planning
honestly I think I was playing Bishop F6
Bishop to F6 here okay which I guess
after Bishop deep three just kind of
transposes don't take the Rook
that would be a nice little checkmate
so Bishop D3 here
yeah and I guess
just have to take one of seven
so everything's liquefied in the center
yeah not a lot of pieces left yeah and
so
she definitely kept
her cool exchange the the pieces wall
and it didn't feel like she gave you any
chances did you feel like maybe perhaps
once you got this King on D5 or are you
hoping for anything at this point no I
saw I thought like when she got her King
out to D3 as well there wouldn't really
be anything and I totally just missed um
I saw a bishop takes H6 idea it happened
later on the game
yeah and this was just
a watch
work a little bit for the draw you know
you were trying but yeah there's
anything
yes absolutely and this tournament is
not decided in the first few rounds you
have so much experience we missed you
last year but you're back again take us
a bit about your preparation before this
event if any
um I didn't really prepare a ton before
this event I was playing two tournaments
sort of back to back in the last couple
weeks just because I haven't played
since January
um and I'm mostly trying to like just
shake some rest off
so
hopefully you know maybe I'm just
getting rid of some nerves here but I'm
just kind of looking to take a game by
game
Carisa thank you very much for uh
joining us and we'll see you in the rest
of your games thank you quick question
for you Carissa U.N East Coast West
Coast you're now Stanford uh tell us
what the West Coast experience is about
how are you enjoying Stanford
um yeah I Love College a lot it's been
my first year it's been done so that was
a lot of fun
um I will say I probably still prefer
the East Coast
um
sorry Austin it's just something about
it I like the cold weather when it's too
sunny it makes me uncomfortable you know
that's not right there should be seasons
all right well uh thank you Carissa too
sunny more questions for you Carissa you
have experience with like playing the
the best tournaments here in St Louis
you played of course the U.S girls
junior the one that you played the boys
do juniors you played U.S Women's
Championship that's several Invitational
now how is it different for you to play
the US Women's Championship and the US
girls do you have a preference there is
in any tournaments you feel more
pressure or more enjoyment more friends
around
um I would say typically there's like a
lot of overlap between the fields of
like the junior girls and the US Women's
this year I guess all my friends have
gone a bit too old for the tournament
but typically you're getting old though
this is my last my last chance
um
but yeah mostly I would say I probably
prefer playing
um US Women's I like sort of like the 11
round structure I think it's nice to
have a bit of a longer tournament just
because you can sort of bounce back more
easily I think from any sort of loss
awesome thank you and good luck in the
rest of the tournament thank you
absolutely
just going through the games we have two
games in the Juniors still ongoing uh
those are the last two games in the Hall
of Fame everything else is cleared out I
was about to say there's three three
extra Pawns in this whenever you get the
opposite color Bishop ending you do have
this feeling that there are chances to
draw but
not when there's this many uh extra
ponds for white on the board white is a
B3 Pawn up a D6 pawn and up a G6 pawn it
should be I can just run with one of the
pawns right exactly before working
before improve the king exactly yeah
just as you're saying it's uh King C4 B4
B5 and King C5 should be uh a win
for Kirk against Josiah in this game and
uh Christian with another guest Andrew
uh the difficult opening you are
pressuring pressuring gaining a slight
uh Advantage but then he played this
move Bishop to E6 a complete shocker for
us how would you explain this decision
by him
um I think I had a little pressure here
on Knight G3 move was very key probably
missed this move um with the Dual threat
of rookie seven Knight H5 and uh you
know I think here it's quite unpleasant
for black I see what the computer says
it's not me not so bad but um I think um
when you see 95 rookie seven sometimes
you know the pressures and the panic and
play Bishop V6 yeah yeah it's quite an
Innovative defense when of course
unfortunately it doesn't work that well
how did you assess it once he plays this
move were you happy to see it on the
board no I was completely shocked I
didn't think it was possible but um yeah
once I took a closer look
um
I think white as you know not many
weaknesses there's not that many open
files for The Rook so I assume that um
yeah if I keep everything protected
slowly I'll why should convert this and
I think that's exactly uh what you did
what was let's say the last task that
you felt you had to do before you get
the victory in this end game well yeah
so he played A5 I played A3 um open day
followed the Rook Rook was coming in and
um
so I think it was just a matter of
um how I keep everything protected while
he while he's trying to come in and okay
so I found maybe not the best way but
good enough
um
H4 G3 keeping his structure a little bit
on this side yeah H4 G3 keep all the
pawns protected and like prodding his
queen size structure so I fixed all his
pawns and I now I keep everything
protected and um okay here I just made
time control and then slowly um yeah why
don't you convert this lovely how
important it is for you to get the first
round victory in tournaments in general
not necessarily in this one
um I think it's always nice to start on
a good note but uh you know I think
everyone probably has like nerves in the
first round it's very normal so it
doesn't mean too much it's but it's
obviously nice it's a lot better than
any other result guys any questions for
Andrew no just our congratulations
indeed and good luck with the campaign
to become the junior Champion yeah
in these national championships we've
got another result yeah we see two
players standing up and gazarian won
against
that too many Pawns a case of too many
prawns which means that we're down to
two remaining games by the way Israel
making a breakthrough in his game uh
let's take a look he played Bishop D2
um
I'm getting my king on E6 isn't that
that's a bit dangerous yeah I was about
to say did we have to allow the king
that that repositioning of the king
Bishop D2 Knight to C5
oh this is a key moment right now
because we've got ideas of Knight E4 to
begin with that that's a nasty hit you
can't play Bishop G5 I think you're
losing any King upon it in games and I
also think I have ideas of blocking your
your a pawn with Knight A6
but is that Knight C5 on the board
Knight C5 so Bishop C3 right that's
probably well this is the the this is
the point that uh we we've got our King
okay now I need to get the bishop on G5
otherwise I get but now I'm
but now we've got this King somehow okay
we've maximized and you still stubbornly
saying okay you've maximized
but win the game
how do we do that and how do you do that
I have a question can we do
C7 yes
then I'm gonna check you yes now I can't
take because that is that's what I want
yeah and I will allow you to play
Knights to E6 right but I still play 96.
yeah but then the question is just a
second now I know you want it upon like
good for you right but I do have
suddenly counter play as well nah I
don't believe you yes no I don't believe
you why not
E7 no King E7 so let's say I go check
that's why I wanted to put the King on
G7 or G6 okay so I am with Christians
just because I don't want to yeah to
allow me any any funsies okay here's
here no A3 for you no A3 uh no I have my
my Bishop boy did I put my Bishop on a
bad Square my Bishop should at least be
here so I could play A3 bit Bishop I go
F7 yes even though no no no no no you
know what I don't want to go F7 I will
take the pawn on H6 okay
yeah my king is in a in a death in King
James
here
and now I catch upon 94. no no I catch
your Pawn yeah either way you you you
just promote with mate yes yes yes
um
but okay so Mishra is going to be able
to put his King on G7 and Pawn on C7 and
then In This Moment
On The Board A5
oh sorry just a second Let me refresh my
my board I apologize I'll be come right
back a7a5 why didn't we like this oh
because of Knight E4 of course
this was the problem right where we're
we're getting tickled the bishop and the
pawn are fort
I guess we have to move our Bishop
yeah you take a pawn
you push upon
it's all about getting the counter play
in time right any King C4 I'll I'll play
King C7 and I think I'm just in time
uh Christian uh come and bail us out of
this one was this uh a wise decision by
black to play A5 uh the position is lost
either way so either way after Knight to
C5 white is actually just winning just
winning yes yes but right now another
key moment Knight to E4 seems to be
winning I'm not convinced how clear that
is but a much better move is actually
King to C4 really yes okay I created
this weakness and now I'm going to
attack it with it so you just go back
maybe King to B6 as well and then be
able to set up some sort of a mating net
um you have to be very very careful and
you cannot push the pawn this is the
weakness that you have to say glued uh
to so you're having some difficulties
right now how do you play this so for
example King
c75 King C8 King C8 say I go night
E6 or Knight to Eva but now I can go
Knight E4 and I'm just picking up the
pawn oh that's true then I don't have so
I can't play I can't be passive actually
well the thing is
I'm keeping my King next to your pawn
and then I just attack the other Pawn
okay that's an easy way so so for
example from the starting position if
you go King C4 and I go Bishop uh hold
on King C4 Bishop E3 okay that's why now
I attack
King C4 has is on the board Bishop E3
I'm just throwing apparently this Knight
E4 is not the most precise probably
still winning but not the most precise
Knight to E6 okay you know what I'm
playing it practical uh Knight to E4 it
makes the most sense to my eyes
ate four king to C7 and now I guess oh
no no no no let me play A5 let me play
A5 A4 A4 okay
can I pick up the pawn oh geez so Knight
takes F6 and the Knight comes back to D5
darn it but when we look at the clock
players are really low on time black has
one minute in like eight seconds
and I'll be mining two minutes this is
King C7
but King to B5 now this is easy
five with the idea 96 check
and uh the bishop is tethered
to this Pawn on A5
I think this is this might actually just
be over yeah King B5 that just uh
looks convincing actually
uh just a zuk Swang
black is running into zooxan oh and this
is a huge victory for abimani because
this was not easy and in fact
objectively this was a draw for a while
for a long while
sure
you always feel great when you get these
wins uh but okay but give me your credit
he he was the one pressing pressing
pressing he was that's why it's like the
youngest Grandmaster ever may be really
pushing till the end even if it's a draw
he's not gonna agree to it or repeat
moves
and we have a guest with Christian
just one second
um but
I have to say guys this one is he's
closing on the show right now
head over to you Christian thank you
guys uh Kirk first of all welcome to St
Louis uh congratulations on a big
victory for you what was the plan going
into days round you know Josiah quite
well you guys are good friends what was
the plan for this round yeah well the
plan for this round was I was just gonna
play my cuddle on and he has almost no
games against the Catalan so I didn't
know what to expect I didn't prepare
this line at all with Bishop E7 so he
played this line with 66 C4 in the
classical Catalan did that surprise you
at all or for sure because I he never
played it as far as I knew of course
it's a common line but also it's a bit
of an unusual Choice considering that
he's an aggressive player this is a
solid opening after
um Queen C2 I was surprised by this C6
line I hadn't looked at it recently but
I knew a couple of you are aware of it
because I was aware of it yeah you
definitely play the most uh direct way
yes 95. I knew the position until
um D takes C5 on move 12. I'm not sure
if Knight D5 is the best move but it is
a move seems to be the best yeah it
seems to be the best move I didn't
remember what to do in this position so
I started thinking E4 is a possibility
but then after night before uh Queen E2
or queen B3 and then he'll move his
queen and I didn't like this Pawn
structure even if the engine said it was
okay it's very hard to play here for
white
what is the plan behind the spawn
structure it feels like once you get the
pawn on e4 maybe your attack is getting
a bit slower is that what you felt well
I don't like my Bishop on G2 being
blocked in these positions it becomes
much harder to play in these positions I
tend to try to bring my knight to E4
exactly so either uh sack on D6 drop my
knight on D6 or play Knight C5 exploding
blacks week and dark squares in this
position and that's exactly what I
wasn't sure if B4 was a good move I
thought A6 was good
I would have certain I certainly thought
A6 was a more solid option yeah
yeah I don't know it already felt like
Rook to C8 was a step in the wrong
direction perhaps Queen to B8 was the
best move in the position I saw Queen B8
I wasn't sure exactly what I was gonna
play here I was even considering uh uh
94 but I realized after Queen takes C5
Knight C5 perhaps the Knight B4 is a
problem yeah so I couldn't play 94 in
that position yeah but I had I have
other moves but okay it's only equal
after Queen B8 I could have played
Knight takes D5 here in an E4 like
engine says yep
yeah and just uh
make the position a bit more peaceful uh
Rook to see it
and this became a mess very quickly yes
he was attacking you and progressing on
the queen side you had this thorn in his
position on D6
how did you assess it at this point I
actually I was not surprised by my
opponent playing in such a manner
because it is a very aggressive player
and takes a lot of risk I know that this
is uh not exactly in the spirit of how
Black's supposed to play this variation
though and I also know while the
position is uh three result game I know
that with uh Bishop pair and the strong
D6 spawn I know that uh even though not
everything can concretely be seen for
both sides white should definitely have
an advantage here yeah and I think your
assessment was very precise was H4 a
good move I wasn't sure I think perhaps
Bishop takes F6 is the more precise but
H4 doesn't lose the advantage by any
means yes I was just trying to keep
tension the position but it's
interesting to see Bishop F6 has such a
high evaluation for white I would say H4
at least from a practical perspective
and don't trust this too much I mean if
you let it think for a little bit maybe
it's going to get the same levels
um I think it was a good decision
practically
Queen 24 was definitely the right move
try to get the game into the end game
and after that it felt like you never
let it go
Kirk congratulations big victory for you
guys any questions well our
congratulations as well Kirk uh keep up
the good form yeah it seems like
a gear away from the beginning till the
end did you feel at any moment like you
are maybe losing the grip of the
position or were you comfortable the
whole game uh not at all but of course I
was not calm because it's never easy to
win a chess game of course there's
always chances for the opponent
fortunately he was never within the
drawing margins so uh he just never got
chances but he fought well I would say
well congratulations and good luck in
the rest of the tournament thank you
very much absolutely and let's just go
to our Junior our favorite in the junior
championships Mishra as he seems to be
putting on the final touches here oh
he's won the bishop already is there
it's no more Bishop there's no more
Bishop so why is the game going on
what is happening here what happened the
thing is I can defend both of those
pawns with the Knight on G7 yeah all
right here we go all right and we see
you handshake game is over
that's a confidence booster writer
because this wasn't easy and we know if
I remember correctly Mishra didn't start
very well last year's Juniors no I
believe he was one and a half out of
four perhaps even minus two something
along those lines so starting off with a
bang is extremely important by the way
uh we only have one game remaining but
in the Juniors not a single draw wow I
mean everybody is swinging for the
fences and it's the seniors who are
showing their sits life is that one game
remaining uh there a single no two draws
and the girls and uh one draw thus far
in the seniors with this game on the
board
Dimitri Igor survived
incredible survived it unbelievable wow
wow
really really uh remarkable I really
thought that uh the The Exchange that is
to say the Dimitri gurvich was a junior
uh was nursing this extra exchange that
he would win uh once again the standings
with all the rounds with all the games
completed Kate yeah so we have five
players who won their first games
because all result of the games Brandon
Jacobson abima new Mishra Andrew Hong
Kirk gazarian and arthroju all have one
point and the rest of the field so far
zero tied for six yes
I haven't seen that before time for six
how are you doing in the tournament
Young Buck well I'm tied for six
with zero points
that's right okay and uh any tricks in
this one uh Christian I mean I you I
feel kind of uh sad for for Dima here no
I think he's an exchange happening I
think it's too easy right now yeah the
the the B Pawn is is too fast that's too
far yeah I think the best thing perhaps
you can get is to go Rook F6 and Rook G7
and try to exchange the Rooks but
it's going to be Rook versus knight and
pawn it could be Rook versus knight and
it's still an easy easy draw of course
yeah
so no I I think he just blew it
was there a possibility to capture the
pawn
before like on move let's say 58
yes Rook to F6 okay are we going to just
don't go King H5 yeah that's the one
thing you shouldn't do
yeah Maiden one is uh to be avoided uh
sorry uh Kate had a question for you uh
Christian on what was it almost 58 after
Knight B2 I know there are some tricks
but maybe I don't see the whole thing
can I go Rook A3
Rook to A3 I know you want to trick me
with some like Knight C4 Knight D6 but I
think so what if I go Knight C4
I take the pawn okay B3 viewers are not
following the analysis at the moment all
we have is the current position
so the thing with that situation is that
uh yes from a practical perspective
probably was the right choice okay go
ahead uh show the analysis on my board
that you guys have been looking at I
didn't I didn't follow it
realism move 58 yes I I think that's the
right Knight to B2 and now Rook wait
okay three okay 1994 trying to go here
for the fork and yes yes we see that yes
but after takes here I move the king
somewhere yes now I take on be so
and then I get my knight to E6 and
apparently this position is just an easy
draw Knight to C5 to E6 is
nothing
maybe not to have faith get the night of
Jesus okay and you just have a fortress
yes I I might just leave the Knight on
E6 I think it's better to keep the King
close to the defense of the Pawn on G5
uh let's just uh okay so that by the way
it feels like that was actually a more
decent alternative but here what Dima is
trying to do is set up uh for mating
net I don't know exactly how he's
supposed to do that by the way uh
somehow he's supposed to get his King up
the board maybe to F5 so that you can go
check check in me right uh
sorry okay still not that easy yeah
still something to play for a tricks
right
by the way to remind everybody our rest
day will celebrate the 15th anniversary
a happy anniversary to the St Louis
chess club and Scholastic Center
actually it's Mondays the actual actual
uh date of Celebration but the party
I'll put it like that so if you're
anywhere near the Central West End we're
gonna have a party from three to eight
uh bring your books your clocks your
sets your t-shirts your caps as Grand
Masters will be signing autographs and
celebrating the 15th anniversary of the
club and bring your friends there will
be so many things to do we're going to
be playing duck chess also with the
Astro that's going to be a lot of fun
what do we do we we opened up a swimming
pool for the Ducks
special small pool with all the ducks
that will be even with like the chess
club logo or Hall of Fame logo so you
can come here and you know take your get
a doc so you can play dachshunds on your
own exactly and I understand Christians
going to be doing the Ice Bucket
Challenge as well so I don't know it's
all good it's all good that's right
don't worry I will be your second you're
10 years too late it's a great honor to
be your second there's no ice bucket
challenge forget about it here your
favorite charity don't worry all right
you got 10 bucks going to your favorite
charity Christian uh well done Uh
current position a night up for check uh
any trickies here uh Christian that Dima
can perform I don't see them well first
of all you have to go to H2 right
correct if you go to H4 this is just a
draw I go Knight G6 94 back things of
that nature yeah so King H2 whatever
you're forced to go King
okay now what you're gonna do your Rook
is hanging so let's force your king to
H1 okay check an H1 now let's say Rook
C2 or D2 or so you're not afraid that if
I pick up this Pawn your king is going
to easily
that's because you're a king is so far
exactly so I can just trade off the
Rooks if you take on B2 yep go King to
G6 pick up the pawn on G5 makes sense to
me and that's going to be what we
already said The Rook versus knight yeah
which is a draw exactly
and unfortunately this of course you can
play on for a while but yeah it's not
going to lead too much
I don't think you can do anything better
than that as white
and whether we yeah try to set a check
yeah I know exactly that's what I I'm
almost when we move one of the Rooks
from the file the queen can always
promote okay King H4 is just maybe an
invitation to gain some more time or an
invitation for a draw exactly
testing
just testing one two three right
okay
I think he just wanted to make sure that
he wasn't walking into mate there you
never played H5 I don't know why I would
never play King H5
right I mean he just kind of made sure
there's no
uh you know there's a magic move you
know you want to play Rook on G1 to H4
is like what
refresh my board okay go back
uh what's happening there uh he's
claiming a three-time repetition I think
okay do we have a three time and I think
they agree to a drawer no no I don't
think so don't feel like anybody was
claiming anything it just Chris
came there
Knight of four check
it wasn't a three-time repetition was it
I mean I mean just look just counting
the number of Night Moves it was
wonderful
yeah no there was no intriguing
occurrence
well there was no time added
no so there was no uh
yeah the problem is you would love to be
able to set up the checkmating pattern
with yes okay six or somewhere along
those lines the problems of The Rook
seat do I just you move the Rook off the
B file I go Rook C1 followed by B1 and
exactly hit the queen
exactly which stops this checkmating
pattern at the same time
exactly
so yeah Rook B7 is kind of one of those
50 50s
if he moves his team you win if he takes
the Rook you lose
yes
Rook to E2
I mean incredible defense by Igor yeah
I was in the opening right dead lost
he was suffering literally from move 20
onwards but I mean these types of draws
are victories yes you know it just it
just feels like you've saved the game
and you feel very very good after such a
game by the way just to remind everybody
in the Juniors and girls
all the results this is our final game
at the three national championships and
just to remind everybody of the current
standings uh in this the first round
we'll start with the girls yes we have
Alice Lee Rochelle and Zoe tank all
having one point
the pre-tournament favorite at least by
Invitational they only made a draw but
she had black yes and ruin Yan and
Kelsey Liu and Rose Atwell also made a
draw and then we have irie small Gracie
prasanna and Shreya mangalam who lost
their first game and in the Juniors boy
everybody was swinging for the fences
not a single draw in any of the five
games yeah we have five way tie for the
first spot Brandon Jacobson
Andrew Hong here at gazarian Arthur Zoo
all having one point type for six and
tied for a six is Jason Liang Balaji
dagupati Justin Wang Arthur guo and
Josiah Stillman with seniors one game
remaining we do have three winners thus
far
and they are so we have Benjamin Drew
against blogie kachin won against
akopian that was a big upset the top
seed yeah absolutely Ruth lost against
shabalo and kaidanov won against wolves
with the remaining game
Nima and Igor uh
exchange more but unfortunately it
there's just not enough material on the
board for white and after this move
rookie too we do have King
G1
okay that's
that's tricking King to G1
inviting rookchak huh
well first of all you can just go rookie
one followed by B1 and exactly go more
or less into the same end game yeah
we're I'm looking at rookie one check
King to F2
uh Queen
forcing the the Queen the newly crowned
queen to be captured I think there are
pigs
three check okay Knight H3 is the very
easy way out and after we capture this
we're in that Rook versus night uh table
base we know it's a draw but there are
ways of losing yes you can and lose
there is the possibility so the only
trick in the position is if you go King
G6 right no no you keep oh sorry you
know you you try to approach the pawn
with King G6 yeah
yeah King G6 immediately yes okay well
this is the only bathroom now I think I
can go King F3 and it's not that easy to
keep the pawn to take the pawn anymore
Knight E6 what
okay he's being fancy
Knight E6 that's a fancy move wow
uh okay not sure why you would do that
I'm sometimes I'm worried about fancy
moves when you have less than two SEC
two minutes on the clock precise night
yes
what exactly is that move do okay it
does cut the Rook
uh
so you want to maybe keep the Rook on
the board well first of all I'm going
King F1 right but after King F1 he wants
to play Rook C2
K-pop what
is being very fast wow uh that King F1
Rook season H2 no but King Rook C2
actually loses
because we may have there the The Mating
net or what is happening well Rook C2
you take only six and I have rookie one
but maybe Rook H2 is what he wants okay
yes okay he's being fancy
for no reason for no reason Rook H2 on
the board
and uh
as we watch the remaining game uh we
Christian with a guess Avi Mario uh
congratulations a very difficult game
you really had to work for uh the full
point and you know last year wasn't such
an easy start for you at the Juniors but
definitely it felt like you came
determined in this tournament yes the
thing with this tournament is whether
you come second or you come ten there's
just there's no difference at all like
from my point of view right you want to
win it yeah
absolutely well let's talk about your
first round game and again not an easy
opponent definitely you chose this
variation but it felt like he sort of
surprised you with this bishop to D7
yeah Bishop D7 I don't remember him
having any games on this but I think
that this position like it seems of
course like it everything is like very
very close to draw but it feels that
like when I have obstacle Bishops and if
I ever get e45 located in the game I
have some very serious winning chances
but of course there should be some way
not to allow this e45 you mean Indiana
game yes yes because yeah here I think
this king of Fate is kind of inaccurate
like a couple moves ago yes
because here I think black should go
Rook like Rook B4 yes and let's move in
the position now my now the idea is like
if I go Rook A4 you can go like Rook B3
okay and this is okay still close to
equal but I'd still prefer white right
because the thing is whenever I whenever
you take on C1 I'm essentially up by a
pawn because a A and C pawns you're not
going to ever promote them in E4 E5 like
like this is much more valuable makes
sense yeah Central uh majority and the
other good thing about White's position
is like of course it looks like you have
like all these terrible pieces on the
back rank but you have this neon Bishop
on C6 and Knight on C4 so despite the
limited material you are still feeling
quite comfortable with the position in
your advantage yes because I didn't see
a way for way for black to force a draw
and okay if you you have a game
but he defined as well he really
defended well and then yeah I think
that's King E2 is also nice because
originally after uh this whole position
it if black ever gets F5 Knight F6 he's
fine like for example after Rook D2 like
if you went F5 this is the first thing I
was calculating just because if this
works then okay black goes Knight F6 and
he covers E4 well I can still try a bit
but it's nothing much but I think I have
King C3 and the point is now wherever
you move like room B8 I have group D5
okay that makes sense now like we should
before I go King C2 G6 I have Rook D7
okay he doesn't have enough time to
cover everything he's just one move away
yeah
very nice
so he played Rook B8 now I think yeah
King E2 is a nice move because if I go
E4 if I go H3 you go Rook d8 I was also
the same game didn't seem so clear to me
because like okay E2 like take take
Knight F6 and now here maybe King C3
uh King E7 B4 the point is I was asking
like you're trying to ask where this
bishop is going if Bishop D6 E4 you win
a piece so Bishop B6 Bishop B6 and now I
thought this is probably a draw but okay
this bishop on B6 is kind of stuck maybe
I can try some G4 G5 somewhere but I
think this king E2 is much nicer because
I get control of the D file You're Still
The One having all the fun in the
position also what I think is what it
but I think he missed this Knight G4
Rook D2 this position it looks uh sorry
like a couple moves ago
yes because here actually Bishop takes
E3 is a very
very critical line to calculate
but here because Knight X3 Rook B3 is
fine so I go Rook
my plan was to go rookie too now okay
Bishop C5 rookies Checkmate and if he
goes Knight F2
like here King E3 brooksie for bidwin
but just but now like Knight D1 Knight
G4 this is very very it doesn't it
doesn't work but what's important is I
have King C3 look everything collapses
very nice yeah he does he doesn't have a
way to defend absolutely everything and
once again Bishop C5 okay yeah
very nice nice calculation
um but yeah this point I felt like this
position must be completely winning and
yeah that's how he assess it very nice
so okay that's confident but F5 is
probably too early like I was
there must be something better than this
because but I was worried that somewhere
if he goes 96 at the right time take on
E6 take on E6 then this pollen F4 will
get
let's see will be sort of weak because
somewhere like E7 Bishop H2 so I cannot
really freely go Knight C7 King C4 King
V5 as I would want to go yeah
so you played F5 you felt but yeah that
was Bishop D4 and all of a sudden okay
now 98 at this position is actually
quite interesting like it black is
probably making a draw but what's
important is like if he goes Knight C7
this is what I was I spent like 15
minutes in this position after instead
of when I was playing C6 and that I
calculated this to be winning the whole
point is I want to keep my king on say
A6 B7 and then okay and but there's also
one important thing that if he ever goes
H5 King G8 King H7 like I think H5 I
shouldn't beat with H4 okay because if I
don't do this he gets his King to if he
takes on F6 it's a draw because if the
it's the h8 squares right wrong color
right so you have H4 King G8 say like
King C4 A6
King C5 so what if he goes King H7 now
you give him a check now you can try
King H6 and try some stalemate things
but okay King B5 even if you give up the
a pawn somehow I'm not I'm not going to
play C7 I'll just bring my king over to
E8 take off seven that makes sense very
nice very nice and the point with this
bishop on D7 is okay your king will
never come in the game yeah and I have
this one with if black tries like H6 for
example
well like Knight C7 takes takes F6
I'm not sure how exactly you can make it
my turn but let's say H6 King C4 A6
I can go King C5
and what I'll keep repeating this
position if you have to a King G8
probably
tonight maybe yeah everything before
working but okay that's he's not
necessarily forced to do that but yeah
Bishop did I can always win with King D5
so yeah maybe this is also working okay
okay and the other thing is I can also
try like Bishop 5 Bishop D3 because some
of these lines I have to
well you have to be very careful that's
A5 right so that you can start going
King B5 King A6 that makes a lot of
sense very nice uh calculation there and
yeah now this end game it's probably a
draw it's still a draw but it's it's
very easy
and I think this was the critical
mistake because the point is I force him
to like I got this H4 at a very nice
moment because
uh H4 because if he had if you want H5 I
had Knight F4 and yeah I think it was
working out in my favor yeah and now
here all he needs is like all I need is
to bring my king on D6 and game is over
like this bishop d295 I got if I get
Knight A6 key 16 F7 it's resignable
because the issue is if you keep Bishop
on this A1 to H attack no I go King G7
king of seven King G7 take H6 yeah if
you keep issue on G5 I can go C7 King D6
kc6 yeah well not King C6 Bishop F4 but
I'll play King E7 I can even bring my
king to G7 shouldn't be lost and he
played Bishop D2 after that you got the
Knight C5 King C4 I'll be honor you
congratulations big victory for you your
Ambitions are pretty clear for this
tournament we'll see you in the rest of
your games thank you
well done Mishra well done indeed and
let's uh just take a look at all of our
final results okay to the honors let's
look at the girls junior standing so we
have Alice Lee Rochelle and Zoe tank all
having one point then Thai for the
fourth place are Karissa
and Rosa Atwell and then with zero
points we have very small Gracie
prasanna and Shreya mangalam and the
Juniors
the Juniors we have Brandon Mishra
Andrew Kirk and Arthur all type of first
type of six Jason I'm gonna have trouble
with about Balaji Balaji dagupati hey
thank you for that Justin Arthur Josiah
all a tied for six and in the seniors we
have three leaders yes we have Gregory
kaidanov Alex shabalov and Malik
satkachian all at one point then we have
Igor novikov Maxim kloogi Joel Benjamin
and Dmitry gorevich with half a point
and vladimira kopian Patrick wool and
Douglas Ruth with zero so far deem is
the one who is going to be complaining
about the One That Got Away uh he
thought he had it Dimitri but final
thoughts Christian well just an
incredible start of these three
tournaments a lot of decisive results a
lot of Fighting Chess and this is
exactly what we like to see here in St
Louis I mean I believe maybe we had five
out of five decisive results in the
junior so they're definitely showing
their metal in this one and I have to
say the seniors are not disappointing
and the girls are just out for blood so
definitely a lot of fighting exciting
just coming your way in the next nine
days here in St Louis yeah the national
championships brings out the best in the
players yes for the first broadcast it's
really great it was great thank you
everybody for joining us thank you for
sharing your day with us tell your
friends where you're hanging out and
we'll see you here same channel same
time tomorrow bye for now bye everyone
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited